I mean, it's obvious to me that Ben Ben Shapiro is manifestally
insane. Last night, he was gripping the microphone as he would
the neck of a black woman. >> What? That's maybe the most
insane open to an episode of a podcast I've ever heard in my
entire life. [laughter]
speaking of, we're going to get more into [music] this right-wing
Civil War stuff. Oh boy. What happened yesterday? There was Oh,
yesterday
Philip DeFranco
war getting worse by worse. >> That's how you know big
when Philip DeFranco starts covering something is a big deal.
All right, >> you're seeing this MAGA civil war getting
worse and worse, messier by the day with more big names jumping
in to fight. And while some on the right they've tried to dismiss
this as some sort of sideshow, this is so much bigger and more
important than they'll admit. And I mean there is a very real
fight over the future of MAGA and the right in general taking
place. They can try and act like this is some small little blip.
The the loud minority, but the numbers show that's a lie. And
while this has been brewing for a while and you it's the people
who surround Nick and or Richard that genuinely believe it. There's
no way you could possibly mean Richard Spencer there. Why would
you put Richard Spencer in the same sentence as Nick Fentes?
I That's crazy. That's crazy. And go back to my Monday and Tuesday
show as a deeper recap. The quick version is that recently things
kicked off because Tucker Carlson interviewed white nationalist
Nick Fuentes on a show last week and among a decent chunk of
the right that sparked some backlash because Tucker is seen even
though he's not with Fox News anymore as kind of this institution.
He has a huge platform. In the interview it was friendly and
Fuentes among other things talked at length about what he called
organized. And so a whole bunch of conservatives, most prominently
Ben Shapiro, [laughter] Mark Leven, and Ted Cruz, condemn,
>> hold on. Did I just hear Philip DeFranco say organized?
Did I just Holy sh That's actually insane, isn't it? I Yeah,
like just the fact that he said the words
is crazy,
dude. That's weird as gay. a lot on the right coming to their
defense, or at the very least Tucker's defense, arguing that
he was merely exercising his free speech and shouldn't be cancelled.
And well, now the latest high-profile pundit to make that argument
is Brett Cooper. And very notably, Brett is a former Daily Wire
host who was once dubbed the female Ben Shapiro before she left
and started her own show. >> They're doing >> uh
that had nothing to do with her working at the Daily Wire. That
has to do with her looking like Ben Shapiro in >> All of
this, they're freaking out because of how popular and impactful
Tucker is. Tucker right now is the number one podcaster in the
world. He is neck and neck with Joe Rogan as they ignore the
obvious shift in ideology and attitudes of their base because
you're so angry that the conservative bases attitudes are rapidly
changing that Nick Fuentes is getting national attention. And
unfortunately for you guys, yes, the attitudes are changing.
So again, it makes sense. >> And over the course of her
show, she took shots at several people including Mark Lean >> admirers,
Stalin admires haters, American haters, Church Hill haters. You're
the church who defends Church Hill like who as an American is
like never never impugill's honor. I don't think there's like
a problem with Church Hill. I don't really know a lot about him
other than he sort of unified Britain and was able to make Britain
like bold against it seems like a good person in history to me
at least. Right. But I I I don't know who's like freaking out
over Churchill Churchill haters. Churchill haters. Damn right.
We're going to cancel them and deplatform
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They're talking about the guy Tucker
hosted. Yeah. They're talking about the guy Tucker hosted, but
it's like such a Just call Just say Tucker Carlson. Don't talk
about like Church Hill haters.
There's only one >> Also, Republican Senator Lindsey Graham.
>> But if you ever run for office
as a Republican and you embrace this weird, we're going to beat
your brains out. >> As well as Republican Representative
Randy Fine. Tucker Carlson is the most dangerous anti-semite
in America. He has chosen to take on take on the mantle of leader
of a modernday hip. >> Dude, I know for a fact when Fentes
saw this, this is going to be her saying like, "Maybe you should
go back to Israel." He's going to do the same Tucker bit, right?
Do you remember the bit he did when Tucker said the thing at
Charlie Kirk's funeral? Charlie, he said like, "Uh, oh, people
sitting around in a room eating hummus in like Tel Aviv or some
shit." I feel like Nick Fentes is going to be like when when
Brett Cooper said, "Hey, Randy, fine. You disgusting. You disgusting
pig. Go back to Israel." When she said that, I was like, "Whoa,
whoa, Brett, that's a lot." Even for me, that's a Whoa. I feel
like I can see it in my head that it would have happened. Haven't
seen a clip, but I believe the clip is out there. Okay. And you
would Cooper going after all of them for pretty much the same
reason. Hypocrisy. >> This is just so incredibly hypocritical.
Like, haven't we all collectively sat on our shows, sat on X,
and talked about how dangerous it is and how irresponsible it
was for leftists to just call anybody they hate? It is the same
kind of inflammatory rhetoric that killed Charlie Kirk. >> And
then with all this, a comment that you made that probably got
some of the most attention was a comment about Randy Fine, who's
>> I mean, he obviously, I'm sorry to say, but he obviously
cares more about Israel than he does, you know, principles like
free speech. So, buddy, like my advice to you, Randy Fine, is
just move to Israel at this point. written that seeming to >> go
back to Israel, Randy. Fine.
You disgust it. >> I echo something that Fuentes said to
last week. >> If you're China first, you should live in
China. If you're Mexico first, you should live in Mexico. If
you're Israel first, maybe you should go live in >> Right.
It also appeared that Fuentes himself took her comments the same
way because he posted on X. Daily Wire alum Brett Cooper says
Randy Fine should move back to Israel because he cares more about
Israel than free speech. You're never going back to the way things
used to be. Enough is enough, America first. But then we also
heard a much different take on the fighting from Daily Wire host
Matt Walsh who blamed the Republicans and >> I don't think
I watched the entire Matt Walsh response. I might I I'll think
about checking this out. >> On Tuesday's elections on exactly
this kind of infighting. >> We've watched the uh right-wing
commentary
rip each other to shreds over offensive group chats and podcast
guests and and so on. Dude, I I feel like
this is probably correct, but I understand how like some of the
members of like conservative people would feel where like one
side is like awesome. And the other side's like, "That's pretty
bad to say." And then Matt Walsh is like, "Can you guys just
all stop fighting? I think he was inspirational. Uh that's a
disgusting comment. I think everybody's in the wrong here."
Just you understand that, right? It's like the Fuentes, right?
is like, you know, cool, man. And then Ben Shapiro is like, that's
gross. And Matt Walsh is like, everybody stop
trying to cut each other's throats right now. Can't we all get
along?
Right now, a lot of people are are kind of drawing lines on the
right. But here's the line that we really need. Conservatives
who have actually shown an ability to win and move the needle
culturally and politically on one side versus conservatives who
have never contributed meaningfully to any victory at all. And
after last night's elections, it's clear that we should just
not listen to those people ever again. In my view, the right
must unite against the people who want us dead. >> Though
then you had Fuentes responding to him saying, "Your fence sitting
has grown tiresome." With him then going on to post about what
he called lunatic Israel for. [laughter]
>> Your your fence sitting has grown tiresome,
Matt Walsh.
Condemn Israel now >> Jews and he's just going from one
master to the other. Ben Shapiro's handing the whip over to Nick
Fentes.
Hey Matt Walsh, why don't you condemn Israel right now? Ethnoarcistic
bullies, right? Despite calls for Walsh and a few others for
unity, that really doesn't seem to be what's happening. At least
not at the Heritage Foundation, right? Cuz one of the biggest
things that catalyzed this civil war was a video statement that
its president Kevin Roberts put out last week. >> We will
always defend truth. We will always defend America and we will
always >> This is actually a good little segment from Philip
DeFranco. I didn't realize he went this deep. I just was going
to show like Philly D. Philly D's decided to cover this and that's
pretty interesting. Shows the cultural impact it's having. >> Defend
our friends against the slander of bad actors who serve someone
else's agenda. That includes Tucker Carlson. >> Right in
that it shocked a number on the right to see the head of mainstream
American conservatism's most prestigious think tank throwing
its support behind Carlson here. And then actually on Monday
night, Roberts partly apologized during a speech at Hillsdale
College. A few days ago,
I posted a video truly with the best of intentions. But I have
to tell you to the students
that this old history professor made a mistake. And my mistake
was not saying we aren't going to participate in cancel culture.
We're not. My mistake was letting that, which we will never backtrack
from, override the central motivation that I had in doing that.
There's one of those ideas ideas that really worries me.
It's an idea that has become cache
not just on the left
but on the far fringes. I just does anybody find it weird that
this guy's like I understand that it's weird that he sounds like
a hostage and all that. It's just clearly not his personal opinion,
right? like his personal opinion didn't conflict with the statement
he gave and then he had to have his personal his new personal
opinion beaten into his skull, his stupid bold skull, right?
Like this is a total 180 on everything he was saying before.
He couldn't just he's like giving his he gave his opinion and
maybe he you know maybe internally he was like more condemning
of Fuentes or maybe not but he just like he clearly had this
this new opinion that he had to come and say publicly. He had
it like beaten into his stupid bald skull and it just makes it
seem weird to me >> of the right
and that's anti-semitism. >> But then Roberts also apologizing
again personally to his own staff yesterday reportedly saying
I made a mistake and I let you down and I let down this institution.
Period. Full stop. And then adding that he was willing to resign
but saying that he felt a moral obligation to like I don't know
if I could explain it in any simpler terms. Trump has spent the
past eight years in American politics
screaming at the top of his lungs that America is being sold
out to foreign countries. America is totally up by not prioritizing
themselves. America is totally because they're going to send
taxes to a bunch of other countries all over the world. How in
the world did people support this and never think that that rhetoric
was going to affect support for Israel?
How?
Right. That's why. And now Fuentes has this huge platform and
he goes, "Yeah, obviously this applies to Israel. This exact
principle, everything Trump ran on, it all applies to Israel.
And it's crazy that all these people get paid by Israel and they
won't tell you that. They won't they won't tell you the truth."
Right?
And now he's got a big enough platform that you can't try to
make it about something else. They're desperately trying to make
it about anything else. Right? Talk about how he likes how he's
talked about Talk about how he's denigrated women. talk about
how he talk about all of his other things, right? But never address
the core argument, which is, hey, every principle Trump's ever
espoused cuts against Israel harder than any other country. So
what the [__] are we doing here? If it's America
first, then that means America before
Like obviously that is the principle and the rightwing just has
been ignoring it for I don't know what I guess it's been nine
years now, almost 10 years basically, right? So basically 10
years the rightwing's been ignoring this
And now somebody with a big enough voice is saying, "No, you
you've been ignoring this. Stop ignoring it." So I think I think
it's pretty goofy that there are a lot of, you know, Israel first
type people who are like, "Oh my god, I can't believe this is
happening. Oh my god, I can't believe how did this happen? I
thought we had principles." No, you didn't.
No, no, you didn't. Or you're stupid.
You either understood you didn't have principles or you're stupid.
I'm not sure which. But clean up the mess he created himself,
though. None of that appears to have been enough to prevent this
rift from tearing part of the organization apart because you
have the Washington Post reporting that at least five members
of its anti-semitism task force have now resigned in protest.
Distinguished fellow Chris Demouth has left and there was another
fellow Amy Swearer who reportedly told Roberts to his face that
his handling of the controversy was quote a masterclass in cowardice
that ran cover for the most unhinged dregs of the far right.
for this also as others at Heritage felt differently with one
person for example at the meeting reportedly asking what would
happen to those who agreed with Roberts and Carlson and another
comparing staffers who spoke with reporters to Judas. Even Roberts's
own speech writer Evan Meyers reportedly suggested that Heritage's
attempts to address accusations of anti-semitism would eventually
mean he'd be required to attend Shabbat [laughter] dinner which
he said would conflict with his faith which another executive
that guy the speech writer is like a hardcore anti-semite. I
think I I think why would you even know what like a Shabbat dinner
would mean or how it interacts with your faith in a particular
way.
I I I
feel like somehow in my head I can just see that guy being like
he's like I can't be I can't be the Shabascoy. I can't I it's
it would be terrible.
That's that's all I hear from that guy. eventually mean he'd
be required to attend Shabbat dinner, which he said would conflict
with his fate, which another executive report
could not see that as a generous offer, but rather a personal
attack on you. So, clearly, [laughter] >> okay, never mind.
The Heritage guy said the same thing. >> I'm deeply sorry
that you could not see that as a generous offer, but rather a
personal attack on you. Filthy executive invited me to Shabbat
dinner.
So, clearly there's a lot happening and we're going to have to
see what happens with Robert's leadership there. But also uh
amidst the fighting, we got to hear from Carlson himself because
he went on Dave Smith's show and explained that he initially
had reservations about >> Oh, we didn't watch this one.
Dave Tucker on Dave Smith might be worth watching. I'm not totally
sure. >> For one, agent attacked my family, my father,
my wife, one of my children by name. For another, as I've said
a million times, I thought he was a fed. I did suspect that.
Um I don't know if that's true or not. I raised that with him.
But basically, in the end, I decided Nick Fuentes can't be cancelled.
They've been trying since he was a freshman in college. It doesn't
work. In fact, he's gotten bigger. He is enormously talented.
Anyone who denies that is lying. And he has like a semico, not
fully coherent, but a semicoherent kind of position. And I would
like to hear what it is because that's kind of my job. And and
I'm also interested cuz he's the most influential voice for men
under 30 in the United States. So then with all that you have
people like
>> dude
uh you know who used to be the most influential voice for men
under 30 in the United States
I think was like one of the big ones. I can't believe that people
have been hounding that guy so hard and Fentes just crept in
and is now massive.
It feels uh feels like why why was nobody ringing the alarm bell
on this that like hey Fentes is totally popping off right now.
Maybe you shouldn't be focused on Hassan for his like kind of
vaguely defensible statements about terrorism. There there are
a couple that are really bad. The the stuff with the kidnapped
who the kidnapped sailors was really bad, but like he's had some
other statements that people freak out about that are a little
that are more defensible, right? And people just been focused
on this guy. Well, well, other people who can see stuff on the
internet are going, "Hey, this Fenttos guy seems a little concerning.
Maybe you should be doing some like maybe you should be raising
some awareness about this guy." like Ben Shapiro, the National
Review, and the Wall Street Journal counter the fact that he's
just >> I know a lot of people think Assan was only popular
with women. That's not >> An innocent journalist doing
his job and hearing people out. It doesn't hold up to scrutiny
with him arguing that he barely challenged Fuentes at all. He
never brought up his worst comments and just let him say things
like, >> "We do on some level need to be pro-like >> without
any objection whatsoever." And that is it's very clear that Tucker
is more willing to grill the absolute out of a guest if he wants
to, like he did with Ted Cruz. You're a senator who's calling
for the [laughter] throw in the government. YOU'RE THE ONE WHO
ABOUT THE >> So from that you had the National Review concluding
why would Carlson choose to take an oppositional attack to a
senator who has been fighting for conservatism for decades but
not to a podcaster who praises Stalin? The obvious because the
podcaster who praises Stalin was like literally not making any
of his usual points on that podcast except like I'm a fan of
Stalin. And Tucker said well we might have to come back to that.
He was like I don't that's crazy. Yeah, I don't we'll have to
come back to that. Right. >> Answer is that Fuentes is
an avowed while Cruz is a staunch supporter of Israel. And then
with everything that's happening, you did have Carlson kind of
saying that it it >> Wait, Steven Jian, you know what America
deserve 911 means, right? Do you understand what it means? Or
do you get really soy about like thinking about how Assan wanted
innocent civilians to die in the two in the Twin Towers?
What do you what do you think it meant? cuz it's it's like there's
a purpose to it to saying that, right? Like do you do do you
understand the abstraction that he is pointing at there? Twin
towers. Yeah, my bad. Listen, those those towers been gone a
long time. I don't remember them that well. Okay, I forgot. I
It just hits hard. Okay, fair enough. >> It all appears
to be about Israel and the future of the GOP. >> This is
a fight over what happens after Donald Trump. What does the Republican
party look like? What happens after Trump goes? And that's what
this is about. That's why they're vesting the energy in this.
That's what the rage is about because they don't want to lose
control of foreign policy. I just can't say that enough. It's
about foreign policy. They don't care about domestic choose.
Choose choose. Choose choose. Now I understand what Alice Jones
was going at. Okay? That's when when he says it's about foreign
policy.
It's only about foreign policy. That's the only thing they care
about. That's what he's saying. Okay? He's just screaming into
his mic, choose, choose, choose.
That's what Tucker's saying. Okay. They don't care about the
United States. But also with that, you have people who argue
that the civil war, it's at least as much about anti-semitism
as it is about Israel. For example, Jamie Kerjik saying in the
Washington Post, "This episode has forced an overdue reckoning
on the American right. For far too long, the problem of anti-semitism
has been allowed to fester there because too many conservatives
have been reluctant to >> Wait, who said this? Who said
this?
Wait, who? Hold on." The problem of this episode about anti-semitism
as it is about Israel. For example, Jamie Kerjik saying in the
>> Jamie Kerjik, >> Washington Post, "This episode
has forced an overdue reckoning on the American right. For far
too long, the problem of anti-semitism has been allowed to fester
there because I feel like right-wing anti-semitism has been thoroughly
deplatformed for like a decade and only became like slightly
a problem within the past year, maybe year and a half." like
it was it was basically just one or two groups that had this
like this coded anti-semitic outlook, right? And I don't I don't
think this is true. I think this person is themselves pushing
a narrative. Too many conservatives have been reluctant to speak
out against its chief propagator. Finally, its battle lines are
being drawn. But ultimately, that's where we are for now. Though
we're going to see more, right there, there appears to be no
shortage of creators out there and even politicians throwing
haymakers. while we wait to see what happens next. I'd really
love to know your thoughts, opinions, and reactions here. But
then, okay, so from there, we're going to go I've got uh I've
got this article which is sort of it's getting close to a distillation
of my thoughts on this topic. It's from 2 days ago, right? Richard
Hania, grapers are just more honest mas. Why Fentes has already
won. And this is going to be the exact point which is, hey, Fentes
is just pointing out that there's been a massive hypocrisy in
the GOP, right? There's been a massive hypocrisy that nobody's
wanted to point out that if you pointed it out without doing
it in exactly the right way, you could just get cancelled and
everybody's too scared to make the comment for a long time.
But it is way more consistent. Being anti-Zionist
is way more consistent with Republican thinking than anything
else. It makes absolutely no sense that this parties that party
that is so thoroughly against Ukraine could be in support of
Israel. It it is a total it is a like cataclysmic contradiction.
Okay. And I I think this gets close to a distillation of how
I feel about it. I don't agree with the points that Hania lays
out. I think this is where he is the five-point list. Yes. So,
I don't agree with the points of the five-point list quite as
they're voiced, as they're written. But it is essentially like
in essence spiritually the exact thinking I had when I was like,
"Oh, Fentes is gonna if Fentes ever gets undeplatformed, okay,
it's over for people. They don't realize it yet. This guy's like
a sleeping giant." Okay, I used to tell people this all the time
and they go, "No, you can't say you like and then be big." And
I'm like, "Just wait. It's going to happen. It's going to happen."
I swear to God, I used to be like a like a schizophrenic homeless
person. like announcing that like the Doom was coming to a lot
of people. I talked to politics about uh like I talked to them
about politics. I'd just be like, "Yeah, this is uh this Fuentes
guy. He's going to be huge. You don't realize it yet, but he
has all the right talking points. He is so good. He is so good
at like tapping into the populous part of the brain. There's
nobody better. It's terrifying to me. He's going to be huge.
Used to be. Yeah, used to be. We're still here. We just seem
slightly less." Listen, somebody gave us a job and cleaned us
up. Okay.
Anyway, there's a quote from one of Lincoln's letters in 198
in 1855 that perfectly sums up how I feel when thinking about
the current conservative movement and the challenge from gropers.
As a nation, we began by declaring that all men are created equal.
We now practically read it all men are created equal except
necros. When you when the no nothings get control, it will read
all men are created equal except and foreigners and Catholics.
when it comes to this I should prefer immigrating to some country
where they make no pretense of loving liberty loving liberty
to Russia for instance where desperatism can be taken pure and
without the base uh base alloy of hypocrisy so this is you can't
have a party that is running on make America great again America
first and then have this this actual like fusion of beliefs that
are hypocritical doesn't make any sense it's crazy okay
so when I say the right is being gropered Some respond that not
many people have heard of Nick Fentes. This kind of this is kind
of like saying that Republicans aren't a low tax party because
nobody knows who Grover Grover Norquist is. Obviously, people
can have major impacts on political movements without being household
names. Oh, does he get into does he get into the mind control
bit? Oh, maybe he will. There's no way Hania could be that base.
There's no way Hanania is like one of you guys, right? Is Hania
just a perpetual viewer? I think the revolution has already happened
with national conservative ideology and MAGA only adding to groperism,
the base alloy of hypocrisy. To see why, we can just look at
what groperization essentially means. I'd argue it has the following
five elements. A strong white identity and focus on whites being
oppressed, which in terms of policy manifests itself mainly in
preference for reducing immigration so whites can maintain demographic
dominance.
Um, I think this is a part of manga. I think they say America,
right? They say American
but there there are elements of this. It's like it's not quite
that strong.
I I think this is maybe the weakest part of the points to be
honest. But Fuentes says this, right? He he announces it clearly
doesn't put into practice with the diversity that that that movement
enjoys. All right. Two, a belief that policy and culture should
be understood through the lens of a zero- sum competition between
Americans and foreigners, whites and non-whites, Christians and
non-Christians. This is the case in both in terms of public recogn
rec recognition and the struggle for tangible resources. This
is America first. Yes, there is a hierarchy of Americanness in
which people are ranked according to race, adherence to Christianity,
and how long their ancestors have been in the country. Again,
um I don't know if this is actually true. Again, Fentes is the
example. Like he's got parents from
I don't know. like they're I think he's what a third generation
immigrant.
But it it doesn't matter too much. I'd say this is like directionally
correct. All of these are directionally correct. Even if I have
like qualms, like minor minor nitpicks about them, they're they're
directionally correct at
Uh a communication style and aesthetic that centers around shock
value, giving the middle finger to PC, and taking base positions
on identity issues. Yes. Yeah. This is this is absolutely true,
right? the idea that like it can be it can be almost so funny
to say something untrue and and like take a position that is
untrue that you you don't really care about telling the truth
anymore. Just give me something that's funny. I don't care.
A dislike of power. Number five, a dislike of power and influence
manifesting itself most clearly in wanting to end the US special
relationship with Israel. So,
I don't think this has ever been a part of manga. I totally disagree
that this is a part of manga at all. I I totally I might even
totally disagree that this is part of the national conservative
ideology.
Fuentes has almost entirely pushed this. This it was it was entirely
absent for Trump's first term, his entire first term. And Fuentes
himself has been pushing this for like 8 years, right? Sorry,
10 years.
So I I disagree that this is a part of it.
Oh, never mind. Mainstream manga has already adopted one to four.
These are also part of the worldview of what are called the dissident
right or national conservatism with broadly defined race being
an arguable sticking point. Only five is left to fight about.
Yes. Okay, never mind. That's the whole point of the article.
Let's go. Let's go.
That is the whole point. On immigration, the watershed moment
came in 2019 when Charlie Kirk changed his position on the issue
in response to pressure from Fuentes and his fans. Although practically
everyone on the right already opposed illegal immigration, until
that point, supporting legal, especially high-skilled immigration
was a popular conservative position, while white nationalists
and nivists just wanted fewer people coming in. Over the last
few years, the nivist position has triumphed among right-leaning
intellectuals and influencers.
Okay.
Not only do most mainstream conservatives with national ambitions
oppose more legal immigration, they make nivist rhetoric central
to the worldview they pitch to voters. When Vance was asked by
Ross Du thought about his economic vision, the two problems that
he pointed to were much were pointed to too much
sorry were too much trade and immigration. As I pointed out,
that makes no sense when placed alongside his support for AI
and automation and his positions on trade and immigration should
therefore be understood as reflecting identitarian signaling
rather than a coherent economic vision. When discussing why housing
prices are high, the vice president similarly goes straight to
competition with newcomers, showing no interest in the serious
work that has been done on the issue. Ronda Santis, meanwhile,
has decided to put his newfound opposition to H-1B visas central
to his attempts to say stay relevant as a potential presidential
candidate. It's Randy Fine.
Now, if you ask Fentes why he wants less immigration, he'll say
it's because he thinks America should be a white country. JD
Vance and Ronda Santis, like Charlie Kirk before he died, will
always deny racist motivations and go but go out of their way
to blame immigration for all problems that the country faces,
cherrypick whatever evidence they can find to make that case
and prioritize keeping people out. There is a reason that white
nationalists once consider Republicans to be part of an establishment
duopoly they were opposed to and now have become cheerleaders
for in the in the Trump era GOP. People can oppose some forms
of immigration for nonidentitarian reasons, but given that all
given that the stated reasons for making restrictionism a priority
centering around crime and economic harms are simply not true,
especially for tech workers, the motivation is clearly something
else. Gropers are just more honest about what is going on here.
you'd say this. I think there's just been mass layoffs in the
tech scene and I think there's no reason you can justify for
H1Bs
unless it's like cost uh cost controlling.
Do you hear how Templar talked on you? Uh yeah, I watched the
clip. Was he
He just said a lot of the criticism against him comes from like
people who used to be in the Destiny community and then he referenced
me, but I didn't hear him say something bad about me even specifically.
Although I guess just being from the Destiny community could
be. But is he not just correct? Queen
I'm guessing Becket could have Becka easily could have been a
big part of the Destiny community. I don't know if he was for
sure or not, but Queen and Deckers definitely were.
So I don't even think that's incorrect. Did Did anybody like
actually talk on that? Uh Aiden totally is. Chud is. Yeah. Like
that's just objectively true. If you want to fight that, you're
just kind of like coping. Totally.
No, I Is there somebody that that's not the case for?
Maybe I I might have to watch the clip again. Maybe he said something
different. Okay, so although totally different in reality, Fentes
and mainstream Republicans are not that far apart on identity
issues.
Vance, for example, has said that Americans whose ancestors fought
in the Civil War have more of a claim to the country than their
political opponents. Senator Eric Schmidt just gave a speech
that in effect endorsed an ethnic conception of the nation. Josh
Holly, meanwhile, calls himself a Christian nationalist, which
makes it difficult to oppose the Groper view with that faiths
are that other faiths are less welcome. And Congressman Randy
Fine just announced anti-semitism and advocated for Zoramani
to be deported to the exact in the exact same speech before the
Republican coalition. What would he apparently like? What he
would apparently like is a country that says some American citizens
belong based on their religion and others don't. Differing with
gropers only in that he wants place in the inner circle. I will
cope on Quean being in Chinese community. Queen was a massive
Destiny fan. Queen watched like every stream for
I don't know. It's like not bad. Eventually he realized this
guy's a total psychopath and left and then blessedly started
making content explaining that Destiny's a total psychopath.
Yeah. Oh, we've got a lot of copers here. There's many many copers.
Queen was a prolific DJer.
He was he was doing a lot of stuff. It's fine. Not as not as
much as I was, not as recently as I was. If that's how you want
to differentiate.
I just don't see it as like a huge criticism of him. I like I'm
sorry if you're in this space. If you're in this space and you've
come from like Chud or Queen or me or like any of these any of
these audiences, you were probably a big part of those communities
as well,
right? Pretending a lot of us watch didn't watch. Yeah, I I just
don't It's like a weird thing to cope about to be honest. I'm
not on him for being a DJ. I just don't think it's a big deal.
If other if other people think it's a big deal, it's whatever.
It's fine. You can think it's a big deal. I just don't. Uh anyway,
point is so this is the last thing was basically saying that
um mainstream Republicans have embraced some like ethnationalism,
some like some conception of their race making them better than
other Americans, some conception of how long they've been in
the country making them better than other Americans, some conception
of their religion making them some in some way better than other
Americans. Fuentes, willing to say the word white, while normal
GOP politicians won't, is more of an issue of branding than anything
else. You could say Fuentes is more inclusive than Vance since
whiteness includes people like Slavs. Quentes would deny this.
Hence, placing those who were in here in the 19th century at
the top in the hierarchy reflects a much narrower vision. I actually
disagree. I think um
this might be this might just be
Hania not understanding. Um this is not true though. Fentes explicitly
excludes Slavs and explicitly says founding stock and all of
that. So the Fentes Vance overlap there is nearly one to one.
I think that's um him just not knowing that which will happen
at times. Okay. Meanwhile, in foreign affairs, we observe the
conservative movement adopting priorities that only make sense
from an ethnationalist perspective. See the deep concern with
immigration to Europe? If that is if that is about maintaining
Western civilization rather than race, what are we to make of
the Trump administration cutting refugee numbers from 125,000
to 7,500 with most bots going to white South Africans? This is
exactly what you would get if the refugee policy was rewritten
by gropers in the federal bureaucracy, which it may well have
been given what we know about the views of staffers in the Trump
administration. One might argue that the ideology of MAGA is
just as much multinational nivism as white nationalism. There
is something to say to this as immigration restrictions, for
example, are justified as protecting the jobs of all Americans
rather than those of a specific skin color. I think the way to
understand mainstream MAGA is that it creates a hierarchy of
concern and legitimacy with whites outranking non-whites, Christians
outranking non-Christians, and the native born outranking the
foreignb born regardless of legality or naturalization status.
Here you can make an analogy to wokeness, which gives individuals
oppression points based on on various traits. This creates certain
tensions like whether you should listen more to the opinion of
a white lesbian or a straight black male. Likewise, under mainstream
manga,
the Myron Gains hypothetical. Damn. Wait, sorry, straight. Never
mind. Not the Myer Gains hypothetical. My bad. Likewise, under
mainstream manga, a Hispanic individual born in the US is more
a part of the community than one born abroad, even if naturalized,
but a white person whose ancestors may have been in the country
for hundreds of years is valued more highly than both. Maybe
there's a controversy over who is more credible as a nationalist,
say a native born Hispanic or a new migrant from the UK. This
is why among foreigners, white South Africans get priority. Just
as with wokeness, sometimes the hierarchies are intention. And
what you're essentially doing in each case is ranking individuals
according to identity based characteristics and then working
out the details. Nationalism based on religion and ethnicity
is particularly pernicious in America. Some nations like Japan
and Hungary are still at the point in their history where they
can maintain an overwhelming majority for their ethnic core.
In the US, non-Hispanic whites are already a minority of children.
Only about 60% identify as Christian. We're facing an ideology
that says maybe a third of the population are true Americans
and everyone else has a second or third tier status and you potentially
kill what actually makes the US great which is not how many of
your papies or grandappies are buried in the same place but liberal
values which includes openness to immigration. I think you can
make the tiered thing work. I think the tiered thing is anti-American
but I I think trying to focus on the tiered thing is like a hypocrisy
is not cool and is not like going to actually break through with
anybody. a lot of people that that this is the entire purpose
of like looking at that guy, the clearly Mexican dude with the
goofy ears in the America first hat. They're totally comfortable
with a hierarchy just as long as they enter the hierarchy and
can climb it like and that their family would be able to climb
it. The hypothetical of them being third tier Americans does
not actually scare people.
You you might think it scares people, but there are a lot of
people who say, "No, I'd be a third tier
And there's like something to the core of Americans going, "Yeah,
you're just coming here. You like join a lower rung of the hierarchy
that they would actually like."
So, I don't know. I I really don't think that that's actually
that big a deal to people.
Potentially what makes the US great, which is openness to immigration.
The US has left other rich industries in the dust on the back
of success of it. On the back of the successes of its tech industry,
which draws talent from all over the world, the back of the success
of its tech industry. Yes. The nivists want to make us like every
other country, forgetting what most that most countries contribute
nothing distinctive to humanity. If they win, we'll get slower
the slower growth in civil strife that is normal without even
the consolation of a common culture since we're already too diverse
in terms of race, ethnicity, religion, and values to create the
kind of homogeneous society that they want. Note how when a non-white
American citizen who is of recent immigrant status becomes prominent
on the other side, Writers will start advocating that they be
kicked out of the country. We're not talking about only fringe
figures doing this. Ilan Omar became a US citizen at 17 years
old. Calling for her deportation is now a normal part of right-wing
decor discourse. Sorry, I'm like not focused right now. Coming
not just from the frog accounts on X, but also Rhonda Santis
and sitting members of Congress with one of them asking people
to sign a one of them asking people to sign a petition to expel
her in a fundraising letter. As mentioned, there's been similar
attacks on Zora Mandani. Remember that Trump initially emerged
as a major player in Republican politics by being the most prominent
figure willing to embrace the birther conspiracy theory about
Obama. Whether anyone on the right actually believes the naturalization
is possible or that Obama was born in Kenya isn't the point.
Rather, the culture of the right revolves around signaling the
idea that non-whites and recent arrivals are less American than
white conservatives. Almost all Republicans will officially denounce
racism. Fuentes likewise sometimes adopts more moderate language
along with claiming that America is a white nation. He has also
said that if you were born in this country, it is your birthright
and he will ally with you so long as you're America first. So
sometimes he speaks in racial terms and at other times he points
uh at other points he endorses colorblind nationalism. This is
not much different from Vance who likes to pull out the ancestor
card in the same way a black woman might at the height of the
great awakening. Maybe Fuentes talks about race 80% of the time
and endorses colorblind nationalism 20% of the time, but and
the proportion is flipped for Vance. But both agree that time
in the country, religious background, and ancestry all matter,
and that sometime some have much more of a claim to America than
others on that basis. It's pretty thing cruel to put so much
stock in the fact that Vance just doesn't say the word white.
how much longer? Oh, this article is quite a bit longer. Dang.
We're going to get through it. We're going to read the whole
thing. Okay. Jeez, we're still going. Oh man,
there we go. Of course, this doesn't mean 100% of Republican
politicians are on board with the vision. Vivcram Vivvec Vive
Vive even Vive Ramaswami is likely to be the Republican nominee
for governor of Ohio. What?
Really?
Why?
That's goofy as. And he speaks out against racism and doesn't
prioritize demonizing legal immigrants. But just because you
can find Republican politicians who are pro-choice doesn't mean
that as a party it doesn't oppose abortion rights. One has to
bend the knee to proifers to some extent if you have national
ambitions. And the same is true now for white nationalists, especially
when it comes to their ideas about immigration and identity.
This is true even at the state level and among members of Congress.
You still see some who take a position contrary to the dominant
trend in the party. Vance is still unique among Republican politicians
to the extent to which he stresses identitarian concerns. But
he's written this ideology all the way to the vice presidency.
And all the momentum is with people who talk similarly and have
the same worldview based on white grievance and anti-forigner
demagoguery.
He won't win. They won't vote for him. Um they might vote for
him in Ohio.
Uh, do you think the rebel do you think the Democratic party
has the balls to just go if they run vague Ramaswami, we're only
running a white male?
Do they have the balls to meet identity politics with identity
politics?
I'm telling you, the Democrats don't understand the power they
have that Republicans to some extent are still like reeling from
the cultural losses in the mid2010s, late 2010s, and they try
to run like different candidates. If you just run white dudes
against them, you will literally grab like a bunch of
Like, I'm sorry. You will just grab a bunch of racist misogynist
voters. It's just facts. They already have poll with them. That's
goofy. That's crazy. Stylistically and in terms of aesthetics,
the conservative movement has likewise moved towards groperedom.
Regarding number four from the list, this is just the based ritual,
which has become the default way of communicating among conservatives.
see Matt Walsh denouncing the idea that anyone would ever punch
right by criticizing those who say things. Gropers are simply
a more extreme version of this. And one key to Quentes's success
is that he says on live stream what a lot of young writers only
say in group chats. Again, we're only talking about a matter
of degrees. That leaves the question. Ha, we no longer see debates
between gropers and more mainstream figures on immigration or
national identity because the Gropers have won. Ah, this this
reminds me, this is a self-similar thing. This is a very very
similar phenomenon to when Destiny got fooled. Okay, I used to
be a Destiny fan. I admit it. And he got fooled by Nick Fentes
cuz he used to say the Gropers don't really talk about anti-semitism
anymore.
The way I the way I tried to explain that to people was like,
"Yeah, they don't talk about that anymore cuz it's settled."
Like you shouldn't take the lack of bringing that up as a debate
internally. You shouldn't take that as like they no longer care
about it. You should take that as actually that question is just
answered.
They don't have any there's no contention. So the question's
answered. They all hate Jews. That's why they don't talk about
there's just no reason talking about people uh in the early 2010s,
mid2010s, even late 2010s had major penalties. Saying saying
anti-semitic had major penalties. So why would they do it when
they all agreed?
They just don't have to.
Vance has basically adopted every substantive idea and aesthetic
preference with regards to the issues being pushed by white nationalists
short of denouncing his own family. The same is true for opposition
to DEI and affirmative action, which also used to be an issue
that distinguished white identitarians, but now is so baked into
Republican politics that you can't even list it as a feature
of groperism.
That's why the focus has moved to Israel. Nearly every ambitious
Republican politician and right-wing influencer thinks whites
are oppressed and immigration should be significantly reduced
if not ended. and that is to that is that it is wrong to ever
denounce anyone on their side for racism or but the Jews remain
the final boss of Republican establishment taboos. The Trump
administration is of course pro-Israel
and has even created a moral panic backed by federal power on
the topic of anti-semitism. But things are shifting the direction
of the gripers with young Republicans more likely to be anti-Israel
and adopt anti-semitic attitudes and a major right-wing and major
right-wing influencers sounding more and more like Fentes.
Unlike with immigration, there is more push back here from GOP
donors. So, the ultimate groper victory is taking longer. But
the trends are unmistakable.
There's a subtext to debates about Israel, which is whether over
whether should be treated or be considered true Americans. People
like Tucker say they want Israel to be treated like every other
country. Yet, when it comes to Europeans facing threats from
Islamic radicals or even Muslim economic immigrants, the American
right is overwhelmingly on the side of the white Christians.
This is why they spend a lot of time talking about topics like
Pakistani grooming gangs in the UK which resemble their obsession
with white South Africans. An anti-globalist movement suddenly
starts closely closely following international news when there
is a dispute between white white Christians on one side and blacks
or Muslims on the other. That's true. Oh, hold on. Let me check
chat real quick. Koko, you should reevaluate the things you say.
You shouldn't say really silly things in the chat and then I
was going to like answer this is I should probably not I've answered
this like a bunch of times. This is a really silly thing to say.
Uh, mas look at this and wonder why Israel doesn't get similar
sympathy. Nobody on the right says don't talk about UK grooming
gangs because you have to be America first. Why is Israel's war
Because America doesn't send financial support to the UK to deal
with grooming gangs is the obvious reason. First, Hania L. Why
is he This is a stupid comparison.
Unless he has some other argument here, right? But this this
seems like a completely stupid comparison. Why is Israel's war
A liberal might say that Israel has too many civilians for it
to deserve sympathy. But even if that was true, the idea that
the right at this point in history cares about the human rights
of Palestinians is a joke and misunderstands everything that's
been happening over the last several years. When Tucker says
Israel should be treated like every other country, then he means
every other non-white country. They don't get the presumption
from the MAGA coalition of always being the victims in disputes
occurring overseas in the same way white that white Christians
do. Again, this is like there's this like convenient misunderstanding
that happens sometimes. It's always a little little dicey. Give
me one second. I got a quick meme here.
Hold on real quick meme.
Oh yeah, real quick me. We're on uh we're on we're going to start
talking just right after this after we finish this article. We're
going to talk about Tucker, Ben Shapiro, Nick Fuentes, and then
the Megan Kelly appearances by both Tucker yesterday and then
Ben Shapiro today. All right, these are really good, but it's
it's kind of pushing towards people are going to encourage Ben
to go debate Nick Fentes. And we of course remember when Nick
tried to find Ben for a debate. Okay, >> cruise down this
side of the street. >> Give me a second.
>> He is close. He is near though. That is That is true.
There he is. Yep. Hey, Ben. You thought you could get away from
me the first time, huh? Without debating me.
>> I just want to talk. Please stop
I'm not a threat to you.
Look, here I am. I showed up and I just want to talk about ideas.
Okay? You're the one that loves the marketplace of ideas so much.
Just talk to me. >> You make me want to.
Hey, you
really >> that was uh >> You know what? You should
see a knock. >> I don't know if that was obl.
>> When I say you suck, I mean you really
>> Get back here, bro.
Ben Shapi, bro. Get back here. >> You define everything
that's wrong in this place.
>> You're really making my skin crawl.
>> What exactly is wrong?
No [__] >> Okay, I'm back.
Anyway, so this is this is a whole clip. I I might start
I might watch it a little bit more after, but I I had to go to
the bathroom. Jesus, I shrank a whole thing of tea and like
a whole liter of water. Two liters of water. Trying to get rid
of like I have like a sore throat right now.
Jesus. Okay, back to this. Keep keep reading. We'll finish this
article and then we're going to go into the Megan Kelly stuff.
So, give me two seconds. Okay, this is implications. So this
is all a paragraph about how oh I had a point here. So
he's saying that Americans
seemingly being white should get some kind of consideration and
prioritization because they're fighting with a group like a a
brown ethnic group, right? And this signals that MAGA or America
first like hate for Israel.
I I don't know if I agree with that. I think it is the funding
thing. I think that's mostly what it is. Um because they they
don't support the Ukraine war either, right?
That seems pretty obvious.
Uh oh, and so this there was one other part here about JD Vance
and his wife. And I was thinking that like the name America First
and sort of the things it pushes for in a lot of ways works like
JD Vance's wife. It's like you have an entire movement that's
based on racism and then you have an Indian wife versus Nick
is like has an entire movement about undoing like core American
values for a long time and then it's called America first. It
is like this concept of national socialism, right? We're going
to adopt an identity, a name that sort of shields us from our
primary like a a thinly veiled like mirage that protects us and
it's going to be
it's just going to be to deflect criticism on a certain thing.
Hey, don't you like kind of totally want to destroy the Constitution?
No, we're we're America first, man. We just want America to be
better. It's like, but wait, aren't you like kind of against
the founding values of America?
No, we're America first. Didn't you hear the name?
It's like it's a very similar thing I see going on. It's like
it I don't know. I don't know how to explain it.
Anyway, so this whole idea that we just read about this is implications
for how are thought of within the United States.
Whatever one believes about the war in Gaza, the focus on Israel
coming from people like Tucker and Fentes is part of a broader
effort to de delegitimize the idea that have equal status to
that of white Christians within the within the United States.
Randy Fine kind of gets this, which is why he begs Christians
to unite around the idea around ideas like deporting mom Donnie.
Um, I
uh
I think it's really up for me when I see so much accurate analysis
and then I see what to me looks like intentionally blind analysis
to like avoid a certain
This is very strange to me, but Michael Nolles at least has an
escape hatch for that history that question. I've never seen
Nick Fuentes voice it. Oh, are you talking about the fact that
they're like antithetical to the Constitution?
I've seen Nick talk about it. He talked about it with Destiny
once. He just said, "Yeah, [__] the Constitution.
We want We want America to be better."
Is what I remember. Anyway, with all that in mind, it's no wonder
that Fuentes has been succeeding. Politicians like Vance tell
Americans that immigrants are destroying the country, that foreigners
are taking their jobs and committing crimes, and that anyone
who ever denounces anyone else for bigotry is a doing the bidding
of the left. A guy who talks about ancestry being central to
American identity suddenly finds himself shocked when members
of his movement start asking questions about his Indian wife
and brown children.
Yeah. No, JD Vance is the same. Okay. JD Vance is the same as
Ben Shapiro.
You guys all joined a movement that believes in these things
and and then you guys are shocked when that movement turns its
gaze onto you. You are the petite bgeoa, right? Is that what
it is? The petite bgeoisi. I don't know socialism. I don't know
Marks very well. He's like the people who get the wall first.
Okay, they're a part of the movement. They help in some way and
then boom, you're you're up against the wall. That's who JD Vance
is. That's who Ben Shapiro is, right? They help they help this
thing take over and then hey, you're like the first guy. You're
you're the first one out, buddy. How about you face that wall
right now? Uh yeah, I've seen this argument as well that they'll
just do anything only to cause destabilization in the country.
Yep. the the idea of the network state is actually shockingly
like what Fentes uses as his like anti-semitic conspiracy about
the Middle East. Not anti-semitic conspiracy. He talks about
the uh
uh the clean break memo, right? Where it's like we want to bulcanize
the Middle East because if it's bulcanized into just like tribes
with flags, then controlling it is very easy. It'll never rise
up against Israel.
And that's sort of the idea of the network state is bulcanize
America, bulcanize the west, get it into smaller groups of people
that are more like less able to resist, I don't know, the oligarchs,
the people who can control
Modern, you know, futurist surfom. Anyway, MAGA, national conservatives,
and post-lberals want to have the best of all worlds. They go
around heavily implying that some American citizens belong less
than others on account of their race, religion, or place of birth.
They will usually avoid explicitly putting things in those terms
because they also want to avoid charges of racism. Their politics
revolves around stoking bigotry against Americans of the wrong
religion in recent arrivals, falsely arguing they have high crime
rates, and relying on economic literacy to portray them as threats
to American standard of living. MAS who want to exclude gropers
from their coalition would like to continue benefiting from racist
ideas and attitudes without ever having to face electoral, coalition,
or PR consequences for it. Nick Quentes has helped make this
balancing act less tenable. We should probably thank him for
showing so clearly what is the ultimate end goal of right-wing
identity politics.
Yeah,
it's basically
he's the guy who doesn't hide. He's the guy who's not like dog
whistling and he's sitting here and he just like went all in
and he said, "You guys are all lying. You guys are all lying.
I'm not.
Say what you really believe."
And unfortunately what they really believe this will be like
probably political cyanide for them, right? They either have
to capitulate to Fentes, that's political cyanide, or they have
to start saying, "No, no, no. We didn't really believe in the
things we were talking about before." Actually, we were just
kind of lying. We were just sort of lying before.
It's political upheaval in either direction. Now, me personally,
I tend to think
that a lot of this is sort of lying. Like, a lot of it is just
leaning into things that they don't understand and they they
see are popular and they think it's funny. And there will be
like a cultural realignment and it won't be quite as as like
it'll be it'll be frowned upon more, right?
I that's my personal bet, but honestly, you never know. You're
you're just betting on what's in people's hearts, like truly
in their hearts, right?
Is it called karma? Well, the unfortunate thing is, R Popo, if
I am mis if I am miscalculating about what's in their hearts,
okay, and they actually are all racist, like true racist down
to the bones, then you might just get a total fascist take over
your country and like a a Third Reich, unironically.
We'll see. I hope not, but I that'd be probably the worst thing,
worst outcome for the world.
I don't think so, but you never you never can say for sure, can
you? All right, we're gonna get into finally we're here with
the Tucker Carlson.
The Tucker Carlson Megan
Kelly interview.
Let me see. I might have a teaser here for the Tuck Carlson Megan
Kelly interview. Yeah. >> Quentes has said a long list
of very vile things. >> Big time. Including attacking my
dad, which was the most vile of all in my >> Yeah, I mean
I personally have watched
>> Wait, not the thing about all the Wait, what? Wait,
Tucker, no. Tucker, no. Tucker, no. What are you doing, Tucker?
Nick [clears throat] Nick Fentes has said some very disgusting
things. Yeah, he said my dad was in the CIA, and I find that
the most disgusting. Wait, wasn't your dad in the CIA? Yeah,
but I didn't know. Well, I did know, but like it was up,
but he goes through that entire progression. By the way, if you
think I'm not I just pre-watched that >> videos of him
questioning the Holocaust,
likening it to baking cookies in the oven, and there's no way
you could have gotten to >> And you you like that less.
Sorry. You like that more than him saying your dad was in the
CIA? A true fact.
>> 6 million seems to be his theory. He seem he thinks
to seem to think that we've way overstated the number of and
the Holocaust. He's ripped on poor Usha Vance in the most. >> Do
you miss the sarcasm? I did. >> Personally have watched
videos list of very vile things >> big time including attacking
my dad which was the most vile of all in my >> Yeah. I
mean I >> uh Yeah. I don't think that's sarcasm. I What?
He sounded way more sarcastic at the beginning of it and then
at the end he's just delivering straight. I think I think you
guys are totally wrong on the sarcasm there.
I think he's trying to lean into like a oh, he attacked my family
and that's the most unforgivable thing you can do. I think that's
what's going on there. >> Personally, I've watched videos
of him questioning the Holocaust.
Likening it to baking cookies in the oven and there's no way
you could have gotten to 6 million seems to be his theory. He
seem he thinks to seem to think that we've way overstated the
number of
the Holocaust. He's ripped on poor Ushe Vance in the most offensive
terms which
>> wait has he actually ripped on Usha Vance in the most
offensive terms?
He will describe he will use racial epithets to describe Ushubance,
but when he's actually described Ushabance directly, he's actually
gone like
I he's he's actually been kind of glowing in some of his his
the things he said about her directly. I think in general when
he's attacking JD, he will use racial epithets to describe her,
which is sure you could say is gross obviously, but I think it's
it's kind of interesting that that's there's a differentiation
there where he's attacking JD Vance by saying it.
I uh it's I understand how it's an attack on both, but I'm there's
something different going on there that I think is interesting
to ponder, but I don't I probably shouldn't even bother correcting
it. I can see how everybody feels like that's an attack on Nusha.
>> I mean, so so what do you say to those people say, "Why
don't you why didn't you raise any of that?" >> You know,
do your own interview the way that you want to do it. You're
not my editor. Buzz off. [laughter] I mean, I don't know. You
want to go yell at Nick. >> What do What do you think of
people who think you should have pushed back harder? You you
do your own >> Fentes. I'll give you a cell. Call him and
go sit and yell at him and feel virtuous or whatever. That's
up to you. I got the same thing with Putin. Why aren't you yelling
at him? Okay. Why? so I can show that I'm a good person. I care
about what my wife thinks, my children think, and God thinks,
and that's it. I don't need to prove that I'm a good person to
you. You may think I'm a terrible person. Okay, so this almost
seems like fine to me because I think Tucker actually holds this
position. I think Tucker has been called a Russian stoogge by
like a trillion different people and has never given a about
it. So when that's the case, when Tucker does like when he gets
called a Russian stoogge and he goes, "I don't give a
It's like, okay, if you want to just be an open Russian stoogge,
I guess you could do that and we can all criticize you for it."
I don't think those interviews with Putin made people go, "Oh,
Pucker Pucker Tucker's a serious journalist." I think basically
everybody looked at his Russia content was like, "Oh, this guy's
like getting paid by Russia. This guy's a total joke." So,
>> okay. I'm just doing my thing, which is I want to understand
what people think and I'm committed to that. And if you don't
like it, don't watch. That's my >> Damn. Okay, we're going
to watch that entire Megan Kelly segment cuz he Sorry, she asks
him about Fuentes.
She asks him about Ben. It's like a whole thing.
So, interviewing people now is a bad thing. I think people want
to not let bad ideas be platformed without them without challenging
them. That's fine. I do think that there's like a whole complex
of people who will watch that interview and we'll review it and
explain why things might be bad.
So, I don't necessarily think the issue is now there's like so
much volume. There's so much
there's so much going on that you know the scale of response
to Tucker might not even be close to the number of people Tucker
exposed to let's say misinformation or something. Although with
Fentes, I don't know if it's misinformation. You're kind of exposing
them to a guy who's like charismatic
that it's like incomplete information. You're not giving a good
characterization of the person. And if you if you don't have
a problem with that, that's okay. But like I think we've clearly
seen with Joe Rogan and
start up this little guy. Should be good. Should be good.
Okay. Uh we're back. We're finally back.
I can't even do the Ben Shapiro bit again. That was tempting
fate. Jesus. Okay. All right. Okay. All right. Let's go. Let's
Guys, we just finished the Tucker Carlson interview with Megan
Kelly. We're going to do the Ben Shapiro interview with Megan
Kelly. Now, this is from today. He responds to some of the Tucker
stuff. He chastises Megan Kelly. Goes off on Candace Owens. It's
all happening. It's all big. It's all happening right now. Oh,
is this actually staying off this time or this feels like it's
broken? Yeah, that's what I thought. Okay, perfect. All right,
should be good to go. All right,
let's go.
>> So happy to be in here. >> They love their fireworks.
They love their WWE entrances now with Ben Shapiro and with all
their conservative commentators. They just love this. Trump did
it once and they're all copying. >> Yes, the man, the myth,
the legend, the one and only. Thank you so much for being here.
>> Thanks for having me, Megan. >> How about that
walk down memory lane? >> That was that was great.
I am so happy you're here. This worked out so well. You've been
in the news
>> Yeah. You seen that? >> Yeah. A little bit. >> How's
your last year been? >> Uh the last year has been interesting.
Uh obviously huge victory for for President Trump, which was
the big news of the last year. Uh all the transformative policies
that he's put into place, that's been wonderful. Uh I've, you
know, had the opportunity to to see him do some of these historic
things in person. And I happened to be in Israel for the Jewish
holidays when he was giving that historic speech at the Israeli
parliament which was unbelievable. I mean it was truly tremendous.
And um and then obviously the you know you figure after an election
things are going to cool down and then things don't cool down.
And so you know it's it's been busy uh obviously since Charlie's
murder um which you know I think all of us reacted in precisely
the same way. Uh the security threats went up dramatically. I've
I've had obviously personal security since I believe 2017,
maybe 2016. I've had about 10 years of personal security. The
last 6 years has been 24/7 security on me as well as on my four
children. Uh and uh and that's been accelerated even more so
in the aftermath of of Charlie's murder. So that that's on a
personal level that's been not fun. The good news is that the
security guys are are very sweet and my kids get along with them
great and they have lightsaber fights with them and they think
that this is kind of normal, but it isn't normal and and I I
wish that that the country would go back to normal, but it seems
like uh it may be a
>> You've been dealing with this for a long time and I've
seen it personally, you know, I mean, I've seen you surrounded
by teams of security and I heard you say, and I mentioned this
last night, that if god forbid something happened to most of
the Daily Wire guys, we would know exactly who did it immediately.
If something happened to you, god forbid, it would be like an
Agatha Christie mystery, there's so many possibilities because
you're loathed by the far left and you're loathed by what we
used to and maybe still do call the alt-right.
>> He's not really No, he's not really loathed by the I
don't know, maybe the left wing doesn't like him, but there's
a lot of there's a lot of worse people out there, I would think.
I don't know. I'd be looking I'd be looking rightward for the
Ben Shapiro person. Okay. And I remember we used to talk about
this on the Kelly file because some people called you alt-right.
And you would explain, "No, no, no, no, no. I'm not alt-right.
I'm loathed by alt-right." So, what is alt-right and why do they
loathe you? So, there is a group of people in the United States
who are rooted in an idea of grievance against the system that
they believe has put them underfoot. And those people believe
that essentially they are underfoot because of their white status.
and and thus they must take revenge on anybody who is disproportionately
benefiting from the system that tends to in their own minds beh
and and you see this mostly refracted right now through a young
man named Nick Fuentes. He's 27 years old. He has is the leader
of a movement called the Groers and I don't know if any of you
are familiar with with this um but he is uh he says and believes
truly awful things. I mean truly awful things. Not not just about
I mean he he has said for example that the vice president of
the United States uh this is a direct quote I believe is a fat
gay race traitor married to a jeet that's a direct quote about
>> said that he named his son >> see [clears throat]
knows how to make it hit say the whole quote don't go oh I don't
want to repeat that oh I don't want to repeat that
just say the whole thing >> yes uh he he also has suggested
and spent years trying to destroy Charlie Kirk's organization
Charlie in texts that have now been revealed called him vermin
for exactly this reason and had banned him and his followers
from TPUSA because he believed that that Nick Fuentes and and
the Groers and white supremacy didn't belong as part of the conservative
movement. Uh and so the alt-right is be became this uh or or
they are two sides of the same coin or they're parts of the same
sort of broad movement. And unfortunately
uh I I think that they've gained a foothold in sort of the internet
subsystem. I don't think they have a foothold in mainstream America
at all. And I think one of the mistakes that people make is to
>> wrong.
Think that the internet is real life. The internet is absolutely
not real life. And the first thing people need to do is turn
off X, which is poisoning brains and making people think that
that not true things. It's basically like war games. They think
the missiles are real. The missiles are not real. The things
happening on X are not a reflection of real life, but they can
bleed over to real life if enough people take them seriously.
So you and I have talked about Nick Fuentes many times over the
years and our many appearances together and that's how I knew
about him because he was saying absolutely terrible things about
you and I am going to show
all this GOP civil war commentary. What exactly are you adding?
We get it. Nick Fentes bad young men. You're not breaking new
ground here. Uh wait, what do you think I'm adding? What do you
think my point is? Glass house.
Sorry. I'm not I'm literally not sitting here saying Nick Fuentes
is bad. You're a complete [__] if you think that.
In fact, I've said Ben Shapiro is about the most to blame of
anybody here. Jesus, you actually don't understand anything I'm
saying. You just showed up to whine. Go find some other stream
to whine on. >> Show a videoer
um of one of my first introductions to this guy Nick Fuentes
and what he was saying about Ben. Um, this is a video of
showing himself playing Grand Theft Auto, right? A video game
where you people and he's pretending that this character in the
video is Ben. Let's
>> Wait, wait. There's no way we get a live reaction. No
way.
Oh my god. I hate to be like Wick here, but some might say this
is Christmas in November for me. Okay.
[laughter]
That's funny. That's funny, man. That makes me laugh and laugh.
That's a funny
The thing is is Nick's what, like 19 here? 18, 19, 20, somewhere
in there. I No, it isn't even the funny part, unfortunately.
The funny part is the smoke grenade.
>> What a chance encounter that was. I think I just saw
Ben Shapiro. >> And it goes on.
I Okay, that's it's so [__] up that they just they
don't get it all that to like every dude under 40
they all laugh. They all think that's [__] hilarious.
Like he's clearly Jo he's clearly just laughing it's a joke.
Yeah, they didn't even play the good part. But they're doing
that to like Soy Signal and they don't understand that. So it's
Listen, Ben, for the love of God, just read the Hani article,
okay? So you can at least get some kind of game plan going and
not He's literally doing Hold on. Uh, no, no, no, not this one.
Hanania. Yes, this guy. This guy right here like just
is a core part of the Republican party right now. A communication
style and aesthetic that centers around shock value, giving the
middle finger to PC, and taking base positions on identity issues.
Not just identity issues, being like based on everything, being
like transgressive on everything. Transgression is in 100%. It
is like the way the culture is moving. And you're sitting here
going, "This guy's really offensive.
You are the leftist. You are the leftist who like, hey, can we
get some facts over your feelings right now? It's just goofy.
It's goofy as to complain about. You You look like a total loser."
>> Goes on. >> I mean, I I would hate for people
to believe that that the Nick Fuentes sort of my my problems
with Nick Fuentes are about me because they really are not. uh
they are about the fact that that Nick
is a truly horrifying person who believes truly horrifying things.
And again, there there is a reason why Charlie Crick despised
him. There is a reason why
every mainstream political commentator has been highly critical
of him. It's the reason why these are these are not arguments.
This is not a person who's making arguments. He is a is a a loving
troll. And I say that >> this is like so long ago.
The unfortunate thing is
what Ben's not understanding is where Nick Fuentes's following
came from.
And like how obvious the sort of hit job that they're doing is
I think so. Basically, Nick Fentes, do I have to do like a
>> uh I'll do it. I'll do I'll do a little graph real quick.
It's literally just going to be like a slowly rising graph and
then he hits like exponential growth sometime around recently
and people just aren't understanding what's going on. Very goofy.
Give me a second.
Right. So we we look at this and it's like can I get a brush?
Thank you. How big is that? That's too big. So like sh stop.
What is happening?
Thank you. Okay. So like Nick Shaper, sorry Nick Ben Shapi,
two tries. We'll try this one. Okay.
So Fentes's popularity pop time. So as as time's gone on, Nick
F's popularity has gone like this, right?
Gone like this. And now it's gone like
and you're trying to take stuff from back here
when none of the audience audience like knows him for those things,
right? Stop taking the stuff from back here and using it to soy
signal. Argue with the stuff from here and trust me, there's
plenty of crazy the Jeet quote. Okay, that one is from here.
Just go argue. Cut it off at like 20
23 204
new set. Okay, just look at the new set. If you can see him on
his new set, use that to criticize him. Don't go back to really
old clips and try to go, "Oh, when he was like 19 and played
Grand Theft Auto, it was a really big problem when he said I
was the guy he was running over." That's not Nobody cares.
You can criticize the points. Criticize uh I don't know, criticize
some of the shitty points he's making, criticize some of the
racism, but don't go back to 2020 and try to pull a Grand Theft
Auto clip and then Soy Signal. you are going to get run the over
again.
Not in a video game, but metaphorically this time.
>> Advisedly, he literally says on his show that he loves
Adolf. Okay, so the so just the reason this has come up in recent
weeks is because last Friday night, that's a epic song.
Epic last Friday night.
last Friday night.
>> Sorry. just if you want to prove he likes. Okay. >> Tucker,
your guest last night, decided to have >> It's like searching
up the old James Gun tweets. Sorry, Dustin Sug. It's like searching
up the old James Gun tweets when James Gun was still tweeting
the same things like 10 years later. Like, stop getting the clips
of him. I understand you guys are lazy. I understand you guys
don't want to pay for it, but go get clips of him now being offensive
now because that's how everybody knows him, right? Don't go get
clips from way before and then try to say, "Oh, this is what
he still believes." Cuz it's so easy for him to go, "No, I don't.
No, I kind of moderated on that." Just don't be lazy. That's
all. >> Him on last week and to completely gloss him in
my opinion. And you can make >> Oh. Oh, hold on. Hold on.
He does it here in front of Megan Kelly and Megan Kelly notices.
We just heard it. Glossing again. >> Your own opinion as
to what you think Tucker was doing during that interview, but
I know what it looks like when Tucker Carlson decides to be an
aggressive interviewer. when he decides to ask difficult questions
of people, Tucker is eminently capable of doing that. He did
it to Ted Cruz quite thoroughly. Um but cuz Ted Cruz was sitting
there advocating for something that Tucker was against. I thought
Ted Cruz I thought Tucker had that conversation with Ted Cruz
explicit because of the explicitly because of their disagreement
on Iran. I thought that was like the entire impetus for that
conversation. He decided for any number of reasons, and I I I
try not to attribute motivations to people, that he was going
to treat Fuentes with kid gloves, that that he was going to not
ask him about any of the things that I've just mentioned, literally
any of them. Uh, and to essentially normalize Fuentes, act as
a sort of gateway drug or as a and what what I've called Tucker
as an ideological launderer of bad ideas over the last couple
of years. And and this is not coming from a place of animist
for Tucker on a personal level. I I've known Tucker for a very
long time. Tucker and I whenever we're in personal situations,
we get along great. I think I saw the Tucker talked about how
we were at Charlie's memorial in the vice president's box together.
And he's correct. I mean, we saw each other. We said hello. We
talked. It was very friendly and all of that. And it's also true
that a couple of days after Charlie's murder, he reached out
and he called me and he said, "Listen, I know that we're at odds
and you know, we've been at odds for a number of reasons, mainly
political. I mean, again, on a personal level, I'd go fishing
with Tucker anytime. the the real question is for me I got into
this business because I care about the ideas and I care about
the ideals and so when you're determining what is conservatism
what should the future of America look like and where do you
draw the lines those are the questions that I need to answer
in my job for me my business is really not about friendship I
have lots of friends people who I love with whom I disagree in
politics and don't believe they should be leaders in the cons
>> wait hold on
I didn't somehow jump way past where I want to be in this. Did
I without realizing it?
Uh, hold on. I'm I'm like not sure this is where I was supposed
to be here at all. Give me one second. Give me one
Where were we on this? Here was the time stamp. The original
time stamp.
>> No, we're in the right placement
>> We're good. We're good. >> And and that to me
is is the real question. In any case, Tucker reached out. He
he said, "You know, we've had a bunch of disagreements and you
know what if we could put those aside and aligns
in particular is what he mentioned." >> Oh, I didn't even
know we were live on Twitch. Hold on. >> Hold on. And I
said, you know, Tucker, you're totally right. Let's do that.
That would be great. >> In fact, >> the TSA, >> the
DSA. DSA. The Democratic Socialist. >> Why the TSA? How
did that bring you >> The Democratic Socialist America.
And the reason that I know >> and Yes. And And the reason
I'm taking >> TSA only divides people >> is because
Yes. The reason I'm taking out my phone is because it's I I don't
just, you know, I like to evidence what I'm saying with, you
know, actual evidence. So, I texted him and the and the text
exchange was was very nice. I mean, here here's what the actual
text exchange went like after the call. So, I texted him and
I said, "Thanks so much for calling. It means the world. It truly
does. Should we do a show together talking about the DSA threat,
Democratic Socialist America threat, and orienting in the same
direction. Happy to do whatever it takes to bring everyone back
together for the fight that matters." and Tucker then wrote back,
"Thanks, man. I appreciate it. I'm going to spend the next week
or two thinking about how to be most effective. The country is
clearly on the brink." I reached out repeatedly after that. Nothing
happened. Um, and again, I I thought it was a good idea at the
time. I I I I think I felt differently after I saw what he did
with with Nick Fentes and
>> uh So now I'm guessing
that you also have background music playing. I do. I have background
music playing. Yeah. usually do. Um,
also thank you for watching on Twitch. All four viewers, including
M possible. Oh, M possible. Also, you say, I think, uh, Shapiro
is pretty principled. Shapiro is principled in what he'll let
come out of his mouth, but he runs an entire organization that
is not principled. He benefits from that. He profits from that.
He's a total piece of [__] So you can say you have
principles, but if I like have a principle against, you know,
racist and I run like and I'm Gerbles just because let's say
Gerbles didn't say anything racist himself. It's like you still
run the propaganda network for like actual fascist actual racists.
I don't know how much I consider you principled even if you don't
state those principles or you don't state like disgusting things
personally.
But also I'm going to end on kick or sorry I'm going to end on
Twitch cuz I want to go over to kick only and do that. So, I
love you. It's kick.com/jlk
if you want to come join us. Good luck. >> After he proceeded,
in my opinion, to spend the subsequent weeks doing literally
nothing to fight the left. I again, I say this with sadness because
Tucker used to be, I think, a a deeply important part of the
conservative push to win.
The number of times that Tucker Carlson has mentioned Zoran Mamani
since October 5th on his show is once. And it was in the context
of Marjgerie Taylor Green and Tucker Carlson talking about the
appeal of Zoran Mamani. Just by way of contrast, not because
I'm a perfect representative here, but because you've talked
about Zor Mani a lot. A lot of us have. Since October 5th, I
did 17 separate shows on Zoram Dani, including four in the last
week before the election. Okay? Because when you're orienting
against the left, you really should orient against the left.
>> Okay? So, a lot in there. I I think just to be clear,
so the the breakdown from the like Dayton after Charlie was him
interviewing Fuentes like was that the next thing that happened
that led to the >> I mean, yes. I mean, I had not se I
not spoken a word there. >> It wasn't that he attacked
you like you >> I don't care about people and I don't think
Tucker cares about people attacking him. I mean, like again,
we're we're professionals. We're in a business where people comment
on on what we say
>> It's the Hutch argument. It's kind of the Hutch argument
a little bit. the, you know, again, this is why, you know, I
think you and I differ on our angle with regard to, for example,
>> it's not like the people came out and attacked Ben,
though, or attacked other right-wing figures. It was Fentes just
doing an interview, right? >> Candace Owens, I think that
what Candace Owens is doing right now is evil. It is evil what
she is doing right now. Okay? And I say that again, >> but
what what
>> like I I didn't know pine on whether it's evil or not,
but my my position is it's really none of my business. And >> why
is it But I have a question. Why is it none of your business?
I mean, you you you comment on these things for a >> I'm
not mother of the internet. >> No, but if this were on
the left and somebody were accusing Charlie Kirk of of his wife
having murdered him, I assume that you would be talking about
>> Is that what Candace is accusing Erica
>> Of murdering [laughter] her own husband. >> She
She's accusing TPUSA insiders and other members of the right-wing,
including Seth Dylan, of being involved in the murder of Charlie
Kirk. Yes. >> Now, Candace Owens would say, "Uh, that's
just not true, Ben Shapiro." And I know why you'd say that, but
but like because you're you're just a liar, Ben. You're a liar.
And the truth of it is I just said things are a little suspicious,
right? You know that that's what that's what I said, Ben. I just
said things were a little suspicious that these TPUSA people
were saying things that didn't add up. I was just asking questions,
Ben.
>> Okay. Like I said, I I don't take in that content, which
is an honest statement. I I don't have time to watch >> I
believe you. I believe you. But the the point that I'm making
is that what I understand in our business, I think it's important.
Listen, I'm I'm friendship not Trump. We don't even know each
other. I understand. But even with Tucker, friendship should
not trump.
>> I didn't see this message earlier.
>> Uh, hold on. Where's this Porter Bellar message from
earlier? Scrolling up. Where is it? Where is it? All rightwing
people, all right-wing media people have to pretend to love fishing.
It's very funny. Fishing is good. If I love fishing personally,
I can see why people don't. Uh, I like fishing. Okay, it's good.
But I do I do notice that like Tucker his whole personality became
like I hunt and fish all the time. I'm like a hunter I'm like
a hunter fisher guy. I like brother you wore a bow tie. You went
to an Ivy League school.
This this ain't you. This ain't you dog. >> Our manifest
requirement to speak out when people do and say things that are
both detrimental to conservatism and morally wrong. >> Okay.
So I I I don't totally disagree, but I think the way of handling
that, at least for me, is much different. So I I thought saw
things go south between you and Tucker, at least from my vantage
point, when you disagreed on Israel. That was obvious. And he
he was, "Well, let me just make my point." And so he was saying
things that were critical of Israel and our policy towards Israel.
And then you did one show where you >> did what I thought
you should have done if you disagreed with him, which clearly
you did, which is say what you believe and what you think is
factual and like educate your audience on what you think are
the real facts and give them the evidence for it. But you named
him and it felt like an attack and that to me was the beginning
of the end where he was like now it's on because he felt personally
attacked by you as opposed to just challenging his idea. I think
you named him and you you kind of diminished
>> And you know he's an 800 lb gorilla and if you mess
with a gorilla he's going to fight. And to me that's where it
started to go south and cuz I remember that day being like oh
[__] like I don't want to see this. >> But
here's the thing. I I would urge everybody to go back and listen
to the show that you're referring to where I criticized Tucker's
ideas, not Tucker as a person. Tucker then responded by claiming
that I do not love America. That is a direct quote. That I do
not love America because I was spending too much time covering
the October 7th attacks and then proceeded in January.
Wait, I I wouldn't make that argument, but I feel like
you basically used Tucker's lack of time spent on something to
show that like to show that he didn't care about leftism, right?
He didn't care about democratic socialism spreading. Now he's
using your increased time on something to say you really care
about this more than anything else. Feels like it's a consistent
argument just applied in reverse. No. >> To then say that
I wanted his children to die in a foreign war.
Okay. So, those are different. >> That's a rhetorical.
>> No, it is not. I'm sorry. It's not an attack on motivation.
>> Did Ben Sorry. Did Tucker say Ben Shapiro wants my kids
to die in a foreign war?
Or was that a part of his whole criticism of Israel in general?
>> Maybe he did. I feel like No, >> very different
thing from an attack on an idea. >> His point was that
you were sounding >> kids are draft age. Okay. So, that's
saying something different, right? My kids are draft age. Like,
I think differently about war. I feel like that's saying something
different,
but
>> And he's upset with anybody who wants us to get too
involved in Israel's conflict because he feels it endangers American
>> It is it is a that Okay. The idea that number one, the
idea that I want the United States to be directly involved in
Israel's conflict is not true. >> No, I know that, Ben.
>> I've been urging Israel to get off of American aid for
literally as long as I have been active in politics. >> But
I'm making clear what his point was. >> But no, no, but
that but my point is that that's not his point. And again, none
of this, well, we no none, we disagree on the interpretation
of what Tucker has been doing for the past 2 years. And it's
very difficult for me to >> that Tucker is merely anti-Israel
when, for example, today in his newsletter, I mean, I can directly
quote it if you'd like. In his newsletter today, he claimed that
Zoran Mani is not anti-Semitic.
This was his This is his newsletter today. This >> Oh,
did that go through,
dude? What the f? Shut up, Ben. God, Ben is the worst. Do you
guys get the soundboard, by the way? Oh, you didn't get it? That's
too bad. I as soon as I heard Zoron, he claimed in his newsletter
that Zor Zorani is not
It's like, uh,
that's Ben thought that was going to hit. Ben thought he had
everyone like he thinks everyone else is on the same page.
I'm sorry, we're not on the same page, Ben. Nobody's on the same
page with you on this one. Okay, I'm sorry. Nobody thinks Zora
Donnie is is anti-Semitic. Nobody cares about Zora Dani's beliefs
on Israel. Nobody thinks he has the immoral belief here. You're
the one with the immoral belief that's that Israel can kill as
many kids as they want,
right? That's your belief, Ben. The rest of us are off that page.
I mean, I'm unironically
globalized the antifat. Like I at this point, people got to stop
dying. Okay. Well, I say at this point, I mean, I guess the ceasefire
the ceasefire is still holding technically, right? Even though
it's been violated.
I think it's still technically holding, but like realistically,
I don't care about people saying that. Okay, that was the moral
side to be on. I'm sorry. It was from the beginning. >> I'm
h I'm happy to read the text. It's pretty it's it's a little
extraordinary because again it is it is kind of shocking stuff.
So here is what Tucker Carlson wrote in his newsletter today
or what his newsletter says under his name. He said is the incoming
mayor a fan of Israel? Does he want America to fight its wars?
Not particularly. But a hater that's a different conversation.
We've never seen anything to suggest he falls into that ugly
camp. If we're talking about fighting the left, defending Zar
Mdani who literally said that he has no opinion whether should
disarm who posed alongside the 1993 World Trade Center unindicted
co-conspirator who would not globalize the inifat who suggested
that whenever there is an a New York police department booed
on somebody's neck it's an IDF lacing the strings to suggest
that that's not anti-Semitic in any way. No
>> I he hates Israel. I I just don't I'm
Israel proved in 2024 and 2025
that like
they could not be trusted and everybody who was against them
purely on their on their oppression of the Palestinians was in
the correct camp. This is just facts
>> Okay. But listen or when he when he or >> I'm
gonna give you a defense of Tucker here and and I don't need
to defend Tucker because I'm not >> Tucker Tucker
say I think in general because I know him and I listen to him
and I I understand generally where he's coming from. He he would
say his problems are with Israel and he would say that that that
shot that Mamani laid against the IDF is a shot against the IDF
and Israel and and how he thinks they're pro war not against
and I think and I think >> all I can say is >> Ben
Ben Shapiro when he gets one ounce of push back
Tucker can defend himself you don't have to defend him here stop
talking
in complete alignment with Zor Mani it is very difficult for
me to believe >> uh complete alignment On what issue, Ben?
What? What? What issue are they in complete alignment on? Ben.
Ben, be honest. Be honest. Ben,
what's the issue? What's the one issue they're in alignment on?
Ben, >> believe that he does not agree with Zor
>> The Tucker Carlson and Zora Mandani are in complete
alignment. So, you think Tucker Carlson is a socialist?
>> Okay. All right. is in a place right now of the same
place that Charlie was getting to toward the end of his life.
The ch the same place. [laughter] Dude, Ben's going to go Ben's
Ben's going to go ballistic. Hold on. Is she about to suggest
that Charlie Kirk,
Israel's strongest golem, was was actually starting to turn on
Israel. There's no way. There's no way she would do that. There's
no way. Ben, don't let her get away with that. And >> place
that some people had tried to drive me, which is you're under
withering non-stop accusations of being something you know you're
not from from some people who you love and who you've been protecting,
at least in my case and Charlie's case for 2 years who you've
been completely defensive of. And Charlie and I both felt and
I cuz we talked about this on my show like what's >> Megan?
Megan Megan please stop talking. Megan, cutting off is anti-semitic.
Actually, Megan, you're about to get another accusation. Actually,
>> happening here. Why are we they dropping charges of
anti-semitism against us when we love and we're both open Semites?
>> We're Zionist. Megan, >> it's a No, you're not
Semmites. You're
We're open Semites. We're totally neutral. No, you're like Phylo.
That's not the way to say that.
Semites would be like a Semitic person. You may notice I'm just
talking about me here. Are there people who are overzealous?
Sure. I'm Have I ever attacked you? >> No. No. Never.
[laughter] >> Ben's just a lot smarter. >> I ever
attacked Charlie publicly about any of this. >> No. No.
No. No. >> Wait. Why did Wait, what? Why? Why you say publicly,
though?
Why did he just say publicly?
That was a weird That was a weird couching of that, wasn't it?
Have I ever attacked Charlie publicly over this?
I know. I know that Candace has some texts. I have I ever attacked
Charlie publicly. I know that Candace has some texts. Have I
ever attacked him publicly about this? Never. >> Okay.
He and I had disagreements behind the scenes. Did I ever Did
I ever You get defensive.
>> By the way, I waited to attack Tucker until he glossed
Nick Fentes.
>> Who is that has nothing to do with Israel. Nick Quentes
hates >> Okay, incredibly important follow-up question
coming right now. Pay attention
>> I'm not saying you have a right to go after him. I mean,
I think you you you did what you thought was right and you felt
and he mentioned you a few times in his interview with Nick.
>> He did, but again, I don't think it's about that because
if he had not mentioned me in that interview with Mick Fuentes,
I still would have said something about it because again, glossing
people who are white supremacists is bad electorally on a pragmatic
level. A right-wing that embraces So, if you haven't been watching
guys, we've seen the past three days,
maybe even the past four days. Ben Shabro's dropped a video essentially
every day saying glossing, glossing, glossing, glossing, glossing.
It's starting to irritate us, okay? Because he does mean glazing.
This is this is almost certainly exactly what he means. Um I
believe JTO Gunnar now JTO celibacy arc apparently
has has linked that clip of K did Kyle Klinsky is glossing as
well. Its own fringes will end up in the same position as a left
wing that has embraced. >> That's why I want to get into
it.
>> Yes. So now having spoken to Tucker, I actually see
that interview very differently. And I did listen to the interview
and I knew who what Nick Fentes was. And I think he did show
himself to be who he is. It wasn't his most vile stuff, but you
you got the feel for what this guy was. But I really think Tucker
was talking to him, Ben, to put like a bumper on this guy. Because
what Tucker was urging him the whole time was to understand that
collective punishment for anyone group of people is wrong. It's
deeply immoral and it's anti-Christian, which this guy is supposed
to be, and reminding him of how deeply immoral that is, that
you should not be looking at a group of people, whomever it is.
>> She is going to ask, she does ask. I know she asks.
The left does it to everyone,
whites mostly, but like this collector shame, white men in particular,
and there's a group of people like Nick Fuentes that does it
to groups of and he was making the case throughout the whole
interview in the way that Tucker does. He's not like you or me.
He's not like pointed and >> not true. And was >> that
is fundamentally untrue. Ask Senator Ted Cruz whether that is
true. >> He gave it to Ted Cruz cuz Ted Cruz is a >> That's
Oh, hold up. So only politicians >> you don't look it depends
on the person. Tucker Tucker would never person who >> I
thought I thought Tucker and Ted talked because of their difference
of opinion on Iran that that they were like kind of sniping at
each other and they decided to talk and then Tucker went at him
pretty hard cuz Ted went Tucker pretty hard and called him like
an anti-semite and
I I thought that was intentionally like that started off and
was proposed and carried out as a contentious conversation knowing
it was going to be a contentious conversation
>> who was not a politician That's his >> Hucker
has excoriated.
>> He is not. He is not Kger. He means like the same thing.
>> Public figures who purport to speak for us and represent
us for many years. Nick Fuentes is a podcaster civilian. >> Okay.
I I just have a question. We all in our industry are constantly
excoriating people who are in our industry. It happens all the
time, every single day. >> Okay. Okay. Again, we're talking
again, we can we can agree to disagree on your interpretation
of what Tucker was doing there. I think everybody should watch
and determine for themselves what they think Tucker was doing
in that interview. And I urge you to watch it backto-back with
the Ted Cruz interview to determine whether you think that that
was an aggressive Tucker Carlson interview. And you can judge
yourself.
>> I didn't. >> Again, that's like a total that's
a totally misleading thing to say, right? When they're entirely
different interviews. One of them is meant to be like, "I don't
know you. I want to get to know you." The other one is, I know
you, Ted. We know each other really well. [__] you
for this opinion and we're going to argue about it.
That's pretty simple. >> Say it was aggressive and I don't
think he would say it was aggressive. I think his point was this
guy, first of all, he's become a behemoth sadly. He's got 5 million
viewers on Rumble. He's got a million followers on X. I agree.
>> This is all before Tucker Carlson, and he was platformed,
hate that verb, but he was platformed by Patrick Beth David and
he went on Dave Smith show and he went on another big show. He's
been getting more and more purchase in the the political ecosphere,
including rightwing. And I think, >> dude, I swear to God,
Nick Fentes would get voted democratically like furer of the
planet Earth, and there would be people who are like, I think
those votes are fake. I don't think he has any real
Sorry, J. I'm I'm mocking you a little bit, Jude. But I feel
like everybody's just like, this seems all fake. And it's like
it's it's really not. I'm sorry. case like really really not.
>> Patrick Beth David has a huge show. I know. But did
you know that Patrick Beth David had him on? Did his life blow
up? >> Patrick Patrick McDavid did a significantly more
aggressive interview with with Nick Fuentes than Tucker did.
>> Okay, but my point is simply he's >> Okay, then
why did you cancel on his show after you did the interview,
right?
Ben Ben literally canled on PBD.
Ben had another interview planned with PBD. He canled it.
There's a couple things I want you to be thinking about. >> He's
growing. He's growing. >> Hold on. Hold on. Um, what am
I trying to do? Oh, I should should I'm not going to do like
a bunch of shilling, guys. If we don't hit the target, I'll finish
off like this segment, which has a couple more pieces in it.
And if we don't make it through the se or if we don't add any
time, I'll probably do some Patreon content or something. We'll
see if there's uh we'll see what there is. Probably do Patreon
content or whatever. But we're
11 subs from two more hours.
You guys should try to get there if you if you want. Otherwise,
I might I might do some Patreon content after this. I'm not sure
you would elect a furer. Oh, maybe not. I I use Furer as a rhetorical
flourish, you know, >> growing in stature. And so what
I saw Tucker do was not whitewash his ideas, but try to put bumpers
up on the guy. I know Tucker well, and I think that was his approach.
And the way the way if you want to put a bumper up on Nick Fuentes,
is it helpful to say you're vile, you're an anti-sem?
>> Uh, it doesn't at all. Revolt and he'll get called on
it. He's obviously trying to say glazing.
>> No, it isn't. That doesn't put a No. the way if you
want to put a bumper up on Nick Fuentes, is it helpful to say
you're vile, you're an anti-semite, you
>> see, this is the place where I do disagree with like
I do actually agree with Ben here. It's like, well, you don't
have to label him as something he's not. You can say he's like
a vile racist anti-semite. If you think racism, anti-semitism
are worth calling out,
>> Uh Ry, thank you for the five gifted. If you think >> that
racism and anti-semitism aren't worth calling bile by and aren't
worth calling out, then you can go ahead and like make that point,
I guess. But a lot of people do think they're worth calling out.
Pretending they're not worth calling out is silly.
But a lot of Republicans want to do that because they think they've
been canceled for saying they're for by other people saying they're
racist. So they're like scared to go and cancel someone else
or say this guy's racist at all. And it's like, hey, you're like
held in this prison of your own mind where you can't actually
state what somebody is.
You think it's like cancelelling to say they're racist. It's
not. Cutting them off from like job opportunities, cutting them
off, banning them from platforms, those would be cancelling.
Just saying Nick Fun is racist is like saying water is wet. Just
say he's racist. It's fine. Honestly, say he's racist and watch
how much every single Republican voter and viewer on any program
doesn't give a [__] >> No, it isn't. That doesn't
put a No, it isn't. That makes the audience feel good because
you have hand to hand combat, but it doesn't help change that
guy's view or his extrem his extremess at all. >> Okay,
I'll tell you what doesn't change Nick. [laughter]
>> Dude, I I want Ben Shapiro to say what he really thinks
right now, which is he's like Charlie Kirk and everything that
guy ever did. That guy's such a loser. That's what That's what
Ben Shapiro thinks right now. All these people think free speech
is really important now. Open debate's really important. [__]
Charlie Kirk. Charlie Kirk is all Ben Shapiro can think right
now. Right
is because if you don't know like after this uh as far as I know
the past couple hours today every single person on the internet
is basically like Ben just debate him. Ben just debate him. Ben,
aren't you the debater? Ben just debate him. Ben just debate
him. And I I'm telling you, it doesn't matter how that debate
goes. Ben cannot win that debate. Ben loses that debate. Every
single cultural element of the right wing is against Ben going
into that debate. Ben Nick could come in and he could just slobber
into his mic and like half fall asleep and it wouldn't matter.
Nick wins. Ben is arguing for all of the wrong things to these
people.
Tucker Carlson with his arm around Nick Fuentes grinning for
the camera while Nick Fuentes tweets out America first and then
triumphantly goes on the air the next day to explain that he
has essentially used Tucker Carlson as a vehicle for manipulating
other people. Okay, that's what Nick Fuentes is saying, not me,
Nick Fuentes. Okay, and Nick Fuente and and by the way, I will
again say that Tucker Carlson when you say to somebody in an
interview, do you condemn anti-semitism? And then the person
says, "Sure." Which is what Nick Fuentes said. He said, "I'm
not an anti-semit." Which is blatantly untrue. >> A responsible
a responsible journalist would then follow up. >> Dude,
it's such
I'm not an anti-semite. I'm a Christian. I'm a Catholic. I love
everybody. It's like, shut the up.
What does this Cookie Monster clip mean, Nick? What did you mean
with this Cookie Monster clip? Tell me. >> That that is
false. Tucker did not do that. He allowed him to get a >> But
it's so It's so gay culturally to do that, right? Like you automatically
lose. You're 100% correct. And if you go, Nick, what did you
mean in that in that Holocaust clip, in that Cookie Monster clip,
you're literally you're already the loser. Hey, Nick, when you
said you're America's premier anti-semite, I know you're saying
you're not an anti-semite, but when you said you're you're America's
preeminent anti-semite, what did you mean by that?
Right. And Nick just laughs and he goes, "Ah man, geez, it's
just a joke or something." And it's like, "Oh, well me, I guess
it's just a joke. all of the all of the Holocaust revisionism,
all the open hatred of and then I'm and then you say you're the
pre America's preeminence anti-semite.
Hey Nick, what did you mean by all that? That's just a joke,
dude.
Good one. >> Away with that. And then he allowed him to
talk about quote unquote organized jury followed by Nick >> dude.
Philip DeFranco saying organized jewelry over like today.
Jesus Christ. I just never thought we'd get to the day where
like Billy D of all people. I don't know if you guys were all
here earlier and caught the Philip DeFranco segment. Hold on.
Let me let me pull it up here.
You're seeing this magaz
hold on hold on about what he called organized. There's a whole
bunch of
>> dude. It's just crazy that he said this on a show last
week and among a decent chunk of the right that sparked some
backlash because Tucker is seen even though he's not with Fox
News anymore as kind of this institution. and he has a huge platform.
In the interview, it was friendly and Fuentes among other things
talked at length about what he called organized. And so a whole
bunch of conservatives, most prominently Ben Shapiro, Mark Leaven,
and Ted I just feel like so many people are googling that phrase
being like, "What the is that? What the What did he just say?
I like organized.
I like my to be nice and neat and tidy."
Neat untidy.
I think Germany like neat and tidy as well. Cruz condemned. Oh,
whoops. Not this video. We're back to this. This guy >> Fentes
being treated to a disquisition by Tucker Carlson about why Christian
Zionists of all human beings on Earth are the people that he
hates the most. >> He took that back. You can't take that
back. How do you >> Yeah, you can.
Okay, Ben. Oh, do do Muslims only blow up and live in open sewage?
Pretty sure you took that one back. No.
>> Or do you not take that one back? take that back. >> He
did how? >> Because you he went he >> and then he
should then he should explain why it was wrong. He should explain
how Christian Zionists are actually wonderful people. >> Tucker
is very quick to self flagagillate. And he went on with Dave
Smith the next day, the next week, whatever, Monday, Tuesday,
this week, and said, "That was stupid. I didn't mean that." He
said, "I'm I'm angry at people like Lindsey Graham. I'm angry
at people like Ted Cruz because he thinks they run head first
in these conflicts and they don't think about what's going to
happen to America." >> Wait, hold up. If we're talking
about firing inside the tent, what everything Lindsey Graham,
okay, and I'm not a huge Lindsey Graham fan. He votes with the
president of the United States 100% of the time and Tucker spent
yesterday's show excoriating him as a
death worshipper. Does that sound like firing outside the tent?
>> Again, these are not offended. >> Again, the the
the questions that I'm asking here, I'm not asking you to do
anything, Megan. >> No, I know. Okay. Our beef is not with
each other. >> I'm not okay. When I draw a line with regard
to what I believe Tucker Carlson is doing to the conservative
movement and what he is fermenting, that is because that is my
in and everyone can make their own decision as to whether they
think that I am right or whether I'm wrong and where they choose
to draw the line with regard to the conservative movement. The
question for me is always whether somebody's statements are forwarding
moral values that I think are worthwhile. I did not get into
this business for the money or for the clicks. You didn't either.
>> Neither did he. >> What was that? >> Neither
did he. >> I mean, he may not have. That's fine. I certainly
did not. I'm only going to speak for myself and what that means
for me is that if I see somebody breach basic moral val >> I'm
sorry I don't believe that that's true for Ben because I think
Ben does understand to some extent that Michael Nolles,
Matt Walsh, Jordan Peterson, Candace Owens, all his employees,
Brett Cooper to some extent all push populist talking points,
all push this us versus them narrative. They're trying to control
you. They're trying to ruin your life. They all do it and that's
what got you here.
You keep you keep saying, "Oh, well, this is every he he keeps
casting moral judgment on everybody else." Okay, it's >> neither
did he. I mean, he may not. That's fine. I certainly did not.
I'm only going to speak for myself. And what that means for me
is that if I see somebody breach basic moral values by >> uh
unless I'm making a huge bag from >> on a and in my own
view, you can take your own view. in my own view gloss the
then I'm going to speak out about that and I'm going to point
out that there is a long pattern of him ideologically laundering
terrible ideas over the course of the last two years ranging
from traveling to Russia to sniff the bread and explain why the
Russian regime is actually wonder >> okay this is actually
a good talking point though
Tucker what was that Russia trip Tucker you need to talk about
that Tucker if Tucker you got to tell the truth dude >> to
saying last week that the Venez Venezuelan regime of Nicholas
Maduro is actually not that bad because they're being attacked
by, in his words, globo homo.
Tucker's made the point. I'm not going to here to be Tucker's
defender, but he >> There's no way Tucker said globo homo.
No shot. I do not believe. No way. Hold on. Tucker
Carlson.
Globo homo. I don't see it. I don't see it.
What the [__] I don't see
Where does he talk about global homo? He
Bro, that's Dude, [laughter] who's writing for Tucker Carlson?
Somebody who's trapped in a time capsule. 2016 4chan. >> He's
made the point that Maduro is culturally conservative. >> That's
such an old term.
That's such an old term. I feel like conservatives are so comfortable
with uh with gays now that global homo is like falling out of
fashion. Like global homo is supposed to be the idea that like
they're trying to export LGBT values to like like pro LGBT values
to every country in the world. No. Okay.
Okay. Sorry. We're saying the same thing. We're saying the same
thing. It's a double andre Billy Drew. Uh Billy Joe Bush. It's
double andre. I know this from the memes I've seen on the internet.
The racist memes. Okay.
Tucker Carlson implying that Bill Donald Trump push against Maduro
serves the global homo agenda. Maduro bans gay marriage, abortion,
and changes. His US backed replacement wants to legalize them.
Tucker explains. Oh, never mind. I do know this talking point
though. He was just saying it wasn't even in the Venezuela episode.
He said this in other episodes too that I've seen. I've seen
Tucker Carlson talk about this. how like well while we don't
agree with um Venezuela on economic issues certainly they're
like socially conservative or
yeah I think that's it. It's like why it's like I might have
some opinions that were like more conservative socially but I
might be okay with some more socialist economic things. Yeah,
I got it. I got it. It definitely
That's like totally >> gives a [__] consistent.
The guy's a
>> of Nicholas Maduro got >> is actually not that
bad because they're being attacked by in his words globbo
>> Tucker's made the point I'm not going to here to be
Tucker's defender but he's made the point that Maduro is culturally
>> Who gives a [__] The guy's a communist dictator.
Everyone in his country is eating dog.
He's shipping fentinel to the United States. I don't give a [__]
>> We ban Rubin donated $3. I heard that global homos love
tearing up Uranus.
>> Whether he's whether he's anti-LGBTQ
>> this is the number one thing about Nicholas Muro. You
know how far down the list you have to get before you can get
to anything remotely recommendable about Nicholas Maduro?
>> I did ask him yesterday about the criticism that he
didn't give Nick Fontes a hard time, right? He didn't bring up
the stuff that we were talking about. No, he didn't. And uh here's
what he said. They seem to think that we've way overstated the
number of and the Holocaust. He's ripped on poor Usha Vance in
the most offensive terms, which I I mean, so so what do you say
to those people say, "Why don't you why didn't you raise any
of that?" >> You know, do your own interview the way that
you want to do it. You're not my editor. Buzz off. >> Wait,
I thought he actually brought up that he thought the Ushan's
comments were disgusting. Did that Did that skip and I didn't
say, >> you know, do your own interview.
Yeah. So, so what do you say to those people say, "Why don't
you why didn't you raise any of that?" >> You know, do
your own interview. The way >> I could have sworn he brought
it. You're not my editor. Buzz off. Weird. >> I mean, I
don't know. You want to go yell at Nick Fentes? I'll give you
a cell. Call him. >> Yeah. As far as I know, I thought
uh Fent Fuentes Fent Fentinel.
Dude, I I'll be honest. I got up quite early this morning and
it's getting a little late, but I'm going to make it. We're gonna
get another two hours on the stream because we got way more content
to do. Got five minutes left. Uh, five, no, six subs. Six subs
from another two hours on the stream. Get them in. Uh, fentanyl
still all China, right? I think that's still just all coming
from China over ocean through shipping
like through ports.
That's where all fentanel comes from. No, then go sit and yell
at him and feel virtuous or whatever. That's up to you.
>> I agree with him. I No, I agree. I agree with him. I
agree with him. He did the interview that he wanted to do for
a
>> Here's the other thing I want to say. We all have different
approaches in this industry, you know, and >> dude, this
>> the cheering doesn't fool anyone. Ben doesn't it doesn't
fool us. Ben
also Mara dude, thank you for the three gifted. Appreciate it,
buddy. >> There's been a lot that people in podcasting
have said that I disagree with, including many of the names.
>> Sh, thank you for the one gifted.
looking at uh and then Marty Epstein with the five gifties.
God damn. Let's
>> Let's go. Let's go. That's two more hours. That's two
more hours.
Let's go.
>> Thank you guys very much. And we disagree, too. I mean,
yes, of course. >> Well, I mean, yes, rarely, but sometimes
we do. Um, but my own personal approach generally when it's someone
who's on my what I consider to be my side, the side >> and
this is the entire question is whether I consider Tucker Carlson
to be on my side. >> I got it. I got it. But I would just
say just for the record, my own general approach and this is
my audience here so they know is in general I will take on a
position and I will make clear how I feel. For example, I've
been asked and some of my audience is mad at me for this but
what do you think happened to Charlie Kirk? And I believe a man
named Tyler Robinson shot and killed Charlie Kirk. I believe
he was influenced by trans tepa radical trans activists that
he fell in with a lunatic uh that goes by Lance Twigs that that
guy was extremely radical and that he and
that guy can't leave his house. THAT GUY CAN'T LEAVE HIS HOUSE.
>> Possibly a band of others convinced this guy that violence
was the answer. And I believe others knew about it before Charlie
was. That's what I believe. And until you can show me cold hard
proof that it was something other than >> Oh, I'm so glad
you guys donated cuz there's Candace stuff after this.
Candace weighed in. Oh boy, did Candace ever weigh in. >> That
that's what I'm going with. And I don't do want to do or say
anything that will jeopardize the FBI investigation and prosecution
of that guy to make sure he spends the rest of his life either
behind bars or on the wrong end of a firing squad. But that's
so I feel like I can make these points without attacking [laughter]
Sorry, there's a thumbnail down here that I got to show and stream.
Let me see how much I'm covering up myself.
She won't bow down to wokeness.
Okay. Okay, Ben. Okay, Ben. Channel's struggling, eh? Ben really
scraping down. It's not exactly a political topic. Bening people
who generally are on my side in fighting the deranged leftists
who are
>> That's Ben. I said you needed to read a Richard Hanani
article. Not that article. Okay. Not that article, Ben. Wrong.
Richard Hanani article. Okay. Hold on. If just in case you don't
know what I'm talking about, I'm talking about the Richard Hanani
article titled, "Yes, Sydney Sweeny's are anti-woke. Leftists
are now trying to pretend they never had a problem with women's
That was the wrong article. Ben, start reading up on the gropers
and how to beat them. Stop writing articles on
>> Stop it, Ben. Stop gooning
for the love of God, Ben. >> Killing us. >> But my
point is, so two points. One, you have to define your side. >> You
do. There there limits to the side. >> All the people who
don't want to kill others based on their political >> I
So I would agree with that except for the fact that as you showed,
Nick Fuentes wants to kill others based on their political ideology.
>> My side. He's not with me. >> My point is that
Tucker treated him as though he was on his side. >> I see
it differently. Yeah, I think exploratory interview where there
was a possible attempt to put a bumper up on >> I I think
that we don't have to go over ground that we've already covered.
We can agree to disagree on that and everyone can make up their
own mind after going and watching the interview >> Why
don't we do the Larry David? I disagree to disagree. [laughter]
By the way, is it gloss or glaze?
yes.
That's literally the only thing I was watching this interview
for was that one moment right there. Okay.
that it's Megan Kelly who calls him out is so perfect. Okay.
Thank God. Thank god somebody finally said it. Thank god. Great.
[laughter]
>> By the way, is it gloss or glaze?
>> Um I've heard it both ways. Gloss like a like a glossy
like >> Do you have kids who do the brain rot talk? That's
what they call it. Brain rot. Those terms like he's got riz.
I don't know. I I've got two teenagers and a 12-year-old. >> I
mean, listen, my original verbiage is that Tucker was fluffing
him. So, I guess that was more more G- R. >> Sorry. Uh,
glazing is what they're going for. Okay, not glossing, but glazing.
Fluffing. Glazing. He meant to say glazing. Everybody else is
blown the out in this exact moment. Okay. Ben meant this dude
was sucking Nick Fuentes off. All right. That's just how it be.
I've heard it both ways. Head. >> That's a reference, right?
>> It is. >> It's a [laughter]
Yeah, he's not afraid to say it. >> That's what Ben was
talking about. Okay, >> let me ask you this. There's some
risk to both of you in this. You know, it's like Godzilla and
King Kong having this battle. There's some risk to both of you
because you both have very large shows, very large audiences,
and there's probably some overlap or at least there would have
been two years ago. So, is this in any way? Do do you feel any
reluctance to you know have this? >> The only Okay, so
I was reluctant because again, he and I had texted about the
idea of orienting in the same direction and then I decided that
we were in fact not oriented in the same direction. Okay. But
am I worried about you know the the career risks? No. Because
to me there's sort of a laugher curve when it comes to influence.
So the famously when it comes to economics and the laugher curve
the idea is that you can you eventually you hit a maximum amount
of revenue you can pull out of your population
and that might be at lower tax rates. Uh like if you increase
the tax rate you might not get any more revenue because fewer
people will pay more people look to evade. some some businesses
will go out of business, right? The laugher curve is like there's
some max tax rate where where you just stop collecting more taxes
from your >> is that if you tax everybody at 0% you receive
zero tax revenue. If you tax everybody at 100% you also receive
zero tax revenue because everyone stops working. I I think there's
an influence curve as well cuz I thought about this a lot before
>> this is so Ben who goes to the lapper curve to to bring
home the point this is so smart but then he knows that we don't
know what he's talking about so he defines it. So if you have
no influence, if you have no influence, but you speak out a lot,
then you have no influence. If you have tons of influence and
you don't speak out when it's appropriate, you also really have
no influence. And so for me, the question becomes, when is it
important to speak out? And Megan, you and I have been talking
behind the scenes about many of these same issues for for a very
long time. And so you know that I actually you've known me for
a very long time. I'm pretty good at conflict, but I don't like
conflict. >> I really don't. You've been trying to put
this one behind you guys for a long >> A very, very long
time. Consistently for a very long time. In fact, for 2 years.
I mean, I can read older text messages after that initial blow
up where Tucker was suggesting I have dual loyalty and all of
this. I literally texted him and I said, "Tucker, we seem to
have gotten crossways somehow. I would What was Ben's primary
criticism of Tucker? It's like a pot calling the kettle black
Tucker's American. He's loyal to Israel. Ben is American. He's
loyal to sorry Tucker's American but he's loyal to Russia. Ben's
American but he's loyal to Israel. They both have dual loyalty.
>> Love for you to come on my show. I'd be happy to come
on your show. We'll do it. And he proceeded to ghost me for two
>> Okay. So >> he was not in a headspade. I didn't
talk to him about this, but my assumption is he was not in the
right headsp space to >> for two years is a long time to
be not in the right head space. But you know >> the two
years we've had, right? Look at the two years. I I It's all related
to Israel. It's all related to Israel. do not agree. I [laughter]
I disagree. I fundamentally disagree. >> He wasn't picking
fights with you before the Israeli conflict. >> It it wasn't
about picking fights over Israel. Okay. Again, I You're trying
to turn it into he picked a fight with me or I picked a fight
with him. For me, the question is the principle up over the past
2 years. >> I I don't think that it's a coincidence that
obviously anti-semitism simultaneously blew up with the war of
October 7th. >> Also, so has you know conflict and controversy
involving feelings over >> of course. And now the war has
been over for several weeks and Tucker Carlson is writing newsletters
about how Zoran Mani is not an anti-semite. What does that have
to do with Israel? >> I dude,
>> I think that's a hangover from being called an anti-semite
at every turn and feeling angry about it. >> You know what?
I'm I'm I'm a little tired of the excuse that if you are called
something enough that justifies all of the subsequent activity.
I've been called every goddamn name in the
>> Every name in the book. And I have not sh but I have
not shifted my positions because people call me names. That is
a childish thing to do. >> Ben, with all due respect, pardon
the >> you did not have an entire country call you a for
the past week. I think he's in he's in a defensive place right
now on charges of anti >> interested in his psychotherapy.
Maybe >> I am. I I love him as I love you. Well, it's,
you know,
>> what and that's why that's why I I started this off
by saying you're empathetic and you're a wonderful person and
you're and you're a good friend and I think that you know there's
a reason why in the medical industry you don't operate on your
friends or your
>> but you're telling me I need to. >> I I'm not
telling you no trying to No, Megan, actually I haven't said that
one time here. I said that's why I'm doing >> I know, but
there are many people >> and you're urging me not to. And
I'm saying that that is not a move that I can make because Tucker
has already closed the door to the idea that we are on the same
side. >> Oh, but he hasn't closed the door to Dayton. Let
me show you another sound bite. Let me just show you one more.
>> But is there any
Hey Ben, I know you just talked a bunch of about this guy and
how he's been docking you and how he's an anti-semite and he
defends other anti-semmites, but he did say he doesn't want to
go to war with you. Hey, let's go.
You bury the hatchet here. >> Way that you and Ben Shapiro
could can actually find your way to Day.
>> I'm not against Ben Shapiro. He did like a 40-minute
thing yesterday calling me dangerous and all this. >> Dude,
Ben, I feel like Ben's fuming >> stuff. It's like I didn't
watch it cuz why? But I got a lot of texts about it and it's
like I'm not m I don't think Ben Shapiro is driving a lot of
this stuff. I don't consider him like the world's greatest force
for evil. I don't feel that way at all. I don't actually think
about him ever. So, I don't want to have a war with Ben Shapiro.
I don't know if does he really think that me doing an interview
in which I explain that anti-semitism is wrong to one of the
lead purveyors of anti-semitism? If that somehow makes me a
What is the argument here? >> I'm going to ask him tomorrow
night. >> No, but I don't even understand what the argument
is. All I know is that the right, and I've been on the right
since before Ben was born, is acting like the left in such an
amazingly precise way that I'm like, "What the hell is going
>> I agree with Tucker that the right is in fact acting
like by again massaging its radicals in the name of some sort
of faux unity. >> That does not sound danty. >> I
because because
again I'm not again trying to turn this personal is a >> I
know. But can it happen? Can it can if you like that person who
sent those texts on your from your end
dude this is uh if I didn't think Ben Shapiro was like maybe
maybe the most hypocritical like
up actor in this whole thing. Okay. The most like self-interested
hypocritical actor in this whole thing. I'd feel bad for him
right here because this is really up for somebody to do for for
Megan Kelly to go, "Hey, I got a clip of Tucker saying he doesn't
want to fight with you. Do you want to keep being a [__]
Do you want to keep being a whiny [__] right now?
You want to declare to the world you're a whiny [__]
Ben?" Right, little [__] boy? That's It's actually
up she's doing this,
but at the same time,
Ben Shapiro sucks. So, I'm going to I'm going to watch and I'm
going to enjoy. >> That person's still willing to sit with
him and work something out.
When Tucker changes. >> Tucker is willing to talk to you,
Ben. Are you really going to You're against talking? Isn't that
Isn't that what Charlie wanted us to do, Ben? He wanted us to
talk out our differences. Isn't that what Charlie wanted? I got
to get a drink. I'll be right back.
>> That the right is in fact acting like the left by again
massaging its radicals in the name of some sort of faux unity.
>> Does that sound danty? I because because
again I'm not again the trying to turn this personal is a mistake.
>> I know but can it happen? Can it can if you like that
person who sent those texts on your from your end >> is
that person still willing to sit with him and work something
out >> the
when Tucker changes his positions
>> then sure. >> If he does not change his positions
then no because I'm not in politics to be friends with people.
I have children. I have a wife. I have a dog. I have an extended
family. And I have friends with you either Ben. about
>> uniting the right so that we can fight the right enemy
on the left and Tucker is of the right and Tucker has been fighting
for a lot of these ideals for a long time and he's changed this
country fundamentally for the >> Tucker has never been
a wonderful advocate for anything on the >> Hold on hold
on hold on I got to back it up then >> sure if he does
not change his position then no because I'm not in politics to
be friends with people I >> if he changes his position
then sure okay if you're willing to kneel to Israel again all
right Tucker kneel to Israel and we can be I have children. I
have a wife. I have a dog. I have an extended family. And I have
friends. >> I don't want to be friends with you either,
Ben. It's about
>> the right so that we can fight the right enemy on the
left. And Tucker is of the right. And Tucker. [laughter]
>> I have a dog. Uh I have a kid. I have a wife. I have
a dog. I've got a dog.
I Okay. >> Hasb been fighting. >> I'm pretty sure
Tucker has all of those things. I think his dog is actually the
reason he has the scratches why he thinks a demon attacked him.
the right so that we can fight the right enemy on the left. And
Tucker is of the right and Tucker has been fighting for a lot
of these ideals for a long time and he's changed this country
fundamentally for >> I'm not saying Tucker has never been
a wonderful advocate for anything on the right because I don't
think that's true. I think in the past he was a great advocate
for many things on the right, particularly on the immigration
issue for sure. I'm saying that's not what he is doing now. I
do not think he is advocating for right-wing positions. He's
not conservative than I am by any stretch of the imagination
on any possible issue. And when it comes to the question as to
whether he is actually making the conservative movement more
likely to lose by attacking inside the tent significantly more
often than anyone else on the right while simultaneously
massaging again watch the interview massaging a the nation's
leading white supremacist.
I'm sorry. There's no >> I I would just wonder
why does Tucker disagree with Sorry, why does Ben disagree with
Tucker on the issue he attacked Ted Cruz for?
Ben, defend bombing Iran's nuclear facilities. Put your opinion
on the record again and again and again. Tucker will sit here.
He'll argue that with you all day because every America first
value works against that bombing. That's just facts. Date Hunt
with those positions. Forget about the person. There's no time
with those positions. >> Fair enough. Fair enough. Was
this a good discussion?
I mean, honestly, I I give you tons of credit for coming and
doing this. It's such a crazy thing for me that I had him booked
last night and I had you booked tonight and then you guys wound
up in this. But part I mean, part of me loves that, you know,
I can talk to both of you, but part of me hates this cuz I really
I don't like it. >> I hate it too. This idea that I'm like
seeking conflict again. I'm not. >> I know. It's ide
I I don't see how the Ted Cruz Tucker Carlson interview wasn't
ide.
>> I feel like the exact same defense Ben is using for
himself applies to Tucker Carlson and that Ted Cruz combo. >> I
am against them. If the [clears throat] ideas are good, I am
for them. End of story. >> I get it.
And he would say the same, right? He feels he feels very much
America first and that you know that we need to prioritize what's
happening in our country and Israel is not on that list. and
so on. You You guys can listen to that interview if you want
to hear Tucker's full thoughts. It aired today. You probably
heard it. Okay, we're going to take 20 seconds and surprise.
We're bringing Andrew and Michael back out here. We'll have a
group discussion starting now. >> Michael Nolles and Andrew
Claven. Where's Andrew Claven's stupid bald head? This guy's
the biggest loser. I I literally don't even know any of this
guy's positions. I just hear him talk for two seconds. I want
to blow my brains out. I'll never know what his positions are.
All I know is everyone must agree because he gets no viewers.
Nobody cares about Andrew Claven's
Cool. All right, so we are done with this video. We've got to
head over to
Okay, first of all,
I need to grab a tweet first. Okay, real quick. Real quick break.
I got to find a tweet. Is this the tweet? Yeah, this is the tweet.
What the [laughter]
What the is the meme below this? Hold on. No spoilers. No spoilers.
First of all, I got this Fentes meme from last >> Mitt
Romney sent $20. >> Or it's just a it's just a clip of
him. Somebody asking about Candace. >> I'm so happy that
you're moving on from Kenderson and starting a window of bread.
Two wangs giggling over a cup of hot cocoa. And everyone already
knows about that Jonathan Isaac clip.
>> Well, first of all, Candace is in love with me and I
I don't know that she's moved on. She's been replying to me on
Twitter. Look,
Candace, where my hug at? You know, if I saw Candace walking
down the street, if I saw Candace in Ugg boots and a beautiful
fall sweater and she was holding a pumpkin spice latte like this,
do you know what I would say to her? I'd walk up and I'd say,
"Candice, where my hug at?" I'd say, "Bring it in." I'd say,
"Why are we doing this?
Why are we like this? Why are we doing this to each other? Let's
just stop."
So, I don't know how.
>> That's pretty That's pretty much the concept. Okay,
that's pretty much the concept, Cherry. Okay, that a lot of the
things this guy says are the gayest things you've ever heard,
but the delivery is it's just peak. Okay, it's just it is what
it is. She feels about me. Do you think of me the way I think
about you sometimes from time to time? I I don't know. I don't
know. I [laughter] don't know where she's at with me.
I think she still can't get over me. I think she's still absolutely
crazy about me. She's in my Twitter replies. some positive, some
negative. She can't make up her mind. You know, she's tearing
her hair out. He loves me, he loves me not.
But, uh, you know, I'll always have a place in my heart.
I'll always have a little spot in my heart for old Candace, for
my She's my girl. She's my home girl. You know, this guy can't
let Charlie Kirk have
So, I like I like her. I I've always like I love her little attitude.
I love the little attitude she's got going on. She's got that
like she's got that typical black chick thing.
And sometimes the black chick and the the Italian guy got to
fight it out sometimes, you know. But doesn't mean we don't have
deep affection for each other. But Brett Cooper,
hey, you know, Brett Cooper, she's really winning me over lately.
>> Refugees at $90,
>> Jesus Christ.
20 bucks. 90 bucks. Jesus.
Okay,
I sorry. This is the next meme. I cannot believe George Farmer
proposed to Candace over a video call. And you scroll down.
[laughter]
Okay. Uh, all right. What a what a goofy meme these these gropers
come up with.
What a goofy meme. But I saw that and then I realized that
Candace Owens responded to everything
Candace,
she going off.
She going off. comment on on >> Hold on, hold on, hold
on. We'll probably back it up just a little bit.
she starts
this section here is called Ben Shapiro is crying
again. Ben Shapiro is crying again. I don't know what to say
other than it was the purest form of antilackism
that I've ever experienced. I mean, it's obvious to me that Ben
Ben Shapiro is manifestally insane. Last night, he was gripping
the microphone as he would the neck of a black woman.
That's [laughter] maybe the most insane open to an episode of
a podcast I've ever heard in my entire life. Wait, hold on. Is
she swapping notes?
Is she Is she swapping notes with
Oh, come on. Oh, come on. No, not that one. Oh, I can't find
the clip. Somebody find me the clip. Oh, all I have is a Dasha.
All I have is a Dasha reference to the tweet. Too bad. I was
trying to find the clip.
Ben Shapiro, get your knee. Get your boot off my neck. Get your
knee off my neck. Ben Shapiro.
Can we get a a Candace reimagining of that same quote? I can't
let a ninja breathe. I can't breathe.
It's
I I I need the clip, but I I don't know where it is. >> I'm
kidding. Obviously, those are not my quotes. Those are actually
direct quotations from Ben Shapiro himself when he accuses others
of anti-semitism. Whenever he hears anything that he doesn't
like about Israel, th those are actually his words. This is a
>> Oh, so that's a reference to things Ben has said before
when he hears people speak in anti-Zionist way. Oh, that's actually
really funny. That makes it >> A real life tweet from Ben
Shapiro accusing any American who is pro-Israel of being Israel
first is a pure for form of anti-semitism.
>> I just want to point out that Nick
Nick did his little bit there.
His whole uh Candace and I are still close friends.
He did that whole bit and then Candace did this episode defending
Nick kind of. >> Dude, can a live? Can a live? Please.
>> This country sucks. You can come here. You can eat cats.
You can eat people. You can drive your car into a store, a stolen
car.
Gang killings. Gang killings everywhere all the time. Can a stream
a little reaction to the major party convention?
Can I sell a hat?
>> Seriously,
I mean, it's getting a little ridiculous. Can a breathe? >> I
can't breathe. Ben Shapiro, I can't
>> Take your boot off my neck. >> My neck.
>> It's ridiculous.
It's crazy. I go ON FRESH AND FIT, they get demonetized.
I go on Sneo, he can't find a manager.
Okay. All right. The edited version goes harder. Yeah, but the
guy who had that account got deleted.
I forget which. I used to have that that Tik Tok or sorry, I
used to have that tweet saved,
but that account got deleted. It used to be this Ramo G account.
I literally used to have it bookmarked, but it's suspended.
back to Candace Owens.
>> That was directed at Nick Fuentes, which we'll uh circle
back to. Uh, also, this was a real tweet directed at Ron Paul.
Ron Paul is manifestly insane. As in previous debates, he is
now gripping the pen [laughter] as he would the neck of a Jew.
Ron Paul, really? And this is another tweet
Perry
>> Wait, why? Why was Ben Shapiro calling Ron Paul anti-semitic?
Wait, why? What was Ron Was Ron Paul anti-semitic? I I feel like
I can like reverse it back in an anti-semitic way. It's like
the thing I know Ron Paul for
is literally being the guy who wanted to audit the Fed is auditing
the Fed.
Ron Paul anti-semitism.
What?
What? [snorts] Huh? >> Free market economist is it has
to be liquidated. We have to get rid of that. That's a burden.
>> I've seen this before.
>> It's Dr. Paul. >> Oh Jesus.
That's a transit eskeemic attack. It can be a stroke. It can
be other stuff, too. Jesus, it's terrifying when you see it,
though. Very, very scary.
>> The memorable moment. >> Uh, Izzy, I don't see
the clip in the Discord, by the way. I don't know where you put
it. You put in Jen. I don't know where you put the clip >> of
the evening. had had the memorable moments of the evening evening
other than Ron Paul's corpse leaning forward from the grave and
strangling the
I don't know what's going on man I don't know what to say other
than Ben is a funny guy he is he's never trying to be funny
okay I got to give Candace a massive W in the opening for this
uh this episode just showing that Ben will accuse anybody of
anti-semitism anytime
that's that's that's a W and she did it
which is funny. >> He just is funny when he's being serious
and he's being seriously angry about a topic. It's just something
that I enjoy to watch. And last night he got on stage with Megan
Kelly. They had she had a tour stop in Florida. And I want to
say I was kind of impressed with Ben because instead of doing
his usual thing where he sends others to do his dirty work so
he can keep his hands clean, he was like, I'm going to peer pressure
Megan Kelly myself. I'm going to make her disavow me. Make her
disavow Candace Owens. I'm going to make her disavow Tucker Carlson
by putting her on the spot and asking her to respond to things
that Tucker Carlson never did and Candace Owens never did or
said. And it's you really get to see it masked down because you
saw this narrative circulating amongst people who were just
making claims that I attacked Erica. And I know what these organic
movements look like. I know how they operate behind the scenes
and I know Ben plays a part in this. And so it was actually quite
refreshing for me to be like, "Ah, now everyone gets to see what
you are because you're saying stuff that never happened." So
we'll start with what he said about Tucker Carlson. You should
know Ben has a real thing for Tucker Carlson. I don't understand
it. It is just I don't know. It's It's been going on for a long
time. There's something about Tucker Carlson that gets under
>> Wait, is is Candace accusing Ben of being Everybody
gets to see what you are.
Wait, are you are you accusing him of being like kind of perfidious?
>> Are you Are you accusing Ben of being perfidious right
now, Candace?
>> His skin, I'm not clear on it. I would actually love
to hear Ben speak about that. I mean, people at the Daily Wire
when they're leaving the Daily Wire have to sign agreements that
they're not going to go work for Tucker Carlson for 6 months.
It's It's strange. Anyways, he jumps into this explaining his
upset that like Tucker left him on Red. I don't know. Tucker
and him had a nice conversation on the day that Charlie Kirk
died and Tucker then sent a nice text because Ben had called
him and I guess Ben thought there would be more of a follow-up
and there wasn't. here is Ben complaining about that and then
spinning it into uh the accusation
that Tucker Carlson somehow supports mom Donnie. I don't know.
Take a listen. >> So I texted him and I said, "Thanks so
much for calling. It means the world. It truly does. Should we
do a show together talking about the DSA threat, Democratic Socialist
America threat, and orienting in the same direction. Happy to
do whatever it takes to bring everyone back together for the
fight that matters." And Tucker then wrote back, "Thanks, man.
I appreciate it. I'm going to spend the next week or two thinking
about how to be most effective. The country is clearly on the
brink. I reached out repeatedly. After that, nothing happened.
Um, and >> that's like pretty self-explanatory, isn't it?
I don't think you're good for the country. I'm not going to work
with
I think it seems pretty obvious to me what that means. Hey, I'm
going to think about the best way to help.
And then I don't I don't call you back. Well, you weren't a part
of the best way to help, apparently. >> Again, I I thought
it was a good idea at the time. I I I I think I felt differently
after I saw what he did with with Nick Fuentes and after he proceeded
in my opinion to spend the subsequent weeks doing literally nothing
to fight the left. I again I say this with sadness because Tucker
used to be I think a a deeply important part of the conservative
push to win.
The number of times that Tucker Carlson has mentioned Zoran Mamani
since October 5th on his show is once. And it was in the context
of Marjgerie Taylor Green and Tucker Carlson talking about the
>> Dude, I Why is that clip Maybe I just wasn't on Twitter
very much today? Why is the clip of Ben soying out about Tucker
not disavowing Zoron for being anti-Semitic? Why is that not
like blowing up on Twitter? Am I just not in the right communities
or
because I feel like that should be the biggest one of just like
bro this guy is actually having a mental breakdown live on the
Megan Kelly show about Tucker Carlson not saying that Zoro Montani
was
>> I don't know >> Zoro Mandani >> I don't
know >> just by way of contrast not because I'm a perfect
representative here but because you talk about Zoro Mani a lot
a lot of us. Nah nah you guys are saying Ben's on the downswing.
This is like the downswing where you farm a guy,
right? This is this is that part of the downswing. And it sucks
cuz I don't think Ben's really wrong on most of the things he
describes. I just think Ben is selective in how he applies like
his logic and his his insight
in a way that really grosses me out. But I don't think he's like
wrong in in his reads of a lot of people.
And it it kind of it's it's like bittersweet watching him go
down because he supported the mechanism of his own downfall and
now the mechanism of his downfall might actually destroy the
rest of us. But it's not it's not horrible for me watching him
go down to it. It's just like
I don't know. I kind of somehow I kind of wish Ben would win
this one. I don't think he's going to have since October 5th.
I did 17 separate shows on Zoramani including four in the last
week before the election. Okay. Because when you're orienting
against the left, you really should orient against the left.
>> So, this just makes no sense. It makes entirely no sense.
He's upset because I guess Tucker doesn't want to do a show with
him in the future. A lot of stuff goes on in the background that
you guys don't understand. So, okay, that's on Tucker. If Tucker
doesn't want to collab with Ben, that's on him. Also, it's Tucker's
platform. So, what it means when you have your own show, which
I don't know why the show's been, you can talk about whatever
you want. Tucker wants to do six months and he just wants to
cover sports. It's his prerogative and people can tune in or
they can tune out. That's what the free markets mean. The free
markets does not mean that the very same people who tried to
uh artificially push >> I think you can make this claim
if you are just a broadcaster just a
I think when you claim to be representing like a political
like a political movement of some kind when you are closely tied
to politics I do think there's some sort of like principles you
should follow there's some sort of there's something expected
of you you've you've gained some responsibility
right I don't think a political broadcaster like Tucker Carlson
can just say I can cover whatever I want you I don't think you
just do whatever you want I think or say whatever you want right
maybe you can cover whatever you want I don't think you just
say whatever you want though. Like Candace takes this to mean
like she could do whatever she wants. She can say whatever she
wants, but she doesn't really care about her influence harming
people or harming the things she believes in, which is just not
a good I don't know. It's not a good position to be in. >> Push
Tucker out of the markets. The same people that applauded him
being fired, the same people that have called him an anti-semite
then get to dictate what he speaks about on his show. Like that
actually just makes entirely no sense. It's not Tucker's responsibility.
Tucker's not doesn't live in New York City. It's not his responsibility
to use his platform to speak about Mandani 17 times. It's very
strange. But to the insinuation that Tucker somehow supported
Mandani and said like nice things about him when he sat down
with Marjgerie Taylor Green, here's actually what Tucker said
with Marjorie Taylor Green. And you be the judge of whether you
think Ben is being an honest person. >> So this one was
which one was this one?
Oh, which one was this one?
Is this him talking about Iran again? >> When he describes
it in the manner that he just did. Take a listen to Tucker.
>> It's interesting. You said a second ago that um when
people are really frustrated when they're the system they live
under fails them, they listen to voices that they shouldn't listen
to or wouldn't listen to under any other circumstance. Like how
did Al Sharpton get to be the leader of black America? Whatever.
I mean, it's like just it's a thing. Desperate people tend to
go to crappy leaders, I think. And I just can't get over what
happened in our biggest city this week, the very same week that
everybody in DC is focused thousands of miles away on the greatest
threat we face, Iran's nuclear program. I don't want Iran to
have the bomb. I'm not pro Iran. Obviously, >> we're not
pro Iran.
>> Like, why do we have to say it? >> It's done.
But at the same time that everybody was looking
>> to Iran, our largest city had a Democratic primary,
effectively the mayor's race. and a like 32-year-old socialist
who wants governmentr run grocery stores
gets gets elected. He's going to likely
wait are the grocery stores in Russia not governmentrun.
What is Tucker saying? Doesn't he believe in government run grocery
stores? I don't even know what he's saying right now. >> Run
our biggest city.
>> In the in the country, >> right? In New York.
>> And it's like why did that happen? And is it because
people are so like desperate for government run grocery stores
or love socialism or love like foreignb born midwits running
their cities? I probably not.
>> That guy was the only person in the New York City mayor's
debate >> I see. >> To say he wanted to focus on
New York >> Oh yeah, but this is this is just facts. Okay.
This is just facts. And you know exactly why Ben doesn't like
this. If he if Ben's criticizing this point, you know exactly
why it is, right? Oh, I think Ben's criticism of Tucker was this
is the only time you mentioned him to was to like say something
positive. But the real problem is that I think Tucker's going
to expand on this and say when they got asked what foreign country
would you visit first?
Zora Mamani said I don't care about other countries. I want to
focus on this country. And everyone else was like fly me out
to Israel right now. Right now. >> They were all the candidates
were asked if you could visit a foreign country what would it
be? And they of course all had an answer. I think most said Israel.
Great. And he said I wouldn't go anywhere. I'd stay in New York
>> and like if I want to meet constituents, I go to their
synagogues, their homes or whatever. But I'd be here in New York
because that's what I'm doing. I'm running New York. That's my
job. >> Well, he gave the right answer. >> He gave
the right answer. He gave the right answer at least. And he's
talking I totally oppose his program just
>> I don't think it works. But um he's talking about economics.
>> And everyone else is talking about foreign policy. >> So
he said what I said. I'm describing to you why mom Donnie won
and you're angry that people are assessing why that happened.
Doesn't matter how many times you call somebody an anti-semite.
People appreciated. It's very obvious the fact that he was not
focused on foreign policy issues when there's so many domestic
ones to prove from. You got to learn why you lose elections.
And it's not Tucker's job to get people elected, least of all
in cities that he doesn't live in. Now, I want to also show you
what Ben said about me. Uh, I really can't talk to Candace about
this after tonight, but also [laughter] she >> because
it's it's so outrageous about dishonest that you we actually
should process what is happening here. Okay, this is a watershed
moment. Ben does not have it together. He is very insecure and
he's going on the attack against Megan Kelly by lying about what
I said and then forcing her to react to the evil of what I never
said. Here's what Ben said. >> We're in a business where
people comment on on what we say publicly.
You know, again, this is why, you know, I think you and I differ
on our angle with regard to, for example, Candace Owens. I think
that what Candace Owens is doing right now is evil. It is evil
what she is doing right now. Okay. And I say that
>> But what what >> because Okay. And I say that
again. >> But what what
>> I I didn't know pine on whether it's evil or not. >> I
need I need the one specific face. that one. I think I'm cooking
it right >> But what what
>> like I I didn't know pine on whether it's evil or not,
but my my position is it's really none of my business. And >> why
is it But I have a question. Why is it none of your business?
I mean, you you you comment on these things for a
>> I'm not mother of the internet. >> No, but but
if this were on the left and somebody were accusing Charlie Kirk
of of his wife having murdered him, I assume that you would be
talking about >> Is that what Candace is accusing Erica
>> Of murdering her own husband? She's She's accusing TPUSA
insiders and other members of the rightwing, including Seth Dylan,
of being involved in the murder of Charlie Kirk. Yes.
>> It's just a It's I don't even know how to respond to
it cuz it just never happened. It's so crazy. It's so He's
>> Every time this happens with Candace, it's so funny
cuz she's going to go, "I never said that. That's so crazy."
And then somebody's going to respond with a clip compilation
of her going, "Uh, would somebody who didn't murder their husband
really do this?" I'm just asking questions. Would somebody who
didn't assist in Charlie Kirk's murder really take those tapes?
Would somebody who didn't assist? Isn't it weird how the medical
examiner said he had bones of steel? And then and then that doesn't
make any sense. And there was definitely a second shooter at
a second location. It's like they'll she'll just be doing all
of these things and she'll be like, "I never once even remotely
said that Erica had something to do with Charlie's murder." Isn't
it really weird how Erica's like totally benefiting from this?
Qui botto benefits. I'm just asking questions. It's not even
anywhere near what's happened. Anybody who's watched this show,
I actually was getting flack from my audience for not covering
Erica's past or speaking about her parents. I said she gave one
of the most consequential speeches and I have focused my investigation
on Turning Point USA and why they're telling certain lies. Seth
Dylan, I told the truth that Seth Dylan lied about the Hampton's
meeting and that he was pushing uh he was pressuring Charlie
about the topic of Israel. I never once accused Seth Dylan of
murdering Charlie Kirk. So, what's he actually doing here? Right.
Obviously,
there's a lot of layers that we should peel back and it's important
that we do it. The least interesting part of this is the fact
that he's lying through his teeth. That's implied he's a Zionist,
but there's a lot more that's happening. That mean
she I hate when people say
I hate it when people say now when you say Zionist you put some
spice on that. It's like kind of like a but that's just that's
definitely what she's doing, isn't it? I just ah
somehow with Candace I just hear it.
>> I just hear it. >> This is the fact that he's
lying through his teeth. That's implied he's a Zionist. But >> yeah,
he's lying. He's a Zionist.
He's a Zionist.
I hear it. We hear it. We all hear it. >> there's a lot
more that's happening. >> Oh, hold on. What is this? What
is this Spencer tweet?
Let me see. [laughter]
What the
I literally don't Oh, [laughter] the rings. I was like, I don't
I don't understand the tweet. The rings.
How many Super Bowls did this? Dude, I'm sorry. I I just I can't
stop counting wins. I think I was I sat here. I'm like, dude,
Erica Kirk ain't going nowhere. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. She's not
She doesn't have it. She doesn't have it. And here she is. And
literally everybody's already at her throat. Okay. It took one
It took two months
for the Widower for the Yeah. the Widow's like buff to wear off
and it's like gone entirely now and it's just open season. >> She
She ain't got it. Okay.
She ain't got it.
>> That meets the eye because Ben Shapiro was effectively
the final boss of the pro-Israel lobby. And it's because he never
comes out and says what he means. He's kind of like more of a
behind-the-scenes person. And we're now watching him come undone
in real time. Because no matter who you are in this age of digital
media, it is simply not a good idea to lie through your teeth.
Okay. Wrong time. 2025. Before you get >> Bro, that's crazy
hearing Candace say that to you [laughter]
guys. 2025 is just not a good idea to lie through your teeth.
I really don't want any more competition as I lie through my
teeth. Hi, please don't come compete with me. I'm the only one
doing it right now.
Like, shut. This is literally the Spider-Man pointing at Spider-Man
thing. It's so obvious. It's >> come undone in real time
because no matter who you are in this age of digital media, it
is simply not a good idea to lie through your teeth. Okay, wrong
time. 2025.
Before you get the lie out, the internet is going to clock it,
right? They're going to go back and be like, "You lied." And
when you do something like that, the blowback is going to be
on you. They're going to go. >> Dude, how are there not
people who do super funny Candace edits where she's like, I never
suggested that Erica Kirk had something to do with her husband's
death and you line up the clips and then you weave in her about
how she never lies and about how you can't lie in 2025.
Like, there's so many funny clips you could do on Candace Owens
and it just never happens. I don't know. >> Oh, actually,
this now impacts your credibility. You said that Candace went
out and said something about Erica. By the way, you hear the
people in the background going, "Woo! Woo. I'm going to tell
you what's happening there, too, and you're going to see how
this thing really works.
>> I already I already pointed it out. I don't trust those
people when they cheer. Okay.
>> Point number one that I want to make about how why >> what
Ben is doing right here is just the stunning hypocrisy of it.
>> Okay, the rules for thee and not for me. I am getting
old. My memory is getting a little fuzzy, but I distinctly remember
the week that I was gloriously fired from the Daily Wire. And
during that week, the CEO of the Daily Wire, at the time it was
Jeremy Boring,
jumped onto an XSpace hosted by Lauren Chen and had a conversation
with Nick Fuentes. >> Dude, actually, fantastic. Hold on.
Fantastic point. When do you guys remember when Jeremy Boring
hopped on with Nick and was like, "Nick, I love your show. You're
so talented. You're really hateful. I don't agree with everything
you say, but like you are so talented. I love your show. I love
your show. Did I say that? I love your show, DUDE. I FORGOT I
I knew about it. I I bring it up all the time. I used to bring
it up all the time and I just forgot mentioning it. I stopped
mentioning it. But yes, Candace Cook, actually,
a fantastic point. Jeremy Boring, co-CEO or sorry, not co-founder
of the Daily Wire, CEO of The Daily Wire, jumped on and was like,
"Nick, I watch your show all the time. You're very funny. You're
very talented. You're very hateful though and I don't like that.
It's like why did he jump on and say exactly the same thing Tucker
did >> where he sang Nick Fuentes's praises and also invited
him onto the Daily Wire. Okay, here's a headline because the
Huffington Post remembers too. Daily Wire CEO tells white supremacist
Nick Fuentes that he's talented and he's very funny. The article
goes on during a live streamed conversation with white supremacist
Nick Fuentes last week. The CEO of the Daily Wire, a major right-wing
media outlet, praised the prominent fascist influencer and offered
only mild. Boring told Fuentes he listens to Fentes's show quite
often and that he thinks Fuentes is very funny and one of the
most talented political influencers, even if he is very concerned
about some of what Fentes says. This is literally what Tucker
said. Oh, Candace Candace hit on a narrative here that works.
Yes, this was this is what people should be blasting out everywhere.
Hey Ben, why didn't you uh why didn't you call Jeremy when he
did this? Why are you calling O Tucker and not Jeremy?
>> Huh? Old criticism about some of his political views
a start. >> Oh, did you ban the French person? I figured
they're giving me KCIP. I don't know if they're a bot or what.
They're like saying a bunch of random [__]
but I Yeah, I was just like >> difference from how he has
spoken about Fuentes in the past. On March 25th, the Daily Wire
CEO Jeremy Boring
>> JC ain't beating the Groper allegations tonight. The
Groper allegations. Nobody's ever said that about me. Liar >> joined
Fuentes on X for a live audio chat room. Boring told Fentes that
he listens to >> This is an anti-Ben Shapiro space. Okay.
All of their opinions are respected. All of their opinions are
given their fair shake. We just hate Ben Shapiro here. It's packwatch
on Ben Shapiro. [__] this guy. Rip bozo >> Fuentes's
show quite often and that he thinks Fuentes is quote unquote
very funny and one of the most talented political influencers
even if he is very concerned about some of what Fuentes says.
Later in the discussion, Boring said that he'd be thrilled to
have Fuentes on one of the Daily Wires shows to debate the media
company's popular pundits, some of whom have millions of
This happened. So I I want you just to remember this because
I feel like people are not appreciating how hypocritical it is
that he's now trying to struggle session Megan Kelly because
oh he had Fuentes on the show when the Daily Wire position in
was that their CEO could talk to Nick Fuentes publicly, praise
Nick Fuentes publicly and also invite Nick Fuentes onto the Daily
Wire platform. We can actually we should actually take a listen
to a little bit of that conversation. >> Oh, Candace is
cooking. Candace is
boiling Ben Shapiro right now. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. You shouldn't have You shouldn't let Jeremy off the leash.
Shouldn't have done it.
>> Between Jeremy Boring, then CEO Daily Wire and Nick
Fuentes. Take a listen. >> People can say, "Well, I don't
like what you say about this and that." I don't like that guys
like Shapiro cannot will not say Christ is king, America first.
I think they forfeit their ability to lead. I I would never listen
to somebody that can't say those things cuz I mean those things
are really the foundation of wisdom which is the love of God
which as you say goes through the sun as we all know can only
go through Jesus and oilia which is you know your love of your
home your love of your homeland that you reside in
not some other homeland. So I just want to get that across to
you. So, it's kind of a >> Isn't it ironic that he is using
Standis Owens, the Standest Owens alt?
>> Strange circumstance that we're talking, but that's
how I feel about >> And I'll say this, Nick, that I listen
to your show quite often. I think you're one of the most talented
people out there, and I'm very concerned about some of the things
that you're saying. I wish uh Turns out that anybody who wanted
to be informed on politics and the direction American populism
was going to move was watching the Nick Fentes program to see
what he was saying. Um, I I was watching cuz I was like, "Oh,
these Daily Wire people are all copying from him." And Jeremy
Boring was watching cuz he was like, "I need to know what we're
cop copying next month."
Different purposes, but it was kind of interesting. I >> I
think that you're a very gifted communicator. And so, it's hard
for me to imagine that you consistently
uh some of these things. And I'll I'll hope that I'm wrong and
yield the floor back to all the people who actually came on here
to talk to each other. I mean, during this stuff, I was definitely
just like the DGG streamer already,
right? Like, I literally covered this on stream, the Standest
Owens call. >> Anybody want to help me out? Why it's now
different? Hm. What could be different now that it was okay when
the Daily Wire was open to doing it and then Tucker did it and
now it's suddenly not okay and it's the worst sin that could
ever happen to speak to Nick Fuentes.
Point number two I'm going to make here is the stunning hypocrisy
again, okay, of him picking the topic of Charlie Kirk, to pretend
that he's noble uh to to
pretend like he has to say something even though he's lying in
defense of what's happening to Charlie Kirk's widow when it is
just a fact that Ben Shapiro did a lot of things behind the scenes
to stop the rise of Charlie Kirk. It's a fact. Okay, here's another
text message. I
Uh,
dude, Candace is this guy today. I saw a little preview of these
earlier. All right, Candace is murdering this guy >> We
have literal hundreds of them pertaining to Ben sending his YAF
boys, the AF boys, National Review peeps that were coming after
us, writing articles. The one that I showed in this little uh
uh our thumbnail here, uh we can show this conversation.
Um yeah, it was it was a headline. Ben Shapiro's YAF launches
smear campaign against Charlie Kirk and Candace Owens. Hey Charlie,
wherever you are, it's happening again. It's [laughter] just
like just a smear campaign. I don't know why, but this is what
Ben does. And it is also interesting
that when I was telling you that Ben called Charlie and he was
lamenting the fact that Charlie and I had this friendship and
warning him that he shouldn't have him. Charlie felt like Ben
was like throwing down like slave owner vibes and he was just
like he thinks I like own you or something. But I'm going to
show you the text messages cuz otherwise you'll say it didn't
happen. Here we go. Uh this was again everything we Ben was going
on people's shows and and talking down about me and Charlie and
he said you're bigger than Ben now. I'm walking into the White
House yesterday. I realize that. I said I know he hates it. He
said we just have to treat him like noise. He wants you to punch
down to him. His respect amongst movement fighters is quite low.
I feel like that's relevant right now to what Ben's doing. He
wants to egg on this fight because he's >> Dude, she's
just like she's just looking for a reason to leak these Charlie
texts talking [__] about Ben. She's been waiting.
Just give me any reason. Just give me any reason to leak this.
Ben, make my make my day, Ben. Make my day. Lost a certain bit
of respect. Um, and then Charlie goes on, you got in his head,
which is terrific. The Ben thing involves me more than he wants
to admit. And then we went on and this is the same
He knows that Jon Snow, he's using a Game of Thrones reference,
is stronger as the dragons fly higher. and he said it pissed
him off and he is sending
>> uh the Ben thing involves me more than he wants to admit.
He knows Jon Snow is stronger as the dragons fly higher. This
is a Game of Thrones thing. I used to be a song a song of ice
and fire like Lord Nerd. The does this even mean? This is not
saying anything cogent or coherent whatsoever. This makes no
sense.
You just said Jon Snow and Dragons is totally nonsensical. >> His
brother to go try and kill us. It's worse. He views you as my
slave. 100%. Control her is what he really was saying to me when
he called. So, this has been And by the way, like I said, I have
>> bro. Ben, dude, Charlie Kirk. Charlie Kirk talks so
much. He was actually such like a
behind the scenes when he wasn't out in front of a bunch of people.
He was like just talking everybody to Candace Owens apparently.
It's kind of >> what he really was saying to me when he
called. So, this has been and and by the way, like I said, I
have hundreds of these messages. And so, you have to imagine
being in my position when you see someone who did everything
he could to kind of stop the rise of Charlie Kirk, now trying
to struggle session Megan, who was actually a very good friend
to Charlie. Charlie deeply respected her. And towards the end,
obviously, she took a very principled position on telling the
truth about what he was going through. and Charlie dies and suddenly
he's like, I care about this evil that could be h Candace is
investigating who killed her friend and and she shouldn't be
doing that. I mean, there's no way to spin it. What is his suggestion
here that me asking questions about Turning Point USA somehow
means that I'm blaming Erica who wasn't even working for Turning
Point USA uh when Charlie died? Because now >> I dude there's
definitely going to be all I know about Candace is like her demeanor
when she is wrong and this to me I'm like dude there's like a
clip somewhere out there of her just being like I just want to
know where Erica Kirk was that day. That's all I just want to
know. Like she she disappeared for like 15 minutes before the
shot rang out and I just want to know what she was doing. I feel
like there's a clip like that out there somewhere of Candace
Owens just totally
100% implying that Erica Kirk had something to do with it and
now she's like I absolutely did not. I would never
you No. Absolutely not. You're disgusting for suggesting that.
Every time she gets like this it's like oh there's there's a
clip of her doing this 100%.
It's just like I every single time without fail. >> Oh
she's the CEO. Of course he doesn't believe that. And it is just
so to me it is truly
so gross to do this to a person that you know you tried to block
and you just now that he's dead I guess you want to sort of rewrite
history. That's what you're you're trying to rewrite history
and pretend that you're his ardent defender. Now another point
that I'd like to make >> is the stunning hypocrisy again
and again when you stop and you consider
that he's pressing Megan and referring to this as an evil. the
thing that I never said or did. But this is the same Ben Shapiro
that work roots the destruction of Gaza on. He supports and congratulated
Randy Fine who has literally tweeted laughing at photos of dead
Palestinian babies. But I guess Tucker Carlson speaking to Nick
Fuentes is just so much >> point out the BB relationship.
T say he's friends close personal friends with BB Netanyahu.
Point that out next. >> worse than celebrating and not
just celebrating interviewing a man who is committing an actual
genocide. Okay. >> that's up for debate. That's what they're
trying him for. BB Netany and Yahoo is committing a genocide
and Ben Shapiro sat down with him last month.
>> And do you guys think he pressed BB Netany and Yahoo
on the >> Hey Ben, why didn't you ask BB why he's so many
kids?
Oh, she hitting every note. Candace showed up to play today.
Okay. Every every once in a while, Candace shows up to play and
she makes a great a bunch of great points. Today is one of those
days except the point I I'm pretty sure that she didn't suggest
Erica Kirk had something to do with it. Other than that, she
showed up to play today. Okay. She got all the best examples.
>> Point of a genocide.
I don't understand how you could just go out there with your
hair on your chest and your chest you're just like, "Yeah, how
dare you? How dare you not make a comment, Megan, about Tucker
Carlson? How dare you not make a comment? I care now about Charlie
Kirk now that he's dead. I care about him and what's happening.
Candace is trying to find out who killed him. That's evil.
You're lying. You You lie when you have nothing left. So the
question is become question becomes what is Ben actually doing
here? Because it's certainly not principled. I think we can put
that to bed. It's actually also risky behavior when it comes
to Ben Shapiro. like he doesn't usually come out of the gate
like that. And I think a couple of things are driving this unforced
error. One, I do believe that he is actually scared of Nick Fuentes.
Okay, I think that fear comes. [laughter]
Dude, Candace is just straight up 100% trying to bait Ben now.
Like, hey, I I said this earlier. I think everybody's just going
to be like, "Hey, Ben, why don't you just debate him? Aren't
you the debater? Ben, I thought you debated people. Ben, didn't
St. Charlie decide that debate is the way we solve all of our
problems. Ben, are you going against the teachings of St. Charlie?
I don't think you can do that, Ben.
>> From guilt, Nick's backstory. Don't care what you think
about him. You already know I don't like Nick Nick because of
how he treated me. Um, but the backstory is compelling. I learned
the backstory listening to Jeremy Boring, the former CEO of Daily
Wire, sit down with Nick. So I right after I've been fired and
I I didn't know what Ben and Jeremy admitted that they they did
to him. And so I think if you artificially push somebody out
of the market and Ben has never come out and denied anything
that Nick Fuentes has said. Um also Jeremy Borington tonight
in a conversation with him. So we have to assume the story is
true. And given what I know about what happens now I think and
what Charlie was going through I think we can all realize that
Nick was an 18-year-old kid like he told Tucker. And now the
whole world knows his story. He started asking questions about
Israel and he got artificially pushed out of the market when
he had his whole life ahead of him.
>> Okay.
A little bit.
I don't like these these people kind of all run with this
that Nick was like totally ununderstandably and unjustifiably
pushed out. Maybe you could argue he deserves some forgiveness
as a kid. Okay. But I
every single time I'm just going to push back on this idea that
he didn't know what he was doing, that he wasn't trying to agitate
in this specific like anti-Semitic way against Ben Shapiro. I'm
just pretty confident that's true, that he knew exactly what
he was doing. He knew what would happen. Like he knew he knew
he was agitating Ben and Ben just happened to come down hard
on him for it. But I think he 100% knew he was going to he wasn't
just asking questions. He was like making pointed, you know,
quest statements him. Okay. And now when they did this because
they wanted to rid themselves of Nick Fuentes who then became
angry about it and definitively has said very offensive things
on the internet but also he was 18 19 years old. Uh now you see
him on >> he said offensive things like last year when
he's 25 years old. >> Tucker Carlson you don't like Tucker
Carlson and I think
dude you can do this whole thing without having to go and you
know Nick's barely said anything. What? What? He was He said
like some things when he was 18, 19. I don't think you should
use those
but like he's done more he's done way more than that. It's just
weird to Nobody can get it just right. Nobody's Goldilocks on
this. They're either like, "Oh, how why would you call this guy
an anti-semite? Don't you think that's wrong to just paint him
as an anti-semite?"
And then other people are like, "Absolutely cancel him now. Here's
a clip of the Cookie Monster thing from 2019."
Like, just you between those two. Get between those two. Those
are like the absolute polar the like the the two poles of the
situation. Get between them and don't fail the giant slalom.
Okay. >> It makes him uncomfortable. I think we're in Harry
Potter, right? And Lord Voldemort thought he killed the baby
and the baby may be lit. I don't even know who the dark.
Candace is just glossing this guy right now. Okay. Absolutely
disgusting.
You're going to make Nick Fentes Harry
>> Come on. >> Lord is in the story. But I do know
I don't I don't even know who he should not must not be named
is in the story. But I do know that with Ben and Nick Fuentes
is kind of a neither can live while the other survives. And Nick
Fuentes seems to have survived. Okay. Without advertises
is the boy who lived. Uh Ben Shapiro is Voldemort. Okay. All
right. Uh
start rolling the memes out. All right. There's going to be so
many memes from this. This is a crazy compar. It's a crazy thing
to say, bro. I'm sorry. She really is in love with him. Okay,
Nick literally called it directly that like she's not over him.
She is in love with him. He loves me. He loves me not. She's
just fully came out here and was like, "Whatever it Ben Shapiro,
I'm out here 100% on Nick's side."
izers, without sponsors, without connections,
um, with the entire media writing things about [laughter] >> No,
no, no. Crisp. Chris, he just has two lightning bolts on his
forehead instead of one. Book it. That's the meme. Nick Flintis
is Harry Potter, but he's got two lightning bolts. >> Him
being put on the ADL's list. He has proven to be quite resilient,
and it is in large part due to how hard they fight him that people
become curious. It's like, what? You're we're watching kids be
bombed. Like, how many people have lost their lives in Gaza?
And you're telling me the greatest evil is is Nick Fuentes. I
I'm sorry. I think I can survive Nick Fentes insulting me. I
don't feel the need to wheel and deal behind the scenes or, you
know, tell Tucker not to host him. I just don't care. It's just
really not my business. I'm like Megan. I just don't care. Like,
okay, if somebody wants to be a fan, they can be a fan of Nick
Fuentes. And I I sense an insecurity here in the fact that 10
years on from when Ben had this thing that happened to Nick Fuentes
that he tells a story about, now Nick Fuentes is still here and
and Ben's influence is waning. It just factually is. Okay. Another
thing that's happening here, and this is on the point of Megan
Kelly and and going back to the woo making it sound like Ben's
got a popular position about me. I sense that the pro-Israel
lobby is on the brink of collapse. They are desperate for allies,
right? And they're so desperate for allies that they're forcing
them away. That's what they're doing to me and Kelly, right?
They're showing the world right now they are willing to lie to
get what they want. Ben is lying right now to get what he wants.
And for whatever reason, the prog believes that this repeat failed
strategy of lying and threatening people
is going to work. Now, you might be asking, "Well, how is Megan
Kelly being threatened here?" This is exactly what Ben just did
on stage. That is exactly the moral blackmail that Charlie was
speaking about in the last days of his life. Okay, Ben is morally
blackmailing Megan, right? He's sitting across from her. The
threat is her reputation. He's standing there and he's saying,
"Candice is attacking a grieving widow and accusing her of murdering
Charlie Kirk. Will you disavow this evil on the spot?"
And he's got these fake people going, "Woo! Woo! Yeah. And you
you can see Megan's uncomfortable because she's like, "Well,
did she say that, man?" Like, "Maybe that is evil. Like, that's
Does that happen?" He doubles down. He's like, "Yes." She said,
"Seth Dylan murdered Charlie Kirk." Do will you disavow this
evil on the spot?
That is moral blackmail. Are you a better person than to accept
Candace Owens who has attacked a grieving widow and is saying
to that grieving widow that you murdered your own husband?
That is moral blackmail. Now, speaking of on the spot, everything
that you just saw happen here and Megan Kelly, I hope you see
this. Truly, you guys send this clip to her. It's this is really
important. >> It is pre-planned.
It is not organic. The supporters are not organic. The questions
are not organic. We can pull back another layer of this onion
so you can understand how vicious politics is cuz it is vicious.
You might remember, maybe you forgot, but I spoke at YWLS in
2024, right after I was fired from the Daily Wire and a big thing
happened and we should never forget it. Okay, while I was heading
to speak at this event, we learned because there was an intern
at the Daily Wire who had a conscience and she felt very uncomfortable
with the secret mission that she was put on. We learned that
a covert mission was happening where they were sending an intern
to ask me a question. Okay. To get my answer on the question
and then what was going to happen next is they were going to
>> What question? They sent an intern to find out Candace's
answer on the question. H >> pass around a clip, but they
were going to make it look like she was just a a random student.
Let me show you a clip because we found this out. I called it
out on stage. Charlie intercepted. We found what her name was
and I called this girl out on stage. Take a listen, >> you
guys. >> Oh, was Ben Was Ben trying to engage in a little
groer war of his own? Is that what we're saying?
Ben was trying to out grope TPUSA
trying to he
he co-opted some tactics, did he? is um the last thing that I
am going to say strangely this is such a crazy story but as I
was headed in here I got a a frantic call from somebody they
did they called me and they said Candace uh something very weird
is happening the Daily Wire has sent somebody secretly to record
you um an an intern a PR intern to secret >> Wait why did
she sign up with the company after this she joined the Daily
Wire after this >> really record to to catch you in a bad
moment, in a bad light. And I think that that intern's name.
No,
to be fair, it is never the fault of a person when their employer
is sending them to do something that isn't good. But I would
really love it if Ariana >> Oh, this is from last year.
Oh, never mind then. This is totally
Oh, she did look she looks how she looks now. So, I did think
that it wasn't going to be um I thought it was more recent, but
then I'm like, "Oh, she if she's TPUSA, this must be before.
I didn't realize Charlie was getting her to go out and do TPUSA
events after she left the Daily Wire 2." Interesting.
>> Stood up. Yeah.
Okay. Maybe that's a little too intimidating for you, too. But
apparently, she got an email at 10 p.m. Hopped on a plane pretending
to be a student. Um
>> what she has been since before she was at the Daily
Wire, right? I think she was always a TPUSA contributor. I'm
pretty sure. Yeah. >> Um, and so I do just want to say
to Ben Shapiro, enough.
Come out into the light. Really, come on. Let's do this debate.
Stop sending interns to do your dirty work.
Uh, the reason I have more problem with Ben Shapiro than um than
Fuentes or Candace is I think a lot of like the at least informed
people have an accurate read on Fuentes, accurateish,
at least in terms of how harmful he could be. And the same for
Candace.
I don't think people realize or I think people give Ben way too
much credit
or if they hate Ben, they hate Ben for the wrong reasons. Ben
is detestable because he didn't give a [__] about
the racism in the Republican party, about the illogical way that
that they were using like uh he didn't he didn't care about the
demagoguery going on so long as it was aimed away from the group
he cared about. The second it was pointed at the group he cared
about, suddenly he could identify all of the problems.
Ben, okay, because he was somebody who knew better and he stuffed
that down into his heart. He he took the things he could identify.
He started ignoring them because he could get a paycheck.
that guy. It's like so much worse to me somehow than like than
Fuentes being on the wrong path, right? Not to excuse what he's
doing, but he is clearly going in the wrong direction. And for
him to do that despite all the the advers uh not uh the
oh adverse circumstances he's been through.
Candace, a lot of adverse circumstances, too. Although pretty
streets were also kind of paid with gold at different points,
right?
So, I I just have this issue with Ben that he was willing to
build all this up, he's willing to build up Trump, he's willing
to whitewash everything he did, and the second all of that work
he did comes back to hurt him, he's like, "Oh, you guys are being
anti-Semitic. Oh, this is so [__] up. How did we
get here, Ben? You know exactly how we got here. This is literally
the reason you were against Trump when he first campaigned. You
just thought you could manipulate him. You thought you could
manipulate his supporters, and you were >> I don't fight.
I'm down for the debate. Charlie Kirk says he will fly you out.
He will fly you out next week to Detroit and we can do the debates
on his stage. Thank you, Turning Point USA. Let's take some questions.
You know the Turning Point USA that I wasn't a part of, but that's
how it went down. And Charlie was like, "Yeah, that's crazy that
this is happening." And he's like, "Call him out on stage and
offer the debate and I will fly him out personally to come debate
you on this." But this is how it works, okay? They send people,
they make it look like it's organic. They'll send people to your
events and they will have people applaud. That was orchestrated
by Alyssa Cordova now that she's not at the Daily Wire. I can
say that who I was calling out yesterday. But it's so important
for people to get this. What is happening at Megan's events,
I will guarantee you people coming and asking her questions and
trying to get her to disavow Tucker Carlson. That is not organic.
Okay? That is pro-Israel people that are paid to do it. Honestly,
Megan, if you're watching, you give me the list of your attendees.
I'm assuming this is a ticketed event. I will find the people.
They will be from YAF. They will be from some organization. If
you let me go for the names, I love an investigation. I will
tell you how many people were sent there to go [laughter]
I it'd be so funny if Megan Kelly took her up on this, right?
She's just like, "Yeah, that's totally astroturf. Those people
cheering, those people are totally fake." They were cheering
at every single thing Ben said. Now, the unfortunate thing for
Candace is it's a conservative like conference thing. It's a
conservative like live event. A good chance there's a lot of
Zionist there. Okay. Like just actual overt Zionist.
I was looking for the PVD clip earlier.
>> There's a couple things I want you to be thinking about.
Number one, you are
>> That's what I imagine when Candace calls Ben out for
the debate. I just think of PBD trying to get him to debate Candace
Owens. That's what this is, by the way. PBD invites Ben Shapiro
and this person for a charitable debate. It was against Oh, this
used to be This must have been Candace Owen's old channel or
something. Channel name 445.
This must have been C. Yeah. 2.99 million subscribers. This was
Candace Owen's old channel. Oh, that's crazy.
>> And and Rorus Applaude
actually trying to intimidate you and to force you to take a
position and to make you feel uncomfortable because it's a part
of that moral blackmail pileup. And so, I'm actually genuinely
not upset. I don't care. I I believe in the free markets. I genuinely
will say again, I will always debate Ben Shapiro. If you know,
if if Tucker left you on Red and you want to come on this show
and you want to debate Israel and you want to discuss Erica Kirk
and the things I never said, if you want to discuss your relationship
with Charlie Kirk, anything that I have said that you would like
to dispute, my platform is your platform. I'd say you should
come on my platform cuz my show is bigger now. Uh but we could
also do yours. So, hit me up. We'll be right back after a brief
break. All right, you guys. I've been speaking a lot about Riverbend
Ranch because you guys know I love their steaks. Black Angus
beef that is famous for its great flavor. Riverbend Ranch has
taken black Angus beef to a whole new level because over the
last 35 years, Riverbend Ranch has been creating an elite to
Angus herd by using ultrasound to select genetically superior
cattle with a focus on flavor and tenderness. Each year, Riverbend
Ranch provides about 850 elite black Angus bulls containing these
special genetics to over 260 western US ranches. Those partnership
ranches receive a substantial premium from Riverbend Ranch to
raise those calves without the use of growth hormones and without
antibiotics. And every fall, the calves containing these elite
genetics return to Riverbend Ranch to spend the following summer
in lush mountain
pastures. So when you purchase from Riverbend Ranch, you're not
only supporting the financial strategy one
same process by single tour stop trying to struggle session her
into making.com.
That's candace likesold.com.
I'm serious you guys. Megan Kelly, make sure you let her know
in her comments. Blow her up because I have seen it before. I
know exactly what's happening and they are going to be at every
single tour stop trying to struggle session
>> Yo, extoay, thank for the 14 months. Let's go. >> And
making a comment. It's just it's weird. I don't know why they
keep demanding that she disavows
uh Tucker and Candace. I don't work with Megan Kelly, but I know
how this goes. It's the It's the exact same process by which
the pro-Israel lobby lost Charlie Kirk because eventually [music]
you just get tired of being bullied and you start to sense and
see that it's not organic and also it's not coming from your
quote unquote friends. I just would never do this. I it it wouldn't
even
flash in my mind as an idea that I should text Tucker Carlson
and tell him who he should or should not have on his platform
or how he should use his platform. It doesn't. It's just not
how normal people behave and they don't understand how abnormal
it is. Anyways, switching gears here. I got to show you a couple
of clips. They're going viral right now. And CNN has cut these
clips because they think they're embarrassing to me. So, there's
this young woman. She's the same age as me. Uh, El Reeve is her
name. And I'm going to be also be clear. I got very testy in
this interview because it was >> Oh, she had an interview
on CNN. Oh. Oh, do we watch this? I'm like I wasn't This isn't
really a part of the story. We'll have to like cut over to do
this, I think. But um I'm actually kind of interested in what
this would be. CNN's going after Do What do you guys think? >> A
couple days after Charlie was killed. First interview I was giving
out.
It wasn't about Charlie Kirk, but we were we had set this up
before and I decided to keep the appointment. You know, I hadn't
been sleeping. I hadn't been eating. And this woman, I guess,
decided that she just >> Bro, there's a lot of cope coming
through. This must have been a disaster. >> Wanted to poke
a bear. Anyways, she's the one passing around. >> Uh maybe
we watch this a little bit after. Okay, I'm I just realized that
we're on a schedule. We got 47 minutes, guys. We are If we wanted
to, we are
four five We're seven subs for another two hours. If we wanted
to do two more, you know what? We're not going to do that. We're
going to do $40 for one hour. So, we we'll do
like three subs from another hour. Is that right? I think so.
Like three subs from another hour on the stream if you guys wanted
to add that. >> This clip >> cuz I just think I don't
want to go the full 8 hours tonight cuz of the technical difficulties
and stuff and I'm a little tired, but I'd also do it. I'll just
I'll throw the uh the new thing >> She thinks it totally
embarrasses me and shows that I'm a white nap. >> No, no,
no. We Sorry. Three subs is not 40 bucks. Three subs is to get
us to $40 from the previous two hours that were added. So, we
have 12 subs. That gets us two hours when it's 60 for two. And
then we have four extra subs. One sub from the donations. That's
five.
And there's three more. 5 + 3 is 8. 8 * 5 is 40. $40. Boom. Just
do math. >> Nationalist. Take a listen. >> You can
criticize Netanyahu without being anti-Israel. You can criticize
Israel without >> being anti-semitic. But some of the themes,
talking points, concepts you've used in your criticism of Israel,
um, I'm very familiar with from covering white nationalists for
10 years. It's very unsettling for me to hear things like you
saying our government is occupied by Zionist. Trump is occupied
by Zionists. We're an occupi occupied nation. Um, because like
there's literally a term that's like an 80s90s
>> Don't you think that's kind of like Zog? Uh, don't you
think that's the point is that hey, wake the up. Maybe maybe
you are the person who's propagandized here. Maybe I don't have
the irrational belief. Maybe you have the irrational belief because
you disagree.
Think about that. Would you think about >> Zag Zionist
occupied government. It's their idea that control the world.
And I'm wondering like are you intentionally referencing those
kind of things? >> Wait, just to slow down. Are you accusing
me of white nationalist rhetoric? Cuz I do have to have a little
bit of a gel about that first. >> Well, that's I mean to
me I'm also like no fan of yours. >> It's just it's silly.
But this is one of the things where I feel like it's such a lesson
for SN. This is why nobody watches anymore. I mean it's like
you're sitting across from a black person. You're like I've learned
about white nationalism and you're using white >> Like
I know them. my [__] [laughter] >> Candace
is trying to use Candace is like, I'm interviewing with CNN.
This is a this is an SJW type woman. If I just tap into the white
guilt, she'll tap out instantly. Okay, I'm just going to I'm
going to use the white guilt against
>> I've read other text. >> I get it. I know. I'm
so glad you're educated, but this is when it's like put it in
a book and anybody will say it. It's like it's just at a certain
point you have to use your eyes and go, "Is Candace Owen?" >> Why
is Candace pretending Zog isn't a well-known term?
just say, "Hey, just because it was a racist term doesn't mean
it's irrelevant today. Doesn't mean it's not useful." In fact,
sometimes if people have made that seem like it's a conspiracy,
maybe it's important to defeat that conspiracy in general. Maybe
it's important to say it and then when somebody says it's an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory, you start spitting Apac numbers
or something, right? How about How about that, Candace? How about
you just lean into your actual beliefs? Don't cower away. >> Is
promoting white nationalist rhetoric. Okay. Immediately, no.
So what else could it be? Could it be that actually Zionism is
is what what it actually >> What does that mean?
>> Oh, Nick Fentes is the boy who lived
>> What a curious scar.
If you look into the history, yes, I believe we are a Zionist
occupied government and we're not the only one. Okay. Yes. And
I take it to the bank. If you need to walk out of here and say
Canon is a white nationalist for you to be able to digest it,
then that's fine. You know, you have to do that in your own time.
But what I will say is I stand by I stand by every statement
that I made and I and I want to double down on it. Okay. America
is occupied by
>> I'd like to triple down on that if there's anybody going
I'd like to triple down on that. These tactics are super boring
and tired. And this is why it hinges upon suppressing speech,
right? Constantly having to refer to somebody as evil or white
supremacist or anti-semitic because you've lost the argument
on the B. Like there there is no merit to your argument anymore.
So it's all a constant struggle session of semantics. And then
she moves on to they. Do you remember growing up when we were
just allowed to use the word they in sentences and nobody said,
"What do you mean by that?" several times she just what do you
mean by they? As if she didn't understand how to construct a
basic sentence. Um and to refer back to the noun. Uh she has
had no idea which plural noun I was referring to. Anyways, I
was not really in the mood. And here is our conversation about
they.
They is a word. So like I don't need to always like say they
like it just it's just a weird it's like this is one of these
psychology tactics where like who is they who is they and it's
like >> cuz it sounds like you're saying
>> does the word they mean >> when you're talking
about >> yes but if I'm not talking about then they doesn't
mean Jews when >> what if I'm talking about a niche a niche
religion like the Franks who were mostly
what if I'm talking about the Frankest though what if there's
a niche group of under a different name where they actually did
all of the things most people punished for persecuted for what
if that what if I just made up a different name that meant huh
>> say they want us to believe this or they want us to
believe that and you hear that's your own derangement right if
I want to say something about I'll say it if I want to say something
about Israel I will say it if I want us just like when I want
to say something about black people I'll say it when I was saying
during BLM they want us to believe nobody said do you mean uh
and so again it's one of these trash tactics make people fearful
to speak if I want to say I will say don't fear saying when I
say Zionists run the media. I mean Zionists run the media. People
that support the political ideology.
>> When I say pay our politicians to take their side, I
mean [laughter] >> of Israel run the media. Any other things
I can help clarify? >> But are you familiar with this like
very long-standing trope? >> Who give a about a trope?
>> [__] dude.
>> I really try not to curse, but I just felt like we needed
to real quick. You know what I mean? just scared to move on from
it because I I really don't I'm so tired of these words. I'm
just I'm tired. I'm exhausted. I'm glad I watched this. We are
tired collectively. We're tired. I had to shut it down because
I suddenly realized I was homeschooling my toddlers. And I told
her I was like, "Look, I have toddlers at home. I can't teach
you, you know, basic sentence. I'm teaching my toddlers how to
read. And here I am. I'm teaching her how to understand they
in a sentence." That's a place. What are we doing? How old is
this person? And she says she's the same age as me. I'm going
you missed first grade. You don't know what they means. And now
you're just going to It's a trope. This is the way to respond.
Okay, just shut it down immediately. Embrace whatever you're
going to be called in in her in this circumstance. If I got to
be called a white supremacist to say my opinion about this administration,
how it's been occupied by Zionists and the cruelties um that
the Palestinian children are suffering at the hands of Netanyahu,
then so be it. I don't encourage you guys to cuss. It's a rare
moment. Like I said, it was a couple days after died and I just
was not in the mood. Uh but I do encourage you guys to defend
yourselves in a similar manner. Now, uh, in that same vein, if
in case you guys missed this going around, Eric and Laura Trump
spoke at a recent TPUSA event at Auburn University, and it's
a different er. >> All right. All right. We're good. We're
good on this.
Okay. What do I have after this? Oh, I was going to pull the
asenold clip.
>> Is Tucker used to be, I think,
a a deeply important part of the conservative push to win.
I think that if Ben if if if Ben really wants to
overrule Nick Fuentes's influence over I think a lot of young
people especially I think that he should engage with what Nick
is saying directly and engage Nick directly.
Nope. The worst thing Ben Shapiro could do for his movement for
his career is to engage Nick Fuentes directly. Ben Shapiro needs
to do a tactical retreat. Okay. Fabian tactics are the goal now.
Direct conflict will go very badly for you. You literally cannot.
There's almost no way to win. You'd have to have Nick Fuentes
like break down and start accusing you of poisoning of like eating
Christian children. That's like the degree you need Nick Fentes
to go totally deranged on Ben Shapiro for Ben Shapiro to win
that argument in the eyes of the public.
No, no, no, no. He cannot do this. He's incapable. He literally
should just run. Wait until you have somebody else who can go
toe-to-toe with Fentes. He should not. If if he I'm just saying
tactically for his side in the same way that I explained what
I think like Fuentes's best move might be in some given situation.
I'll just tell you Ben Shapiro's best move is to run away.
Run away. Say he's too disgusting a platform. Say you don't want
any part of it. Let somebody else handle it cuz you cannot. I
That's just facts. Okay. There every every like cultural thing
is pushing against Ben Shapiro right now. I think I think his
company's like uh like their influence is waning anyway. This
pushes it forward faster. I think you give him more time to blow
himself up. No. Uh, this would be bad, too. Puggyups. This would
be bad, too. They're more likely to freeze because they have
things they agree with Nick on that they disagree with Ben on
that they usually keep to themselves. This would be a huge mistake
as well. If Walsh or Nolles talks to him, it'll be like a It'll
be double glossing. Okay. They'll be double glossing or it'll
just be transparent. Uh, what did you mean when when you said
the Cookie Monster bakes cookies? How old were you when you said
that? That's really disgusting.
It'll just be transparent. They don't They all need to run away.
Let somebody Let listen. All you need to do start big uping Bap
or something. Okay.
Listen, Ben. Call up the other Ben Netanyahu that is. And ask
him about how he dealt with Gaza. Okay. He raised up so they
could counter the PA so that there's not a coherent like fight
against him. Okay. Okay, there's not a coherent and coordinated
enemy. That's the tactic. Okay, go find Bap in whatever weird
bath house he's in. Okay, trying to pretend he's like a Roman
soldier when he's just a weird old man. All right, go find him.
Gas him up and get him to go fight with Fuentes again. All right,
that's the play. Do not engage him directly. You will lose. That's
just that's how it is. Okay, that's what it is. That is what
it is.
Okay,
apparently there's some clips from
Let me see what the clips are from tonight. There's one more
article I want to read and then there's some clips from tonight
as well. Okay,
let's see. That's a good clip.
What is this? Fentes responding to Shapiro a little bit. >> The
guy who normally clips showing up. >> Little man, it's
time.
>> This little guy has got to go home. Little man, it's
time for you to go home to Israel. We don't want you here.
He goes around saying, "I need security everywhere I go because
everyone hates me." Well, go live in Israel. You'll be greeted
like a hero. It will be a hero's welcome when you return to Israel.
They'll play trumpets in the streets.
You'll have all of the
moatza ball soup, whatever the
you want.
Get out. Fake American. Ben Shapiro is not American. Can we just
get that
You have forfeited your right to call yourself American. You're
not one. You don't care about America. You don't care about Americans.
You're not America
He said in an interview once, "The number one guaranter of my
loyalty to the United States is Israel."
>> Go there. Go there. Then go home. What's stopping you?
Just don't come back next time. Next time you're in Israel hanging
out with the war criminal.
Next time you're over there hanging out and jacking off the war
criminal. Just
You and your wife and Israeli kids. I think she's Moroccan. Actually,
I don't think she's Israeli, but I think she's like Moroccan.
I don't This is like a weird
This is what I'm This is what I'm talking about. Eventually,
he's got to blow himself up. This is why you do Fabian tactics.
Okay? This guy can't stop himself.
He will eventually do it or he'll become boring enough that you'll
be able to criticize him for his hypocrisy in the same way. He'll
fade into the fabric.
He'll he'll fade into the fabric. He'll become a part of the
He'll become another [__] in the machine. You can
deal with him the same way you deal with anyone else. Or he'll
blow himself up. Just stay there next time. Seriously, out of
here. This is the United States. Anyway, in this exact moment
though, like all the momentum's behind Fentes, he should not
engage directly. I don't know if there's anything else from tonight.
We'll take a quick look.
Quick look. Quick look. Nah. Nah. Okay. I just wanted to see.
I think that's that might be it on the American first stuff.
There's one article I want to read real quick and then
we might be moving forward, moving on, moving upward.
Oh, hold on. Portoell is hooking me up with some with some more
clips. >> It is wild to me. You know, sometimes I I I when
I when I see people who spent years claiming to believe in something
and then just turn on a dime and and advocate exactly the opposite.
Even though I know people are are going to do that, sometimes
when it's this brazen, it actually surprises me that they can
do it without embarrassment because it's they don't even try
and hide it. You know, like all the people on the right who pretended
for so long to be be believers in free speech and opposed to
censorship when it was being done to them, turn around and cheer
for all sorts of punishments for people who criticize Israel,
be censored, be expelled, be deported,
you know, just like 4 seconds ago you were pretending to believe
in free speech. It was, you know, same thing when liberals were
rallying against the evils of the war and terror with George
Bush and then Barack Obama gets into office after vowing to uproot
it all and instead starts embracing the same policies, even extending
them. And then, you know, liberals, the same ones who were calling
George Bush a fascist and a for these policies are now defending
Obama for doing it. I remember the first time I watched these
kind of things. I was like, how can human beings
I'm not saying I'm surprised or I'm not so naive as to believe
that believe everyone's so principled. None of us is so completely
principled. We see things through through our own interest. >> Glenn
saying a lot of the right things.
>> We're willing to bend our own rules to advance our interest.
But you try and be consistent. And so that means you if you see
yourself so blatantly espousing exactly that which you condemned
a very short time ago. You question yourself and you say at least
maybe I should hide this better. And yet there's none of that.
[laughter] These are the people >> This is this is something
I really feel like in my soul sometimes. It's like, dude, I'm
kind of fine with you like lying to me if you could do it effectively,
but lying in such a brazen way that makes me think you think
I'm a
like that's offensive in and of itself. The lying is not even
the worst part. Now you are like spitting in my face and calling
me [__] with the bad lie you're doing. The you're
attempting to get by me like [__] you actually twice.
Lying is bad. Like it's really bad, but I can let go you. Hey,
you have some motive and you don't think I can handle the truth
or something, but like come up with a convincing lie. For [__]
sake, we're insisting for so long that
we can't have cancel culture. We can't get people fired for their
views. We can't exclude people or deplatform them because they
have views that we dislike. You shouldn't go around calling everybody
a racist and a bigot who disagrees with you. And now these are
exactly the tactics
that they use. That's why we started off showing you Ben Shapiro
with Jake Tapper on CNN screaming bigot and racist about Tucker
Carlson
something that >> oh I should go grab that >> deal
Bowman could have been doing >> and probably has done
>> or Robin D'Angelo
instead now it's Ben Shapiro probably will be Ted Cruz tomorrow
who's called Tucker an anti-ummit and a bigot count >> I
don't know how I do that constantly it's actually crazy >> here's
uh Mark Leavvin who's been a favorite on Fox News for a long
time
a leading conservative voice. Here is his
uh view about Tucker Carlson as well as other Israel critics
like not just Nick Fentes but Steve Bannon
who's also questioning the
uh US support uh US relationship with Israel and listen to
the words he chooses to describe people who are opposed to the
country he most loves to Israel. So, I think depending on what
happens in New Jersey and potentially New York City, you're going
to see the the radicalization of the Democrat party. You're going
to see significant numbers of Democrats voting for it.
>> Not overwhelming number, but significant
And now you know why I'm fighting like hell against the Tucker
Carlson's and the Fuentes and the Bannons and the others who
are myopic who uh they're dancing with and Stalin and
bigots and racists and segregationists,
Christian haters and haters is a prescription for
massive electoral defeat. What? What did Cherry Everything Cherry
Cherry's just like Ben Shapiro, okay? She just spreads propaganda
in the chat. She just lies and spreads nothing happened. She
just spreads propaganda and it's [__] up. >> From
which I don't think we'll ever
be able to recover. >> You're a racist. You're a bigot.
You're a I mean, isn't that [laughter]
>> Wait, is is Glenn doing the voice now?
You're actually a racist. You're oasis and you're a bigot and
you're you're >> exactly what the American right >> oh
god liberals were constantly saying about their political enemies.
Now you have Marin and Ben Shapiro
saying exactly that. Here's Ben Shapiro when the interview between
Tucker and
uh Nick Fentes came out and then the head of the Heritage Foundation
Kevin Roberts defended Tucker Carlson. Ben Shapiro had this whole
tweet and video that went along with it that all the Israel supporters
cited as kind of the the the gospel of the pro-Israel
view and he said no to the Gropers, no to cowards like Tucker
Carlson who normalized their trash. No to all this and then of
course no to bigotry
and anti-arocratic horseshit. No. So no to bigotry. [laughter]
>> What was that about open sewage? Was wasn't there a
quote about open sewage? bombing and living at open sewage. >> Sudden
somehow Carlson has become a bigot overnight for his steadfast
opposition to what Israel is doing in Gaza.
And
>> dude, I don't even think Tucker opposed the war in Gaza.
I don't even think he opposed the operation into Gaza. I feel
like he just was like, "Hey, probably bombing Iran is like way
too far." Like, hey, isn't it crazy to go all the way to bombing
Iran >> and US support for it on America first ground?
This is all the prohibition.
>> It's this is the funniest part, Jay. Goon arc is that
like they've actually somehow immunized themselves against calling
Nick out and it's happened so
like just remember
I want I want to say that wasn't it 2023 when we had Alex Jones?
Yay. Nick Fuentes.
Wasn't that 2023? Was it even 2022? It's 2023.
It's 2022. Okay, it's 2022.
But like even back then people were calling this out, right?
Like it was like supposed to be the end even though it wasn't
really.
So like things have changed entirely. >> Discourse is about
here's >> been three years. >> It's been 3 years
since we met Net and Yohoo.
Net and Yohoo, Alex and Yohoo >> as well. And this was
Ben Shapiro
uh in 2010.
and he eventually
said that he regretted this tweet.
But this is exactly the worldview that Tucker Carlson was just
describing lies at the heart of the Israel project and the way
that they treat Palestinians. These are the people who are claiming
Ben doesn't regret this because he disavows it. Ben regrets this
because optically it's being used against him in the future.
Ben
Ben doesn't think this is the wrong thing to tweet. If Ben thought
this was the wrong thing to tweet, he would have condemnation
for Benjamin Netanyahu. Okay,
that's there's just no other way to look at the situation.
If Ben thought this was truly wrong, he would have criticism
for Netanyahu for people for Arabs as though they mean this little
that they they're basically not human. They're not capable of
the same things other humans are capable of. >> They're
so offended by bigotry. They're
>> # settlements rock >> offended by racism.
[laughter] >> These are the views on which Ben Shapiro
was. This is what he said. Quote, "Israelis like to build, Arabs
like to bomb crap and live in open sewage. This is not a difficult
issue." Is that somebody that you think credibly is driven by
anti-racism and an attempt to root out bigotry wherever it's
found? Or is that somebody driven by
supremacy and loyalty to Israel?
to ask the question is is to answer it.
Here's the free press. Uh, bro, what are you guys posting in
the Discord right now?
What are you guys?
What can you not Can you guys chill in the Discord? Like, this
is unacceptable. Okay,
mods,
take his perms. Mods,
get him out of here. Okay, get him out. Get him out of here.
He read one. Richard Hanani article
and these are the memes getting posted. It's [__]
crazy. Unacceptable.
>> Whoops. Uh, get me back onto Glenn. Glenn. Glenn. No.
Barry Weiss's rag
>> and [laughter] >> the free press. >> She
and the free press published this article on November 2nd. Ted
Cruz. The fight against anti-semitism is quote existential.
The combative Texas senator talks to the free press about Nick
Fentes, Tucker Carlson, and the rise of quote billious bigotry
on the right.
It's just they sound exactly like
never Trumpers, never Trumpers, never Trumpers. Ted Cruz as a
Hispanic man out here saying like
out here criticizing Donald Trump for being a bigot and then
suddenly like getting on his knees for him once Trump wins the
election. Especially once Trump like continues to do well in
their minds
governing in the first in the first term he had. Right. >> Abram
Ki Abram Kendy and uh Robin D'Angelo
exactly like them. You wind these people up
and they will scream not racism and bigot at you if you just
screw with them on Israel. Oh, he's doing anti-woke. Oh, well,
I mean, he was doing it earlier, too.
This is the programming. Will we get even a tacit announce a
tacit acknowledgement that Yeah, Nick Fentes does think is awesome.
And that's kind of weird. Will there be anything? Will there
be a little bit? At least a little bit. Glenn, a tiny bit. Come
on. You got to at least do it a little bit. What the [__]
are you doing if you're
h They're just sorting out. They're just like they're just calling
people racists who disagree with them. Meanwhile, Nick Fentes,
the guy that they're criticizing. Oh, hold on. I didn't turn
my keyboard back on. Wait, I did. Hold on. Does my keyboard not
work now?
No, it does work. Okay. Last Friday >> Cherry almost Cherry
almost me there. My keyboard works just fine. >> That's
a epic song.
Epic. Last Friday
tabletops and we
think we
>> Hey, if you can hear me, please.
>> Huh?
Curious.
>> That was the clip. Uh, that was that was the clip right
there.
>> Get back to work, Matt Walsh. Get back to work, Matt
Walsh.
>> This is all to say nothing of the discourse that >> you
find a new Fentes meme. Uh, yeah, I've got a lot of Fuentes memes.
I don't know if you know that. Zuran Mandani
where
somehow
this very kind of standard
DSA leftist from Queens who emerge in the same political climate
and environment as AOC this kind of politics. He's a
>> Wait, wait, wait, hold on. Wait, wait, wait. Did Jay
Sock just pull up the last Friday night clip again? >> I
mean, oh no. I mean, [laughter] no.
Oh no.
Oh no. [laughter] No. No.
That's terrible, huh?
You hate to see it.
>> Yeah. I hate to see it.
>> Okay. All right. I can I can do this all night. Okay.
I can do this all night. >> To the LGBT agenda, trans rights
and every other kind of He called the NYPD anti-quer just a few
years ago.
his wife works.
She walks around in mini skirts and standard western clothing.
They're just a very standard
young left liberal queen's couple.
>> But because he's Muslim and a credit of Israel, it just
became standard. >> Actually, that that leads into now
I just remembered the other sneaker clip I wanted to watch was
him describing mom Donnie and his wife's first date.
Hold on. I actually need to go grab this other sneaker clip.
This is a good clip. It's a very funny clip. Hold on. Where's
it at? There it is. >> 6 feet good personality and stuff
like that. She's swiping. She's looking for a guy who says 6
feet good personality and stuff like that. She sees a guy, right?
She thinks she's going to go on a date. Maybe they go to They
probably go to dinner at some like cool restaurant that Zoran
knows, right? Definitely some like some ethnic food. He's like,
"I know there's good African restaurant in Harlem. We can get
some African food." And so they take the train, right? Cuz he
doesn't want to spend too much. He's broke. He probably lives
uh he probably lives in he lives in Atoria. She lives in Bushwick.
It's such a New York love story. A Bushwick girl and an Atoria
guy. She brings a little joint in that container in her purse.
She shows up 15 minutes late. She's wearing a cool outfit that
she thrifted. And where does she thrift that outfit? There's
uh Elra Vintage. She's wearing a jacket from Lrain Vintage. She's
got good style. She like she follows Rihanna on Instagram. She
knows some things. Maybe she's listening to Brat on her headphones.
Have you tried jolaf rice? And you eat with your hands. That's
Zoran. That's Zoran Riz to try to get [laughter] a liberal girl.
Yeah, that's authentic. You're supposed to eat it with your hands.
Oh yeah, cool. Yeah. Yeah. Oh my god, this guy's poor. But then
she tries the jolaf rice. It's a little spicy. She doesn't finish
it because she's a girl and she doesn't want to fart in front
of him. Yeah, it was good. I'm just so full. And then maybe he
calls an Uber back instead of taking a train. He already showed
that he's a workingass guy. You don't need to take the train.
He calls an Uber and they're going back. He's saying he's just
gonna stop at hers. He's gonna make a stop at Atoria and then
go and then go to Bushwick, right? Because he's in Harlem for
the Africa food. He can make a stop at Atoria. East kind of north
and then it'll go down. But really, he's hoping I'm going to
take that. I'm I'm going to take this down. I just got a Joel
price. >> I'm going to steal this this meme from him by
the way. Sound >> was cracking jokes. Huh? I showed us
some good music. We have some inside jokes and we made fun of
Trump. I'm going to take this down.
They make a stop. Oh, wait. Wait, no, he lives in a story. She
lives in Bushwick. So, he's even he's going the long way, but
he wants to make sure that he gets she she gets home safe. That's
why he's going in a circle. All right. Away from the African
rice. They get to Kajusco Street. Wow, that was such a good time.
That was This was so fun. Do you want to come see my place? I
have some plants.
>> Yeah, I'll see those [__] [laughter] plants.
I'll see those plants. I want to make sure you get home safe,
too. I'm going to walk you to the door. I don't want to I want
to make sure that these And you can't say crackheads like everybody
else. I was going to say, I want to make sure these white supremacists
don't attack you. the white man. [laughter] I want to make sure
these Trump supp >> It's like It's like the uh It's like
the vine boom. Okay. It's like a new vine boom. It's not quite
as cringe and run >> Borders aren't lurking, but you just
want to make sure you get Okay, so he's walking her up. He gets
to the brownstone. She probably lives on the third floor. Third
floor walk up. No elevator. It's Bushwick. She takes off her
shoes. Probably from an Indian Arabic. You know, you know better.
>> I feel like this is like a super New York story and
I I can like identify that Sneo loves New York right now. Sneo
loves being back in New York. He He like regrets every second
he like lives in New York again. He just totally regrets
being from uh or ever spending time in Miami. Just hates >> better.
And they make a joke about it. >> Yeah, I know. I know.
>> These are the girls plants, not not Zoron's plants,
just to be clear. >> Take my shoes off cuz we're third
worlders. We're third world. We're just the same. We don't bring
our shoes inside like those white people. You know when white
people in movies, they kick their feet up and keep their shoes
on in the bed. Ew. Haha. [__] white people. They're
laughing. She sparks the joint that's in her purse. They forgot
about the plant. That's what it was about. She was going to show
her cool plants that are in the window sill right by the fire
escape. She sparks it up. They're smoking. Uh, let's go outside.
I don't want my roommate to smell the weed. She gets asthma.
They're sitting on the fire escape. Smoking a smoking a joint.
They're talking now. The hinge date's going well. It was just
supposed to be some dopamine. And she hasn't even texted a group
chat in 30 minutes. She hasn't said, "This guy's weird." All
of her friends have her location. She didn't even check it once.
She's laughing. He's vibing. He's charming. You're doing the
smile. He's doing a smile. Go,
>> dude. That goofy ass smile is like why he got elected.
You know that, right? You all know that. That goofy Doron smile.
I keep I keep listening to him talk and I'm like, why did people
think he's charismatic? Why did Why does anyone think this guy
is charismatic? He's kind of when I hear him talk. And then I
saw his smile and I'm like, "Oh, this goofy goober smile is like
a 100% of why he got elected. He just smiles. He's just this
goofy ass goober in his smile." And everybody's like, "Okay,
I trust this guy."
Unironically, a little bit. He kind of smile like Pisco. Like
I see Pisco here. And it's not in a racist way at all. I swear
to God. It's like this goofy goober Pisco smile that's happening.
It's there, man.
It's real. This is like every element of him being charismatic
is just this smile. That's it. People are like, "Oh, this guy
looks cool. This guy I'd hang out with this guy. I'd smoke a
joke with I'd smoke a joint with this guy for sure. For for sure.
For sure. For sure. For sure." I didn't even think that could
be racist. Well, he's Ugandan and Pisco's from Peru. So, I don't
know. I don't know. Couple years later, she's the first lady
in NEW YORK CITY. THAT'S HOW IT COULD HAPPEN NOWADAYS. That's
a New York love story. That's a Hinge should be using that as
the subway ads instead of the other cornball they have now.
>> Oh, Sneo just gave them a million dollar idea though
for Hinge. Hinge would definitely pay for that story.
Just as Sneo told it. All right. He's out here. He's out here
just dropping million ideas for nothing. Just for the love of
the game. All right.
Where were we? Glenn Greenwald. Yeah, Glenn Greenwald mentioned
uh Zoron and his his wife.
language in ant pros conservative politics to call him a jihadist,
someone who wants to implement Sharia law. I mean, it's just
a joke.
>> The leftist, the the Democratic Socialist of America
approved candidate who wants to implement Sharia law, >> but
they look at him, they see this
and so they automatically say, "Oh, that's a jihadist."
suggesting he would be happy with terrorism.
Do you think these people have any credibility at all to pretend
that what offends them about Tucker Carlson and Nick Fentes is
the fact that they're racists and bigots?
Do you think these people have any credibility at all to pretend
that that's what literally all Ben has to do to get a little
bit of moral credibility back is say that Netanyahu is a war
criminal. He's a wararmonger. He's a war criminal. He should
be driven from power. Just say it, Ben. Just say it. is driving
this. >> Here's Ted Cruz on Fox News talking about Mandani.
>> Look, last night was a disaster. It was an electoral
blowout.
Uh the results in New Jersey were disastrous. The results in
Virginia were terrible. The results in in New York. Comrade Mandami
is the face of the Democrat party. We have a an actual communist
jihadist. And it's important to note Mandami is not a socialist.
He is a full-on communist. He has called for seizing the means
of production in our economy. He is a >> All right, I don't
really care about all the communist stuff. I mean, it's a joke.
He's a Bernie Sanders
democratic socialist. He doesn't say he's a communist. He calls
himself a democratic socialist same way Bernie Sanders does.
There's his wife, by the way, on the Fox News screen. Does that
look like a a wife of a Sharia law jihadist?
But again, this is all grounded in exactly the sort of racism
and bigotry that they're now pretending to be so offended by
in order to kick Tucker Carlson out of the conservative movement
here. Uh, speaking of somebody who
spouts racism on a on a regular basis is somebody who
is one of Donald Trump's closest confidants or a loomer.
I mean, she everyone knows if she goes on to Twitter and starts
attacking someone who's an official in the Trump administration,
even high up people in the national security world or wherever,
she calls up Donald Trump and those people get fired. She's incredibly
influential with Donald Trump. She's one of his closest confidants.
>> I'm taking um what's his name? He's not on the screen,
but I'm going to put them back on. Hold on.
Total Jany death. I'm going to take them put them back on the
screen. Give me a second. I paused to let them know. Hold on.
How do I get rid of them?
Where is this guy? There he is. Okay, you should be back on the
screen if you talk now. >> You won't find anybody more
overtly racist than Laura Loomer. Overtly more bigoted than Laura
Loomer, >> dude. Yeah, that's the other thing. Oh my god,
these people are racist against people. And then Laura Loomer's
out here saying like this. >> But the bro, Laura Loomer
is racist against people. Are you kidding me? You kidding me?
Hold on. Show me the tweet. Where's the tweet?
Where's the tweet? I can't find it, but I'll find it. >> Difference
between Laura Loomer and Nick Fentes, at least one of the differences,
the determinative difference as to why
conservatives are insisting that Nick Fuentes be banished, but
Laura Loomer has a
open door in an open line with Donald Trump is because Laura
Lumer loves and supports Israel and Nick Fuentes doesn't. >> Your
hair and your eyes look so good. You're like beautiful. >> Thank
you. It's like an Aryan degenerate
>> Thank you. >> I love it. >> Thank you. Thank
you. You're Aryan, too. >> I know. But I'm
>> It's okay. >> Hate me. [laughter] >> It's
fine. >> The all right people want to put me in a gas chamber.
>> Dude, she's just drunk. It's some like conservative
party >> cuz they're obsessed with the
>> I don't I think they're just memeing on you. But it's
okay. >> They're just jealous because I have big
>> Yes, that's what it is. You got it. >> I'm going
to tell you a secret. Like you have so many people in this movement
who preach child life for like people on the side and like cheating
on their >> That's so bad,
>> dude. She's like totally
>> What the She just totally wasted. Crazy. >> Here's
the sort of thing. Laura, >> oh yeah, I forgot that it
was Mike Ma says September 8th, 2024. If Kla Harris wins, the
White House will smell a curry and White House speeches will
be facilitated via a call center and the American people will
only be able to convey their feedback through a customer satisfaction
survey at the end of the call that nobody will understand. Even
with Elon Musk's X,
the tweet was uh the visibility of that tweet was li >> I'm
I'm actually That's okay. She's like super disappoint. That's
okay.
because decided this post may violate ex's rules against hateful
conduct.
>> Laura Lmer has been on a crusade for the last several
months to insist that Muslims be banned from all aspects of American
life, not be allowed to vote, not be able to hold elective office.
Here's Laura Loomer's 25th. Quote, "We have Sharia law all over
America. It's time for the GOP to start cracking down on Islam
in America before we turn into the UK or France. We need real
leadership on this issue now or the Muslim Brotherhood will take
over our country by 2032. Muslims should also be banned from
holding elective office in America since their allegiance to
Sharia law is incompatible with the US Constitution. Does anybody
believe that a political movement that places Laurel Lubber in
an extremely influential
as she says things like that is a movement that actually is
so passionately devoted to
anti-racism or being against bigotry? No. Obviously not >> kicking
anybody out who has any connection with bigotry and racism because
they're just so deeply offended by it. Ain't nobody believed
that. >> Here's Bill Aman on November 5th
after calling Don Mandami every name that he could think of.
Says Jordan Mandami. Congratulations on the win. Dude, this is
Why can't Laura Loomer be normal in any direction?
Like just in every direction. She's totally abnormal. She's a
complete freak in every direction.
Bill Aman, the most the the
most well-known,
most significant sufferer of JN on the entire planet, goes, "Hey,
Zoron, congrats on the win. Um, I'll help you make NYC better."
AND LAURA LUM, NEVER CONGRATULATED JIHADI.
He's going to kill you, Bill. Now you have big responsibility.
If I can help, let me know. And Laura Loomer replies, never congratulated
Jihadi. Moa man Mandani wants you dead because you are an American,
Vakman. You can't work with
Here's a tweet from Colin Rug who said, "Just in, New York City
mayoral candidate Zan Mandani blames bomb threats at polling
places on President Trump." And Laura Loomer replies, "His Muslim
voters probably called in the threats."
Here's Laura Loomer on November 4th. This is all just in the
last week or two. Replying to a similar post like the one of
above, she wrote, quote, "The Muslims can't think of a better
way for the Muslims to celebrate the victory of a Muslim mayoral
candidate today than by committing an ISIS attack in New York
City." If if you want to pretend that you're offended by the
alleged bigotry of Tucker Carlson or of Candace Owens or of Nick
Fentes
or Marrick Taylor Green
or Steve Bannon or Matt Gates because they criticize Israel and
yet you're fine with a movement that elevates someone like Laura
Loomer saying those things. Just expect to be laughed at. Don't
expect to be taken seriously.
And as I said, there are Israel critics who just outright admit
that they don't care at all about racism. All they care about
is whether somebody supports Israel. We showed you that John
Thor's tweet. There's a similar Ben Shapiro tweet. I think we
have that on the screen where here Ben Shapiro 2015.
Uh this is when Anne Coulter posted a bunch of tweets about that
were widely condemned as anti-Semitic. Ben Bener said regarding
Anne Coulter and her tweets
about they're awful and nonsensical. and culture is also super
pro-Israel and always has been. So I won't lose sleep.
we don't actually care about racism or
What we care about is if you're pro-Israel or not. And if you're
pro-Israel, we don't care. You can be as bigoted as you want.
You're totally fine and welcome in our movement.
You can be totally bigoted against any group as long as you're
pro- Israel. That's the >> God. He just He gets it. He
gets it. What? For the first time ever, I feel like Glenn Greenwald
kind of gets it a little bit, which I'll be real kind of concerning
to me in the first place. All right, that I'm I'm listening.
I'm like, "Yes, you understand." But I'll think about it. I'll
ruminate on the fact that Glenn gets it. No, not a lot of other
Well, actually, it seems like basically everybody gets it once
um
once they understand. Okay. Got to help people understand. Let's
see here. Test. That's the determining factor. >> BB Poison.
Not a fan of plastic surgery. got it. >> And the fact that
they're so honest about it at unguarded moments is incredibly
valuable because I can show you all the proof
that this is all a pretext and a fraud
to expel and destroy Israel critics
by pretending that what they're really concerned about is
But if you're electing the Randy Fines of the world and having
President Trump campaign for him
after he openly said, "Haha, go dead and babies. Give me more
of those. We want more of those."
Bro, don't even think about
I still haven't seen that Randy Fine tweet.
That should be like disqualifying for office. Like you actually
should be thrown out of office. You shouldn't hold public office
in the United States if you tweet crazy like that.
That's so much worse than like George Face lasers even. That's
so inhuman and disgusting,
bro. What? Lindsey Graham almost Lindsey Graham saves himself
by not explicitly cheering about kids dying. But the Lindsey
Graham like quote, "Oh, we're all right people. We're lowering
your
off turning around and then pretending ah
Don't even think about turning around and then pretending that
the reason you're after Nick Fuentes and Tucker
is because you're so deeply concerned about bigotry and racism.
Everyone sees through this.
Everyone understands exactly what's going on. This is a war that
conservatives who are pro-Israel are losing to conservatives
who are finally opening their eyes. And in fact, people across
the political spectrum finally understand the true face of Israel,
the true extent of American subservience to Israel, the true
extent of the cost to Americans and to their country, the United
States, as a result of that subservience to Israel. >> These
are like the last gasps
of a desperate panic movement, but they still build a great deal
of power.
>> Wow. Oh man,
I just noticed um there's this tweet exchange. Okay. got sent
this tweet exchange
says uh Hassan
I don't even know what this is. What was Hassan on earlier? Glenn's
got it basically just hey no more no more moral condescension
from Israel firsters who haven't disavowed Benjamin Netanyahu.
I I think every disavow of Benjamin Netanyahu that happens absent
a disavow of the the country's actions is performative. Let's
start with just disavowing the open and like the open war criminal
who puts people in his cabinet who are so like psyched to ethnically
cleanse Gaza, right? How about that? We can start there and then
if you've got anything to do after that,
we'll see. Uh Hassan [__] there needs to be a more
robust response from Democrats so people know Trump's claim he
would only deport violent criminals was a lie. And there were
people that genuinely thought they genuinely believed that Donald
Trump was actually excising the the the violent criminals. And
the only reason why people are led to believe this lie aside
from the faucet of misinformation that comes from independent
outlets on the right and also Fox News as well is because there
is no robust response from the Democratic party that says that's
a lie. That's a lie. Undocumented migrants in this country are
responsible for a lower rate of per capita crime than natural-born
US citizens are. If you pair that up with documented migrants,
it's negligible. It is marginal. And they're hyperfocusing on
it specifically because this is a vulnerable population that
is easy to target and it's easy to ridicule and there is not
enough of a robust defense mechanism out there. And that's the
reason why people end up believing this and then they get shocked
when it's actually implemented. I talk to those people every
day and there were people that genuinely thought they genuinely
believed that Donald Trump was actually excising the the the
violent criminals. And the only reason why people are led to
believe this lie aside from the faucet of misinformation that
comes from independent outlets on the right and also Fox News
as well is
>> Dude, sorry. I'm reading I'm reading over here. Uh
Kilo got absolutely bodied by Tactical Templar on Twitter. Hold
on.
Just in Trump administration asked the Supreme Court to stop
by 9:30 tonight the court orders requiring payment of full November
SNAP benefits. By the way, I think this went through and I think
was it Katanji? Was it Katanji Brown Jackson who put it through
which kind of sucks. I'm guessing that this is just blatantly
like constitutionally you got to let it happen.
Am I Am I the only person who who read this? I think this popped
up on my phone. Let me check the NY Time Dimes site. Jesus.
No, it's not anything this time.
We're good. We're good. Uh temporary ruling Katanji Brown Jackson.
Temporary ruling by Justice Katanji Brown Jackson blocking a
lower court order to fully fund the aid added to the uncertainty
around the nation's largest anti-hunger
unlucky when when it's the most recently appointed far-left judge
on the court. I think that was the explicit intent with
I tend to think like, nah, that [__] was probably
unconstitutional to stop him. I think he probably just had the
right to do that, right? I think he probably just had the explicit
right to do that and you're probably not winning in the court.
If she just came in unilaterally by herself, was like, "Yeah,
I got to I got to let him do this." She's preventing it from
going to the Supreme Court so that a lower liberal court deals
with it. Oh, is she just Wait,
so she temporarily blocks it and kicks it back to the lower court.
Is that all it is? I thought she was temporarily blocking it
until the Supreme Court could hear it. But if she's just temporarily
blocking it and sending it back to the lower court, I understand.
Where was I? I was talking about Kilo getting bodied by Tactical
Templar.
Okay. Tactical Templar responds to Hutch says, "I refuse to believe
you are one of the people so shockingly that you don't realize
that the Democrats are holding up the opening of the government."
Kayla responds, "You realize that a shutdown is because Congress
is unable to compromise, right? If Republicans wanted to end
the shutdown, they could easily just adopt the Democrats counter
proposal. The Senate actually and it's because Democrats are
demanding things. the
I mean, okay,
this referencing
the same B like uh this is a superset supererset.
This is a sub the Yeah, Congress is a super set. Yeah. Contains
the Senate.
Jesus. The Senate actually and it's because Democrats are demanding
things and the American people sorry that the American people
do not want. It's a poison pill. The answer is no. Republicans
should end the filibuster and end the shutdown.
Why do do you think Americans are clamoring for an end to premium
tax credits under the ACA?
Is that what the people clamor clamor for? That's what the the
people really want. I guess this Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on. Got to go up a little bit more. Next kilo response.
The Senate is a chamber of Congress. They proposed the CR for
the spending in the first place. The continuing resolution. What
do you think the Democrats are demanding? The Senate is a chamber
of Congress, but we don't refer to it as such. We refer to the
three branches separately. House, Senate, and Executive. You
know, the classic three branches of government, the House, the
Senate, and the
Definitely not the judicial, the congressional, and the executive.
Right. Definitely not. It's definitely the three branches, the
House, the Senate, and the Executive.
>> Legislative, congressional is what I said, but legislative.
Yes, it's legislative. Listen, I'm Canadian and I know what the
three are. >> I I know what the legislative branch is.
I might not know the word they use for it, but I know it is one
of the three
Anyway, you can refer to the House or or the Senate as Congress.
Like, it is still Congress that's doing it.
They're both Yeah, it's like not wrong. Anyway, I just I don't
know if people on Reddit think this makes you seem smart, but
it's just incorrect. The extension of Obamacare add-ons during
CO were never intended to be permanent as well as funding for
millions of criminal illegal aliens to get funding as well. Under
what? What?
The answer is no. They will get none of it, brother. There are
two chambers of Congress, the House and the Senate. Both have
to advance the budget, advance budget legis legislation to reopen
the government. When the government shuts down, it is because
of Congress. The executive is a branch of the federal government
alongside the judicial and the legislative.
Congress is part of the legislative branch. The executive is
completely separate. This is also literally third grade level
material. Very embarrassing stuff from you. You're also just
completely wrong about the disagreements over funding. But based
on your responses here, I don't actually think you'll be capable
of tracking what's actually going on, so I won't try. Now, prepare
for it cuz
Ko's about to get nuked. Uh, you of Reddit, insufferable, ignorant,
and nate. Also, why haven't you uploaded any videos to your YouTube
recently? He's done. He's He's Kilo lost. Kilo's
Where? Where are the videos? Kilo. Kilo, I thought you had a
video on the way. Tactical Templar actually owned you. Wait,
where who quote tweeted this guy?
We clap for this guy.
Working on one now. Stay tuned. God, you love to see it. Wait,
what's the clip from Tactical Templar from Shimu? >> I
love Tactical Templar. I love Merido grape.
There's no such thing. >> This guy's on one. Okay. What
were we watching? The Hassan clip. I was just going to go through.
Apparently, somebody came back
quote tweeted this says, "Ridiculous for Hassan to criticize
Democrats for not having a united messaging struct messaging
structure to combat Republicans lies when he is one of the biggest
peddlers of anti-democrat propaganda in the country. Who said
both sides were the same? Who said you shouldn't vote for Kamla?
You."
And then Hassan says, "You're smoking
But hold on, there's more. But wait, your words, not mine. Would
be Democrats, if they were in charge right now, would be doing
100%
the exact same thing, one to one. >> So I think with regards
to Gaza, this is Hassan's point. I think this is supposed to
just be Gaza,
>> Make no mistake. Anyone who tries to tell you that Kla
Harris will be different is a delusional [__] Do
not listen to them.
Uh which to be honest, I
I do think there's like at least hope with Kamla. Okay. I don't
know if Kamala would be better. I don't know how like compromised
people are, but
this one is uh causes the issue where I believe this the most.
Unfortunately,
this is about Israel. It'll also be the last time I dignify you
with a response. Have fun with the pro-Genocide coalition you're
trying to build.
Destiny is a great one. He's right now doing a series of conversations
with all the DNC candidates. What happened to that? January 22nd,
2025.
and then did we have another response? I think I think she kept
responding, but I don't I don't think I tracked anything further
here. Hold on. She quote back. Nope. Not that we see. Destiny
quoted.
I I just think it's very funny, dude. How the I can't believe
today
we got the Megan Kelly Megan Kelly played the GTA clip. Good
to see Ben Shapiro. See the GTA clip.
Wait, what is this?
This is racism almost certainly
this is going to be about race mixing. Misogynation clip coming
up. [laughter] I saw a white woman, a black dude. Misogynation
clip 100%. >> We'll save that. You know what? I like that.
That's nice. I'm out. I don't need to kill anybody here. Well,
I spoke too soon.
Uh I think with that, are we done for the day? I think we are
done.
I think we're done here. Let me see. What do we got? We got time.
No, we're out of time. Okay,
we're out of time. Supporter call. I think I might opt out tonight.
I'm like, honestly, I got to go to bed. But should be back tomorrow.
Should be back tomorrow night. Should be having a good time.
All right.
Let's see who's online.
Okay. Where are we going? I don't know what the [__]
Krontos is doing. Is that Slicker on Krontos' stream? I'll I'll
host uh Krontos here. Have a good night, guys. We'll be back
tomorrow.
Bye-bye. Oh, I can't host. Why can't I host Corantos?
Can I not host Corantos?
What? What?
Why you not letting me host Karantos?
Oh, am I banned from his chat? Uh, that's complete. I better
not be banned from his chat. The There's no way. WHY AM I BANNED
FROM HIS CHAT? I DIDN'T do anything. That's
Well, I wanted to raid him. Now I'm like I guess I'm just raiding
Malik. Like basically just Malik. He's like the only person I
know who's online. There we go. We're going to Malik. Have a
good night, guys. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye.